foreign
says without data you are blind and deaf
right in the middle of the freeway which
highlights data's critical role in the
Modern Life data shapes mobile ads
Investments and travel recommendations
based on our online activity data-driven
decision making supported by Ai and data
crunching tools empowers informed
choices as a result the IT industry
seeks professionals skill and data
handling and Analysis with Microsoft
Excel in high demand simply learn offers
a comprehensive Microsoft Excel course
curated by experts to match industry
standards it covers Basics advanced
concepts Excel VBA data analysis and
visualization time series analysis of
trending projects helps build a strong
data analysis portfolio the course also
addresses common data analyst interview
questions this course will will open the
doors for various data enthusiasts
however if you are looking to get
certified then hey there we are here
with an amazing course through which you
can catch the eye of top Recruiters in
the industry allow me to introduce
post-graduate program in data analytics
by simply learn just
look at the features followed by the
skills you will gain through this course
some key features of this comprehensive
program includes exclusive hackathons
and anything sessions by IBM eight times
higher live in action in live online
classes by industry experts Capstone
from three domains and 14 plus data
analytics projects with industry data
sets from Google Play Store Lyft World
Bank Etc masterclass was delivered by
Purdue faculty and IBM experts simply
learns job assist helps you to get
noticed by top hiring companies and much
much more it is well said when skills
Empower possibilities flourish to grab
the opportunities gain skills like data
analytics statistical analysis using
Excel data analysis Python and R data
visualization Tableau and power bi and
much more so what are you waiting for
hurry up and enroll Now find the the
course Link in the description box
before we begin consider subscribing to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply learn
so without any further Ado let's begin
over to our tutors what is Microsoft
Excel so Microsoft Excel is a software
product designed and developed by
Microsoft store and data in an organized
way that is rows and columns
and Microsoft Excel is also capable to
manipulate data through some
mathematical operations
followed by that Microsoft Excel is also
used to extract the insights from the
data and represent it in the form of
visually appealing graphs and charts now
we have a basic understanding or an
overview of what a Microsoft Excel
software product is
now moving ahead we will understand the
fundamentals of Microsoft Excel
so following arts and fundamentals that
you need to know before getting started
with Microsoft Excel so basically when
you install the Microsoft Office in your
computer you will have various Microsoft
products out of which Microsoft Excel is
one of the product so we will be dealing
exactly with that particular product
that is Microsoft Excel so when you get
started with Microsoft Excel this is
what you will see in the first page so
this particular page is called as
Microsoft Excel home page where you will
be having various varieties of sheets
Microsoft Excel will give you some
suggestions based on the type of sheet
you want to work with we will see this
in a better way through the Practical
session so once you get started with the
sheet you will have some more options so
this particular option is called as the
toolbar menu you will have the file home
insert raw paste layout formulas data
review View and help so these are the
tools that you will be using to work on
your data using Microsoft Excel
furthermore we have a toolbar ribbon so
when you select sum or the other option
from the file home insert draw page
layout formulas data review View and
help buttons you will have a ribbon so
for example you can see that I have
selected the Home Tool here so when I
press on the Home Tool this is the
ribbon which Microsoft Excel gives me so
this ribbon has some options in it which
can perform various operations now in a
further a more detailed way we will have
toolbar groups so when you see in the
previous slide we have a complete
toolbar ribbon so this particular ribbon
is segmented into groups so you can see
the first group as paste Cut Copy format
painter etc etc and the second group is
the font the size of the font and to
increase the size of the font to
decrease the size of the phone bold
italic underline etc etc and here you
can see the text alignment so each and
every group has separate functions
so each set is called as a group
and I think you can see a small Arrow
option over here so this Arrow option is
used into the toolbar groups when the
group is not able to fit all the
operations or all the functionalities in
one single provided section so when you
click on this particular Arrow Mark you
will have another dialog box so this is
called toolbar more options so you can
see that when I clicked on this icon you
can see a new dialog box which opens me
a new set of operations which are not
able to be fit in this particular group
so we will also see more about this in a
better way in the Practical session now
moving forward we have cell and address
so when you open a Microsoft Excel sheet
you can find boxes so each and every box
is named as a cell and each cell has its
own address for example the highlighted
cell over here has an address B3 so B is
the column name and three is the room
name
and apart from that you can have the
sheet tracker in the bottom left corner
of the Excel sheet where you can
navigate through different sheets
and in the bottom right corner you have
an option of increasing or decreasing
the sheet size so these are the basic
fundamentals of Microsoft Excel that you
need to keep in mind before getting
started so we will have more on this in
the Practical session if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
so now we enter the demo inventory in
Microsoft Excel so we will be using
Microsoft Excel to create a sheet of the
employees in a company
so basically an employee in a company
has employee ID name and designation
salary etc etc so we will be trying to
create the same table using Microsoft
Excel but before that let us understand
the fundamentals of Microsoft Excel
through the Practical demo first so I
have started my Microsoft Excel and this
is how the home page of Microsoft Excel
looks like so you have a blank workbook
over here if you want to create a new
workbook you can select new Option so
Excel will provide you with various
variety of sheets you can see money in
Excel adjustable meeting agenda
streaming show list small business cash
flow and many more if you're not able to
find what you're looking for then you
always have an option of selecting the
particular type of sheet what you're
looking for so you have various options
if it's business if it's personal if
it's planners and trackers list budgets
charts etc etc so let's imagine that you
wanted something from business so just
by clicking at business option the Excel
will load a variety of sheets related to
business options so this might take a
while so you can see that the Excel is
loading few types of sheets
so you can see that Excel has provided
us with some online varieties of sheets
for example any calendar business
expenses Channel marketing budget budget
summary report blue product list etc etc
you can see construction proposal
invoice your name and Excel has got it
so Excel will provide you with some
variety of options based on your
requirement now for this session let's
get started with a blank workbook which
looks something like this since this
tutorial is based on the fundamentals
we'll go with the blank workbook
now over here you can see the toolbar
that we discussed earlier that has the
file home insert draw base layout
formulas data review View and help so
this is the toolbar and under the
toolbar I have selected home and you can
see this is the particular ribbon what
we discussed about this particular
ribbon belongs to home page and when you
select file option you'll get back to
home and if you select insert option
you'll have another different ribbon
with different groups etc etc so every
particular tool has different ribbons in
them and remember the extra options that
we discussed when you press over this
Arrow key this is it so when you press
the arrow key you'll have few more
settings which cannot be fit in this
particular section of groups so you can
have some variety of options over here
of changing the font changing some FX to
the text font size and font style etc
etc apart from this we have also
discussed about the cells in every sheet
so this particular cell has an address
so you can see the address over here
which is B3 so B happens to be the
column name and three happens to be the
row name now we also had a discussion
about the shear tracker right now we
just have one sheet if you want multiple
sheets you can just feel free to select
on the plus option which will always
create you some extra sheets
and you can navigate through sheets just
by pressing on the sheet name
and when you get back to the bottom
right corner you have an option of
increasing and decreasing the cell size
or the sheet size now let's keep it
default with 100 percent
now these are the few fundamentals that
you need to keep in mind before getting
started with Microsoft Excel now that we
know the fundamentals of Microsoft Excel
let's get started with a practical
session which is about the employee's
details in a company
now let's select this particular cell
and let's type in employee details
yeah we have the cell
now an employee details table will have
the information related to employees so
the information will be about name
it will be about employee number
it will be the designation
and maybe salary
and maybe blood group as well
and let's take another one which is
phone number
yeah
so so far so good and you can see that
we have some problem with this
particular column the designation and
the name uh the name of the designation
is practically good but it is not
visible so when you uh when you're not
on that particular cell you can see that
the name is incomplete over here so you
can always fix that you can just you
know manually change the size of the row
or cell or you can also feel free to you
know double click on that cell which
will automatically you know set the size
of that particular cell and same goes to
the blood group just let's try to double
click on that and same goes to phone
number
great
so you can see that the employees
details are just confined to the first
two cells it's supposed to be somewhere
in the middle right so no problem we can
do that as well we can select all the
cells and we have an option of merging
them
you can just select this one which will
help you with merging and centering that
particular data to the center part
so that's how we do it
now let's get started by adding the
names of the employees
let's add the names Joe
John
uh Mary mark
Susan
and then
Jennifer
let's open mic
let's open them
chef
Jeffrey
yeah we have a couple of employees now
let's type in the employee numbers
yeah we have the employee numbers now
let's type in the designation okay let's
choose Joe to be the CEO of the company
and John as the software developer
and Mary as tester
Mark and finance
Susan also in finance
and Jennifer in testing
and Mike in marketing
same goes for Tim
and again Jeffrey into software
development
and uh
login into testing again
now let's click on C so that it gets you
know resized according to the length of
the text
now it's done so let's get into salary
uh ten thousand dollars
and fifteen thousand dollars
[Music]
nineteen thousand dollars let's increase
the salary of a CEO so let's keep it one
lakh dollars
and finance again twenty thousand
so yeah the salaries are allocated again
the blood group
foreign
groups now let's type in the mobile
numbers
[Music]
yeah now we have typed in some random
mobile numbers as well
so uh yeah this is how you can add in
some data into your table
and now let us imagine that you forgot
to add or remove a column so let's
imagine that we wanted to add a serial
number as well but somehow we forgot to
add it now you can always add a new row
or column for example here we wanted to
add a new column so we just have to
right click on a select the insert
option
you know we have a new row now
let's type in serial number
and let's type one
now can you see the small box option
over here if you just drag it you can
you know copy paste all those over here
and now let's right click
and
fill series now we have the employee
number starting from 1 to 10. that's how
you do it and apart from this you can
also uh you know change the font of the
entire row you can change the font to
say
aroni and you can always also change the
font
and same goes to the employee table we
can select it bold it and you can also
increase the size and again select a
color for the text maybe a different
color green would be better
and you can also select the entire cells
and align them to the center
looks more good
and you can select or double click the
row names so you'll have the proper
spacing between all the rows and columns
so we have double click on the column
right yeah so basically that's how you
make things happen now let's save this
so I'd like to go to the save option and
amp data
let me save this in my local location
and just save it's done
so that's how you work on your Excel
file with some basic data
and to learn more don't forget to get
subscribed to Simply learns YouTube
channel and don't forget to hit that
Bell icon to stay updated so you are the
first person to get an update on any
technology not just Excel now let's get
back to the Practical mode and now we
are on our Excel spreadsheet so here we
have some text boxes on the column A and
on column V we have lower and upper
okay so um we have a mix of uh uppercase
and low keys in our text so first we'll
try to convert them to lowercase and
then we'll try to convert the entire
text into uppercase so for that you need
to press on equal symbol and select the
lower formula
tap and you selected the function and
now click on the cell A3 that's your
cell address and press on ok now all the
letters are converted to low case so we
had J in the uppercase which is
converted to lowercase now all you can
do is drag the formula to all the cells
and it will be applied to all the cells
right now let's similarly try to convert
into uppercase and tap space and there
you go you have selected the formula now
the cell address
press enter
and drag the same address I mean drag
the same formula to all the cell
addresses and there all the cells are
converted to uppercase now that's how
you convert the cells or data in Excel
to uppercase or lowercase in Excel now
we are on the Excel spreadsheet
now here we have some sales data based
on a store now what we are going to do
is we are going to add some multiple
rows or a single Row in this particular
data so here you can see the region wise
category Wise statewise subcategory Wise
and there are sales and quantities right
now let us imagine that you must start
to add a sale data here right so let us
imagine that on the row 7th you are
supposed to add some detail for example
some technology related sale happen on
that day and you missed out to add it
right so how do you create a new row now
so for example if multiple sales
happened on the same day like three to
four and you missed out them so how do I
add three to four rows in between the
existing data right so don't worry about
it it's completely simple all you have
to do is select the row and right click
and press on the option insert now this
will insert one single row if you wanted
to add one single row or a tuple and if
you wanted to add multiple rows for
example you wanted to add three rows all
together then it's also simple all you
have to do is select three rows
and right click and press on insert and
then you have three rows so there you go
so that's how you add multiple rows in a
Excel spreadsheet or that's how you add
one single Row in an Excel spreadsheet
now we have started our Excel worksheet
and here you can see we have Android
details on our worksheet now all of a
sudden uh you wanted to add employee
second name as well or a last name right
so you're a beginner and you don't know
how to add a column or you know you
might be a little ambiguous right so
instead of using this simple step you
might end up creating a whole new sheet
or maybe other approaches as well which
are time consuming so let me give you
this simple step all you have to do is
select the column so here you wanted to
add a last name right so B is your
column with the first name and here you
wanted to add a second name or the last
name which is in between the columns B
and C so remember that Excel adds a
column always towards the left side of a
column so here if I if you wanted to add
a call next to V then you want to select
the column C and right click and select
the insert option so that it can be
added in between V and C which is
adjacent to B so let's look at it right
so you have added the next column or a
new column right next to the column V
and it's in between the designation and
employee name now you can add your inner
second name so that's how you create a
new column in Excel now in case if you
wanted to you know create multiple
columns all together so here we have or
here we needed a second name also here
you have a designation and you wanted to
add another column which you know
assigns managers to the employees right
so let's delete it delete the second
column and let me explain you how what I
want to do so here you want it to to add
the second name of the employee and also
the manager of these employees right so
here you wanted to add two columns
altogether right and now you might be
wondering could I add two columns
together uh or will it work only for the
one column thing right no it it works
for two columns and also more than two
columns all together so you wanted to
add two columns here right so select the
two columns you can you can select or
you can click on the column C and hold
that left key and drag it along the
right side okay so here I have selected
two columns and here it's three right so
you can see here uh it's one zero four
eight five six seven six R cross three
see that means you have selected three
columns if I navigate out of the four
you can see we have selected four
columns right now right click and select
on insert and you'll have four columns
in between employee name and designation
now you might have to add your second
name manager's name manages employee ID
you know and the department everything
or you can add anything or any number of
columns in between the existing columns
now we are on our Excel spreadsheet now
you might want to you know add some
extension to your data since we have
sales here you might want to add the
dollar logo right so if you have like 5
to 10 rows then it's easy but if you
have multiple rows then it might be a
little time consuming in such scenarios
you might want to select the entire
column right so how do you do that in a
shortest method so there are multiple
methods to do it so the easiest one the
first and the easiest one is clicking on
the column number or column name so here
we have the column name that is e and if
you click on it the entire column is
selected and here we have numbers so let
us imagine that you wanted to select the
row number two click on number two and
you have all the rows I mean the entire
row selected all the cells are selected
right so this is one way and again
there is another way where you can just
you know click on the first table header
and press Ctrl spacebar so the
combination key is control spacebar for
columns and if you want to select the
entire row it is shift spacebar so this
is the method two and another method so
you might have a doubt here right so
when you click on the column name or
when you click on the row number the
entire row or entire column gets
selected right and you wanted to select
only the cells which have data so we
have another way for that so you can
select the cell now hold the control and
shift key and press the lower Arrow key
to select the entire column with cells
having data so there you go you have
selected all the cells in one single
column with only data and all the cells
which do not have data are not selected
same applies to rows as well Ctrl shift
right arrow key or left Arrow key based
on your rows and all the rows with data
will be selected I mean all the cells in
a row are selected not the entire row
and coming back to the first question
that is adding the dollar symbol so here
we have General so go to the data type
and add currency
so you have rupees here so currently we
are in India so we have rupees now what
is the advantage of selecting the entire
row when you don't have any data and the
57th row or the next cell right
I'll show you now let us add the number
100 and press enter there you go let us
add another number like thousand and
press enter so the data formatting is
automatically applied to all the cells
so most of the time your cells or the
data sheet will be varying you might
have to add or remove elements or
numbers right so in such scenarios this
will be helpful now comparing two
different columns or multiple columns
happens to be an important job when
you're working in data analytics as you
have to come up with some decisive
decisions based on the data now if you
had to do it manually then you might end
up taking hours or even days based on
the data set you're working with but if
I say that you can do it within minutes
then it would be interesting to work
with right now we'll be doing the same
now we'll work on a sample data set
right on my screen
so here we have column 1 and column two
now our job is to compare the column 1
and column 2 and come up with the result
now the first and the simplest way to do
it is use the built-in condition
formatting which comes with Excel by
default now all you have to do is
select all the data and navigate to home
and in the home go to Styles group and
select conditional formatting and in
conditional formatting you can see
highlight cells so in that you can use
duplicate values when you click on
duplicate values a small pop-up window
will come on your screen and here you
have an option of choosing whether
duplicate or unique so duplicate means
you're comparing the cells and you can
see there are some duplicate cells which
are present in column one are also
present in column two now you can also
check how to you know find out the
unique values which are only present in
column one but not in column two so you
can just press unique and there you go
you can find it now you can also try to
you know change the color by filling
with green for The Unique columns and
duplicate cells with color red now this
was the first method and you can also
work out some different ones like you
can just directly press equal to and
select the cell and
equals to and the next cell press enter
and if there is a match it will give you
true if there is no match then it will
give you false now you can drag it down
and see which all are matching and which
are not
now you can also make some minute
modifications to this
so uh if in case you didn't find the
data then you can say not found so for
that you can try if and inside brackets
and then you can give the value as not
found
if true it's found first you have to
give the True Values so for true you can
write it as found and in case if it's
not found then you can write it down as
not fund
there you go close the bracket press
enter
and there you go if there is a perfect
match you will have found and if there
is no match then you'll get not found
now so far we have discussed uh
comparing two cells using conditional
formatting and also by using equals to
operator and trying to add some tweaks
to the equals to Operator by involving
with if operator and apart from those we
also have another way to compare two
columns in Excel so another way is using
the lookup functions so we'll use a
simple vlookup function to compare both
the cells so of that let's type in
equals to vlookup
space and select the cell you want to
check for and then
the range of elements you want to
compare and then I'll press F4 to log
them
now uh you want the data from column one
and now you want the exact match so zero
press enter
so there you go so the elements which
are present in column 1 and column 2 are
been displayed here so but in case if
the elements are not found you'll get an
error so let's look at that simply drag
the formula to all the cells and there
you go so the elements which are
matching will give you the proper result
but the ones which are not matching will
give you not applicable or error message
this can be fixed we can make some minor
tweaks to the same formula
so we can add if error
comma
simply write an as not found
and close the bracket so that should do
so we have closed the bracket and press
enter there you go now simply drag this
and soon you can see the data which is
having no match is shown as not found
now uh there is another possibility okay
let's get back to another different
sheet so this should work
so uh we already have the formula so
let's erase that first I'll erase the
whole data
and even this one
yeah now we have the clear column for so
here you can see we have for India and
here you can see we have just four and
similarly here you have Mahendra and
Mahendra and here you have Mahindra
right so in some situations you might
have to compare two different columns
but the names might be a little
different right so for example uh if
you're working with Oracle and if you're
working with Oracle America and you have
in the first cases Oracle and in the
second column is Oracle America then
those are one of the thing but you have
some minor text changes right just like
here you have Fort India and here you
have four so what if you had such kind
of issues so you can also make some
minor tweaks to it so using the same
lookup formula you can add equals to
vlookup
and
also the comparison cell which is this
one and we are not you're not stopping
them you're trying to add
the wild card here so the wild card is
asterisk which means if there is
anything like if you get the comparison
between the first cell and the second
cell which matches and if there is
anything extra
rather than the actual cell please try
to consider it so that's what we're
going to do so after entering entering
the wild card symbol you'll select the
range of columns which you have to uh
you know fetch the data from
and then try to fix them using function
key F4
you're looking from the column number
one and then you're finding the exact
match now you can close it and enter
now let's try to drag it
there you go
so you have the data Mahindra and
Mahendra
Hyundai India Honda India so that's how
you try to use comparing cells in Excel
now you can see I'm on my Excel
worksheet and I have one table on my
worksheet right now so you can you know
transposing or you know converting rows
to columns is a very simple task I'll
explain you in two different ways so the
first way select all the cells
that you have on your sheet and press on
Ctrl C so it will give you the copy
option and then you can also place in
the same sheet or if you want you can go
to a whole new sheet and select the
paste option over here but before
selecting the actual paste option you
can see a small drop down icon click on
that and navigate to paste special and
in this you can see transpose option
click on that or you know make sure that
it's checked and press ok now you can
see all your columns have been converted
into rows and all your rows are
converted into columns so this was the
first way and what as the second way you
ask me so it's really simple select one
cell somewhere
and you know you can or let's create a
new sheet as well so here you can you
know write down the formula as transpose
and select the array which you want to
transpose so this is the array
so transpose is basically an array
function in Excel so once you are done
with you know selecting your data press
enter there you go so all your rows are
now columns and all your columns are now
the rows now on my spreadsheet you can
see some data which is the sales data of
quarterly basis and the four different
zones that is North West South East so
you can you know make things look better
by hiding these columns and if you hide
these columns it's critical for the end
user to identify which columns are
exactly hidden right to make things a
little easier for your end user you can
select the columns and then go to the
data option and in the data option click
on the group option so this will group
these columns and you will have this
symbol of minimization which will help
you hide these columns automatically and
unhide these columns automatically now
let's also try to group ghij columns
and there you go now similarly let's
also try to group the rows of North
and rows of West
then you have the rows of South
and rows of East
right now all these rows and columns
have been grouped now all you can do is
just click on the minimize button and
those will be minimized similarly the
rows right
and to unhide them all you can do is
click on the plus icon and they will be
unhidden
you can also try to ungroup the columns
and rows all you have to do is select
the columns and click on the ungroup
option similarly the rows as well
and that's how you can group and ungroup
rows and columns in Excel now we are on
our spreadsheet and you can see I have
some sample data on my spreadsheet and
it does have some blank rows
now how do I eliminate these blank rows
so one step is you can you know select
the entire row and try to right click
and delete it
again this sort of method might take us
to get rid of all the blank rows and
most of the time you might end up even
selecting the rows with data in it right
so if I want to select multiple rows
then I'll be selecting some rows with
data as well which might be a little
Troublesome in the future now let's try
to use the easier way now for that go to
the find and select option select the
go to special option and in that select
the blanks option and press ok now hold
Ctrl key and press minus key
and you will have an option of deleting
the cells now select the entire row now
we are selecting the entire rows with
blank data and press OK and the cells
will be shifted now this was simple but
let me show you another example so even
here we have some blank rows but in
between those blank rows for example
take cell 17 or cell d17 or row 17 we
have some data testing
and here in the employee ID we have some
data in a26
and again in beat 39 we have some data
that is first name
right in such scenarios how do I
eliminate data
so we have a simple Logic for it so all
we need to do is add another row which
is to count the number of cells in the
row now that can be count
from here equals to the function is
Count a
let's tab
and
the cells will be from
A2 to G2
press enter now you have seven
so now we are basically calculating the
number of cells so if you apply the same
to the entire
data set let's drag it
and there you go so there are certain
places where you find 0 which are
basically the empty columns right now
let's do some formatting if you need
let's try to add filters
Ctrl a Ctrl D and now table will have
filters and headers
now here you can see the drop down icon
click on that now instead of select all
what you can do is Select zero now you
will be highlighted with all the rows
which do not have any data select all
those and press on delete or what you
can do is the same way Ctrl minus
and there you go
now
clear the filter
now all you have is the data
without any kind of blank rows so all
the rows that had some amount of data
are retrained and all the data or all
the cells or all the rows which do not
have any data which are completely blank
they have been eliminated so here you
can see columns and rows so especially
the fourth row and the column C right so
currently we have data on our
spreadsheet and it is exceeding the
number of rows currently visible on our
screen right so when you scroll down you
can see that the header or the headers
of all the columns are getting vanished
or scrolled up along with the data right
and you may go to keep that so that you
will have reference to every single
aspect of or every single cell data
you're referring to right so for that
reason you might want to freeze this and
also you might have a doubt what if even
even I had this data in the column
section right and what if I had to
freeze that and you know when you scroll
this and keep that data set on the
column as it is right so we can also do
that let's look at both of them so there
is a simple process to do that all you
have to do is select the cell or for
which you want to you know set the or
freeze the column adjacent to it or the
row adjacent to it right so currently I
want to let me expand it so currently I
want to freeze this particular row right
and this particular column so the cell I
would be selecting is the first cell
here that is D5
right so when I select this particular
cell I can be able to freeze this
particular row and this particular
column so now you need to navigate to
the toolbar and then select the view
menu and inside view option you can see
there is an option of freeze paints
right so click on the drop down so you
can see three different options as we
discussed earlier we can either choose
to freeze an entire row that is a second
option or you can freeze the entire
column that is the third option or you
can freeze both that is the first option
right freezing rows and columns so let's
select this one and see if our rows and
columns are frozen or not right so now
let's scroll down and you can see our
row is successfully Frozen there right
and similarly scroll towards right and
you can see our column has been
successfully Frozen right so this is how
you freeze rows and columns or you can
freeze panes in Excel now here on my
sheet you can see we have some numbers
that is ten dollars or ten point two
zero dollars twenty two dollars fifty
three point one two dollars twelve
dollars and hundred and ten dollars now
the task is to convert these numbers
into word format that is representing
the numbers alphabetically right this
might be a little curious and we also
might end up searching for a predefined
method which is not readily available in
Excel but there is a way where you can
create a function using Excel VBA or
macros now again creating a macro is
completely complex now identifying the
trouble Microsoft has already come up
with a readily available macro code on
their official website which will
support the various versions of
Microsoft Excel starting from Microsoft
Excel 365 to all the way up to the older
Excel version that is 2010. now you can
scroll down and use this particular
macro function which Microsoft has
readily made us available and use this
to create our own macro and Excel VBA
now let's get back to Excel and you can
create a macro using the developer
option now developer options will not be
readily available in Microsoft Excel to
activate developer option go to home and
go to the options menu in the last
and here go to customize ribbon and here
in the second drop down menu you can see
developer option by default it will not
be checked click on the check option to
activate developer options and press ok
now you have your developer options
ready click on developer options click
on Visual Basic and here to insert a new
macro click on the insert button click
on module and a new macro window is
readily available for you now Ctrl V to
paste your code and your function is
with the name number to text right now
close the macro
and here your function will be readily
available
equals to and the function name was
number to text press tab to select the
function and select the cell where you
have the data close the function press
enter now drag the same formula across
all the cells and here you have the text
converted from numbers so here we have
10. 20 cents and you have ten dollars
twenty cents twenty two dollars and no
sense 53 dollars and twelve cents twelve
dollars and no cents and 110 dollars
with no sense now that's how you can
convert numbers to words using the macro
which is predefined for excel in the
Microsoft website so for example uh let
us imagine that you wanted to create one
single cell for all the employees in
your company which stores the first name
second name or last name including the
email IDs at one place right if you want
to do so like let us let us let me show
you how it looks like so let me copy
this here
and that's the first name now it's your
second name
along with the email ID
now let us imagine that you wanted to
store all the employees in the same way
right so you can do this by using
combine operation in Excel now all it
takes is just a simple formula that is
equals to and the first selector is
as A2
and you can use an amplitude sign
now you can use the next cell reference
address B2
and then colon and the last cell address
that is E2
now press enter
so when you press enter or tab you will
get this particular answer but this data
is completely in a state where you can't
understand it right the first name last
name and the email ID has got
of mine altogether so you want to use
some spaces right so all you need to do
is just make a little modification to
this particular existing data so you can
press another Ampersand and include
spaces
and then you can separate the email ID
and the name with some colon
so now we have separated the first two
cells that is the first name and the
last name with the space using the
ampersense and then again we have used
an ampersand to include the colon and
see that we have also included a space
between the colon marks that it's get
separated cleanly and now let's try to
press Tab and see the result
so there you go the first name and the
second name is separated by space and
the email ID and the complete name is
separated by a colon now you can use
this to all the cells
and there you go all the first name last
name and the email IDs have been printed
here so that's how you use the combine
operation in Excel and you can see on my
screen we have the sales data of one
single employee in the month of January
okay so this is the sales data of John
in January sales
now let us imagine that we have the same
persons or same Jones data of sales of
all the three months okay so here we
have the sales data of John for January
February and March and you wanted to
Club all these three months and write it
down as quarter one right so let us try
doing it
now you can see that only January is
replaced as quarter one and February and
March are still remaining the same so
let us try to delete them
so we have deleted them and I think now
it looks like uh this is a sales data of
one single quota that is quarter one but
again
quarter one is under column B and anyone
who looks at it feels like this data is
of January February and March and all
the quarter one details are only present
in B column but C and D are completely
you know different from this one right
so you don't want that kind of an
impression on your uh you know the one
we're presenting to you so in those
situations you want to merge all these
three columns and make sure that the
quarter one is present somewhere in
between the cells so that all the data
looks relevant and uh it defines that
these data elements belong to a quarter
one right so there is enough in Excel to
do that so select all the cells that you
want to merge and going to home button
and in home button get into the
alignment group and select merge and
center so you can do it directly also
you have a couple of more options there
is merge and center merge across merge
cells and unmatch so we'll go through it
one by one so first we'll go through
merge and center
so there you go to sell scored months
and it has been aligned into Center
now again if your manager or anyone
Superior to you wants this to be you
know independent like they want it to be
in terms of January February and March
so that they can have access to it and
month-wise so you want to unmatch it
back right how to do that now so the
same menu and select unmatch and there
you go you have your data packed in the
original form again all you have to do
is you know rename a few cells
there you go
and you have it back right so in a few
situations okay you can also add
reporters so that it looks more relevant
now uh you know now let's try to match
this again and watching Center yeah now
again uh let us imagine that you are
going through an appraisal cycle and you
also wanted to add some comments about
the sales happening in your company uh
regarding uh all the employees right so
also we have that here now let me expand
a little bit
yeah okay
so again let's Marge and Center
now uh you wanted to you know you wanted
to take a review of your level one level
two and level three managers so you have
all the three uh rows here but you can
see the cells are not matched and uh you
wanted to merge every single row so
merging and centering everything row
wise would be a little time consuming I
mean three columns is okay but what if
you had like uh you had to take a review
from
a couple of small manages like five to
ten right or imagine a you wanted to
write some random comments apart from
review you wanted to write some random
comments based on month-wise uh sales or
something like that so it would be time
consuming right so apart from that you
have another option where you you know
select all the cells and come over here
and select the option of merge across
and all the cells will be merged all
together at once and you will be having
those individual rows where you can
write down your reviews like review one
and so on review
2 right so this is how the option of
merge across works and we already have
been through the margin Center and merge
is completely similar to margin Center
so this is how margin Center merge cells
and merge across and unmerged cells and
Excel now there are multiple ways to add
date to Excel spreadsheet for example
equals to today this is a shortcut
method and you can enter
done you will have today's state but
again there is some problem with this
kind of approach so today's state is 4th
of September 2022. now if you open the
same spreadsheet after today that is
tomorrow or day after tomorrow then you
will have a concurrent date that is 5th
of September or 6th of September right
the date will always vary or get updated
according to time now you don't want to
change that or you don't want that to be
happening with M Plus data joining right
it should be stagnant it should not vary
right so there is another shortcut way
apart from using the date time functions
there is a keyboard shortcut where you
can add date to excel that is control
semicolon so this is the shortcut way to
add date to your Excel spreadsheet and
this particular date will not change
this will remain the same constant date
throughout the time now there is a
chance where you might also have to add
time to your spreadsheet that is date of
joining and time of joining right so
there is another simple shortcut where
you can add
Time by just pressing three keys that is
holding Ctrl holding shift and pressing
semicolon then you'll have the time
so this is how you can add date to your
Excel spreadsheet and add time to your
Excel spreadsheet and this date and time
will remain constant it will not vary
like the 3D function that we have used
here so you can see on my screen we are
on the Excel spreadsheet and on my
spreadsheet you can see dates in column
A and A different formats n column C D E
and F respectively Now by default the
data type or the data present in the a
column will be considered as general and
there are a few situations where even if
you try to format the date in your
format like you know the customized
format you may not be able to do it
because it's still under the general
data type so for that for being on the
safer side what we will do is select the
data and navigate to the data toolbar
and in that you have the text to columns
option press that and remember to have
the delimited icon you know you might be
having the dash as your icon or slash as
your icon for the delimited thing and
select that and next next and here you
can see right it's in general mode so
you can press on date and DMI will be a
date format that is date month and year
now click on finish so it's been
formatted now now let's copy the same
data and paste it in all the four
formats so that will see the different
formats that we can change to or
customize to
right
so there you go let's expand the columns
a little bit now we have day month and
year
so now you might want to change a couple
of things right for example you wanted
to change okay let's see the menu so the
way is to select the cells and right
click and select the format sales option
and in here you can see the date
function and then here you can see
different types of modifications that
you can do to your data right so
you might want to also change your days
based on the location so right now we
are in India and imagine if you wanted
to you know change something based on us
or if you are if you are having your
client in us and he wants the dates and
US format you can also change that so
here you can see English United States
and press on that press OK and you can
see it's been changed to us format where
you have EOS in the first place months
in the second place and dates in the
last place right and now let us imagine
that your client does not want the dates
all he needs is just months right you
can also do that get back to the format
sales option go to custom and here
instead of uh you know a month date and
year all you can do is just write down
month and year and select ok so you'll
have only month and your not the dates
now your client is being a little more
you know he wants a little more detail
and he wants you to add a lot of
granularity to your data which includes
day time Etc everything right so you can
also do that so the same way go to
format sales custom and here I think
it's indeed itself
so
let's navigate a little
yeah here so you have the day date month
and year press ok so there you go right
so that's how you can do it
and now let's try a little bit more
if you have a few more options pending
so go to format cells
and Custom
and you also have
timings
so here you have date month year and
timings press OK and then we have all
the timings as well so since these dates
are you know I created them just a few
moments ago to keep it simple so I did
not have to add the diamonds here so if
you are Keen about adding the timings
you can also do that for example if you
wanted to add the timings of the
employees logged in and look that you
can also do that using the same format
and you can see now we are on our Excel
spreadsheet and you can see we have a
column of dates and on the column B we
have age now how do you calculate the
age using the read of spirit so this is
completely simple all you have to use is
the dated IF function or if you also
call it as date diff function based on
your choice we also have a specific
entire tutorial based on date diff in
Excel for further information that video
will be linked in the description box
below you can go through it or you can
use the end screens and icons linked to
this video to get back to the tutorial
based on date diff in Excel now let's
calculate the age of these dates or
these people with these date of births
so all you have to do is type equals to
and type dated if
and open a bracket we need three
parameters here that is the date of
birth that is the first parameter now
the second one is the today function
because you're calculating the age of
these people as per today right so we
have a two day function in Excel press
on tap to select it and give a close
bracket now comma and if you wanted to
calculate the age in terms of days you
have to uh you know give d as the input
yeah here it should be D as the input
and don't forget to use the double
quotes here and if you use the single
course there might be an error so use
double quotes if you want it in the Days
part you can give days and if you want
it in months you can give months for now
we want in us so we will be giving y as
the third parameter and press enter
there you go you have the H here in 26
years you can drag the same function and
you have the ages here as you want it
right so this is how you calculate age
in Excel and on my Excel spreadsheet let
me expand it
we have two different timings that is in
and out so here we are considering a
scenario where we are calculating the
total number of hours worked by an
employee in an organization so the end
time will be the time where the employee
logged in and the out time will be the
time when the employee logged out so
here we have made some minor cell
formatting so when you right click on
any of the cell you can get back to the
formatting cells option and in that
option we have selected the AM PM so
there is also another option of choosing
the 24 hour timing that is 13 20 uh 1330
so this represents the 24 hour format
but since we are you know working on
Office timings let's keep it as AM PM
okay so there you go so we have our
timings of in and out now to calculate
the time difference between the end time
and out time so this particular
calculation is completely simple all you
have to do is press equals to select
outline minus select end time so there
you go press enter and you have the
total number of hours the employee has
been working in your organization so
here also we have made some minor cell
formatting so usually it comes out as Am
Pm right but instead of that we have
made a minor cell formatting we have
navigated into time and we have selected
the 24 hour formatting so that we have
just ours in our output so that's how we
have calculated the time difference
between two n times and out times of an
employee using Excel allow me to
introduce post graduate program in data
analytics by simply learn just take a
quick look at the features followed by
the skills you will gain through this
course some key features of this
comprehensive program includes exclusive
hackathons and the editing sessions by
IBM eight times higher LIVE edition in
live online classes by industry experts
Capstone from three domains and 14 plus
data analytics projects with industry
data sets from Google Play Store Lyft
World Bank Etc masterclass was delivered
by Pearl faculty and IBM experts simply
learns job assist helps you to get
noticed by top hiring companies and much
much more it is well said when skills
Empower possibilities flourish to grab
the opportunities gain skills like data
analytics statistical analysis using
Excel data analysis Python and R data
visualization Tableau and power bi and
much more so what are you waiting for
hurry up and enroll Now find the course
Link in the description box so you can
see that I've got some data which is for
first name of the employee last name of
the employee and phone number and let us
assume that your manager has given you a
task to identify all those employees
which did not give and
phone number so you wanted to identify
them using a check box right
like you will be providing a check for
all the employees that we have received
the phone numbers and you will not be
checking the employees which did not get
the phone number right so let's try to
do that so to include a check box you
might want to get into the developer
option but for few reasons Microsoft has
disabled developer option by default to
enable developer option all you have to
do is just navigate anywhere on the
ribbon here and right click and then you
can see customize the ribbon option when
you click into it you will be redirected
into the ribbon option and here you can
see the developer option on the right
side
write this one so by default you can see
that your developer option is not
enabled to enable it you have to check
in it and there you go you have it now
so press OK and you'll have the
developer option now go to the developer
option and select the insert option and
there you can see the check box now draw
the checkbox anywhere
I'll try it over here and there you go
you have the first checkbox right now if
you want you can even customize this
so carefully click it
you can edit the text
and write it as
done
okay
now you can even copy this to all the
cells
just select and drag and there you go
now you can go ahead and check all the
employees which you have received the
phone numbers
and you can eliminate the ones which did
not provide you with phone numbers
that's how you can do it
and there's also another option where
you can use this to include it in a
formula
since this data is only of 25 rows you
can manually check in the data and you
can leave the data which is you have not
received but what if you had 2500 right
then you might need formula so in such
scenarios you can use a formula so how
do you use that so for example if this
particular box is checked then you will
get a True Value here and if it's not
checked you will have a false value then
you can use that Boolean value to
include in your formula right sounds
interesting now let's try to implement
that
you can right click the cell and you can
find format control
then you can see here
you have an option called cell link here
select the cell link
and press ok
so here you can see if you have checked
this the value is true and if you
uncheck this
you can see the value turned false now
you can use this particular cell
reference for including this in a
formula now let us also check how to
include checkboxes on Google Sheets and
Google sheet it's really simple all you
have to do is get it against that option
and you can see a really available
checkbox you don't have to use any
developer options over here and there
you go you can just check now let us
assume that you're giving an important
presentation and you're also requested
by a manager to add the Excel document
that you have used to create that
particular report which would be
something like this when you click on it
it will open a new Excel document or
Excel Window with all the data in it
right so how do we do that let's look at
the demo now let's have a blank slide
and let's get back to this Source where
our Excel file is located that is in my
documents so we are currently in my
documents and we have the Excel file
which we used for creating that
particular report now if we copy and try
to paste it on our Excel document it
would look something like this
and clearly it's not visible and it's
not accessible right so instead of this
there is another way where you can
directly add the Excel document in the
form of logo which is a rather simple
idea all you have to do is just click on
the insert option in the toolbar then
navigate to the text group and here you
will find the option called object click
on the object and it will give you a new
window where you can identify which type
of document or object you want to add
either create or create from file so we
have the file in our local system so
we'll choose create from file browse and
from browse we will go into the
documents section where we have our
Excel file click on the Excel file and
click on ok now if you want the data or
Excel file to be displayed in the form
of an icon then click on the display as
icon section and here you can change the
icon so you can choose any one of the
given options let's choose this
particular one and click on OK another
OK and there you go the icon will be now
displayed on your Microsoft PowerPoint
PPT which is completely clickable as the
previous one
whenever you click on this the Excel
document will be opened so that's how
you add Excel document into Microsoft
PowerPoint now we are on our Excel
spreadsheet and here I'm trying to
insert some images onto my spreadsheet
so here we have company logos and
Company brand names so since we already
have the brand name so what we need to
add here is the brand logos okay so how
do I add such kind of an image into an
Excel spreadsheet that you might be
thinking that Excel spreadsheets are
just for data not multimedia image of
files right so no it's not it's
completely wrong you can also add your
images onto your Excel spreadsheets is
completely simple so click anywhere on
the Excel spreadsheet navigate to the
insert button select the illustrations
option from the islands group click on
that and you know in the drop down you
can see the pictures icon or the
pictures button click on that
and select from this device or if you
have an online starting which you can
take that or you can also check out from
online pictures for now I'll select the
device this device
and here I have some images the images
what we need are simply learn and simply
code logos press ok
or insert so here you have them
now
you can also adjust the size of the
image using the small buttons here
press it over here
and done
so you might be wondering is it all done
is there anything more to do or just
adding an image is done no most of the
times when you create or you work with
Excel spreadsheet you will not just you
know add some data and add a relevant
image to it most of the time you add
some graphs or you most of the time
you'll add some charts to showcase the
data dashboard right so it will be
something like this so this is how you
add the image or graph onto your
dashboard and sometimes you might not
have enough place to display your entire
dashboard during those situations what
you do is you try to hide the row or
column so now let's try to hide this
particular room let us imagine that you
wanted to show only uh to uh charts and
there is no space for your third chart
in such scenarios you might want to hide
or remove that third chart okay so let's
try to hide it and see if gets if it
gets hidden or not when you try to hide
it you can see the column A has no data
and the row number four has been hidden
so we have three and five but what about
the image it is still present right so
if you want to make sure that the row
also hides the image then you might have
to do a little formatting with it so
select the image go to picture format
or you can also right click and directly
navigate to picture format this opens up
a set of options and here you might want
to go to the third one which is picture
format third and select the properties
and here select the option of move and
size width cells so when you select this
and you try to hide this it will also I
mean the graph or the image will also
hide along with the row so that's how
you do it so how to insert PDF in Excel
now there are multiple ways to insert a
PDF into Excel so we will go through a
couple of ways first is here let us
imagine that we wanted to insert some
PowerPoint presentation in PDF format
into our Excel sheet so that it belongs
to excel Basics now click on the cell
where you want to add the PDF or just
click any cell in the Excel spreadsheet
then go to the option of insert in the
toolbar then navigate to text option
click on it and select object
and here you can select create from file
and then you can browse and here you
have your Excel Basics PDF in my
documents click on that select insert so
here you can just press ok
and the PDF will be inserted now you can
minimize the size of PDF to fit the cell
there you go the PDF got successfully
inserted into your Excel spreadsheet now
let's discuss about the second way now
the second way is completely same the
only difference is you can add some logo
to your PDF so you can see it has been
added in direct form of a PDF like what
sticker first slide of the PPT but
instead of that if you wanted to
highlight it as an icon then you can
select the display as icon button here
and press ok now you don't have to
reformat the size of your PPD or PDF all
you have to do is add the logo to your
PDF and it will also include the title
so this is another way of adding you
know PDF to your Excel sheet now another
way so a few times you don't want the
first page of the PDF to be visible or
any kind of logo of that PDF reader to
be visible on your spreadsheet sometimes
all you want is some dedicated image or
a dedicated logo right so so this time
let's try to add a dedicated image to
our PDF so go to insert again here you
can see the illustrations option
click on picture and from this device so
I will select the simply launch logo and
now you have to resize the logo a little
bit to fit the cell
there you go
you can click on the right click button
and and select the option of Link
now select the existing file or web page
option so if you are interested to learn
more on hyperlink in Excel we have
dedicated tutorial on that please go
through hyperlinks in Excel by simply
learn which will explain you everything
about hyperlinks in Excel how to insert
them different types of documents to be
inserted and how it works in real time
for now let's try to insert the existing
web page
and go to documents navigate to
documents and inside this
you have the Excel basic PDF click on OK
and it has been added to your image so
when you click on it it will open the
PDF document attached to it so when you
hover over to the cell you can see it
will ask you a permission do you want to
continue or not just click on S ignore
the warning so you can see the PDF has
been successfully open convert PDF into
Excel
now to do this let's get back to the
Practical mode and try to convert some
PDF data into Excel now you can see the
PDF document which I am looking to
convert from PDF to excel so this
particular PDF document has a table so
this is the statewise jst collections
that happened during March of 2020. now
we need to convert this tabular data
from PDF format to excel format now we
are on the Microsoft Excel now to
initiate the process we might want to
choose a blank workbook for this
so now we are at the blank workbook and
the complete sheet is empty now let's go
into the data option in the toolbar
and in the data option of the toolbar
we have
the ribbon of get and transform data in
this ribbon you can see get data option
select that and you can see various
options here from file from database
from Azure from other sources Etc
now we need the first option that is
from file and in that we have a drop
down and in that drop down you might
want to select the PDF if you have a
Json file you can also choose from a
Json and if you have the data from XML
you can choose that and even you can
extract the data from text or CSV as
well now we need the PDF option so
select the PDF Now navigate where your
file is existing so my file is on the
desktop and now let me select the PDF
document
select import now Excel will
automatically analyze the tability data
in the PDF format and give you the
results
now according to excel there are
multiple tabular formats table 1 table 2
so basically this table is one and the
same so all the 29 states are fixed in
one table itself but since the PDF is
divided in sheets this particular
document is considering the first table
as a separate table and the table which
is present in the third page as a
separate table so we have table 1 table
2 and there are few more tables which
Excel is assuming that it might be table
but it's not and another table which is
page number zero zero two it has a table
and another one is right here now there
is an option of selecting all the tables
all together at once or you can select
only one table which you want to select
so if you select multiple items Excel
will automatically give you an option of
choosing your tables you can just tick
and select the tables you want
or
you can directly select the table you
want on your Excel sheet
so right now let's try to select
multiple tables
so I'll be selecting one two four and
five and this particular one is not a
table so I'm eliminating that now you
might want to choose the load option
so Excel is now loading the data
now all the data has been successfully
loaded
now
yeah it is giving us a notification that
all the data has been successfully
loaded and now just right click on it
and here choose the option load 2 and
here
select table option and if you want the
data to be you know loaded to a new
worksheet you can choose that and select
ok
now you can see all the data has been
successfully loaded in the form of
tabular format in the new Excel sheet
similarly let's try to load another page
in the table format
new worksheet
select ok
and the third sheet
now get ready to impress your boss by
converting all the PDF data into Excel
sheet just in a matter of few seconds
with few steps
and there you go all the four tables
have been loaded successfully in the
form of excel in just a few steps now
this is how you convert PDF to excel
that is how to add tick mark in Excel
now on my spreadsheet you can see some
employee data so they've been assigned a
task and they want to update the task
status as done and not done using
symbolic statements that is tick mark
and into marks now how to do that it is
really simple we'll discuss two
different ways the first way is to do it
by conditional formatting so click a
cell on the task status go to
conditional formatting click on the new
row yes of course we can use the icon
settings but we want to automate it so
click on the new rule right so here
instead of two color scale select icon
sets now go to the settings here we
don't want the third symbol so select no
cell icon and here instead of percentage
number formula let's add just a simple
number and the second one as well just a
simple number now in the icon settings
select Tech Market have various types of
them you know the circular Tech Market
let's select the generic Tech Mark
without any outer circles and into here
generic X Mark and now let's set the
values when the value is greater than 0
it will be green and when the value is
less than or equal to 0 it will be X and
the reference value is 0 and here also
the reference value is zero everything
is okay click on OK and done
and here you cannot see the logos here
we need to add some formula here which
is equals to F click on Tab to select
the simple and if Cell address C2 is
equals to done
then the value should be 1 else the
value should be 0 close the bracket
enter
right now you can see this particular
logo here now drag the same formula it's
done now you can see we do have numbers
you can eliminate those numbers as well
just edit the rules
and here you can see show icon only
click OK and the numbers will be removed
also I did the second one and there you
go the numbers are gone and only the
symbols remain now what is the second
technique the second technique is
available in the developer options you
can activate it by you know going into
the options here go to file and here go
to options and here go to Advanced
customize weapon and in here on the
right hand side you will get developer
options click on the tick box and it
will be enabled now go into developer
options and click into insert menu click
on the form controls or active X
controls select the check box and now
just place it over here you know you can
edit this particular checkbox delete
everything drag it as checkbox as well
now you can drag the same cell across
all the functions and you will have the
check box as well now you can click on
it and say if it's done or not whereas
how to add Watermark to excel now on my
sheet you can see some data so here we
wanted to add some Watermark logo to
your Excel spreadsheet so that it looks
genuine and worked by you right so
that's the overall idea of adding a
watermark now go to the insert window
and in the insert window go to the text
option click on that select header and
footer once you select header and photo
you can see something on your screen
like this so in this box which is
highlighted by a cursor is why you're
going to add the picture on my top in
the menu bar you can see header and
footer elements in this select the
picture element and it will navigate to
you to a different option window since
we are adding the image from our local
system select from file or if you are
adding from your Bing or any search
window you can also add that or onedrap
as well but now let's go with from file
it will directly navigate you to the
pictures folder in your local system so
here is my Center launch logo click on
it and select insert now you can see the
images added in this format which is
Ampersand and picture and you might
wonder where is the picture it is
actually present to view it click on any
cell in the spreadsheet and there you go
you can see it now you might be
wondering the image is a little towards
top and abnormally placed right so no
worries you can always you know format
your picture just press enter and use
enter to move your picture towards the
center of your data spreadsheet and also
there is another option of format
picture altogether here you can adjust
the height and width of your image by
you know increasing and decreasing width
or increasing and decreasing height
using the arrow marks also works and
apart from this there is another option
of picture formatting where you can
choose your image to be washing out
black and white grayscale or anything so
currently I am going with automatic
which will automatically adjust the
brightness and you know everything for
your image it looks perfectly fine so
click on OK and there you go right so
now
this should be fine
right now everything is done and
everything is automatically saved if you
are having that auto save option on your
spreadsheet and let's go back to the
normal view from the header and footer
view click on The View and go to normal
you might be confused right where is
Hello going to vanish did I have to save
it no it's already saved everything is
fine even the image is there but you
cannot see it in normal view to see it
click on file click on print then you
can see the logo it will be present only
on the printed Pages not on the normal
view okay so that's how you work with
watermarks in Excel and that's how you
can add and customize your watermarks
using Excel how to modify or increase
cell size in Excel now most of you might
probably want to increase just the sales
error here has to increase the
visibility of the text so one of the
easiest way is just to press on the plus
icon on the bottom right corner of your
Excel spreadsheet so this will
automatically increase the text size and
you can see the text more clearly now
apart from that if it's just not that
what you want to do you can also modify
by hovering over to the line between two
columns and right click which will give
you the option of format cells or column
width so either of these options will
help you to maximize or minimize your
column width
similarly you can apply the same idea
for your rows as well so you can either
format the cells or modify the row
height of your cell and this is another
way and another simple way is to just
hold that line and drag it so it
improves your width of the column and
another way is to just hover onto that
line and hold it and drag it to
improvise or increase your width of the
cell and same LaPlace to your row so
this is another way so apart from that
there is another way that is format
cells from this particular option in the
home button you can select this and here
you have the row height out of it row
height column width autofit column width
for example let us imagine that you
wanted to you know just by mistake you
you increase the cell size and you want
it to restore it back to the original
thing right so you can just click on the
autofit height and click on the order
fit called width then you go it happens
in that way and now coming back to
another
simplest way let us imagine that you are
given a lot of data and you are told to
go to fit all the rows and columns now
we have already seen the format cell
option where I will Auto fetch all the
columns and width of the column and also
the height of the rows Etc right but
there is also a keyboard shortcut to do
this so all you have to do is select a
cell and press Ctrl a to select all the
cells in the spreadsheet and once all
the cells are selected all you have to
do is press and hold ALT key and then
release it then the combination of keys
that is h o i
so your column width has been now
adjusted now the same formula or the
same shortcut key with a small
modification press and hold and release
ALT key now h o and a to adjust the row
height so this is the way where you can
increase or decrease or modify or
autofit all the cells in Excel now you
can see that we have the First Column
that is a column and the first set of
that is text and all the other cells are
numbers but as a whole Excel considers
the whole column as a general data
format so why have we discussing about
this so to create a barcode in Excel you
have to make sure that all the elements
in the column are of Text data type so
the first step is to convert this
General data type to Text data type so
you can do that by going into the data
type and selecting text and now all the
elements in your first column A are type
text
now the next step is to convert these
elements into barcode now for that let's
create a new column called barcode
now our new column that is barcode has
been created now the next step would be
is to check for the barcode font so the
barcode font looks something like this
but let me remind you the barcode found
in Excel is not available by default
don't worry if it's not available we can
download it from open source so let's go
back to Google
so on the Google you want to search for
barcode font for Excel so the one that I
would recommend is three of nine barcode
font
now you can download this font by just
clicking on the download button over
here now I've already downloaded this
font on my local system let's now try to
install that
now the three of nine barcode folder
will come in the form of zip folder you
have to unzip that
and after unzipping you'll get the setup
file which looks something like this
which is three of nine new select that
and you'll be having the installer file
over here you can install by selecting
the install button over here so I have
already installed it in my local system
so it is readily available for me on my
Microsoft Excel now we might want to
create the barcode for this particular
cell in A2 so let's create that so to
create a barcode we need to write on a
formula that is equals to double quotes
star
double quotes and Ampersand symbol
address of the cell that is A2 another
Ampersand symbol again double quotes
star symbol and double quotes
so you can either use this or instead of
star you can use brackets as well
so let's try brackets
now select enter
now this will generate another type of
code in your resultant cell now we will
change the font for this particular
resultant cell and we will get our
barcode now you can just drag all these
cells so that you can apply the formula
to all the codes and I got all the codes
over here
now select all the cells get into the
fonts and here select the barcode font
and there you go you have the barcode
for all the
numbers you have in your column A so
that's how you create barcode in Excel
Excel Flash Fill is a feature of
Microsoft Excel where Excel can sense a
pattern in a cell and apply the same
logic to extract the similar resultant
pattern out of the remaining cells in a
table
might be a little confusing right so let
us simplify it so let us imagine that
you have a text in one of the cells in
the Excel sheet and you want it to trim
a part of that text for example let us
imagine that there is an assembly an
assembly where the car parts are
assembled together to finish a car so
each and every part has a code the
serial number the product code and the
assembly code Etc right and you wanted
to separate all those three
if you wanted to do that you might want
to use section function which might be a
little tedious to apply to all the cells
but what if I say there is a simple key
format using which you can fill all the
columns in the Excel sheet within a
fraction of second sounds interesting
right so that's exactly The Flash Fill
function in Excel does
now before we get started let me tell
you guys that we have daily updates on
multiple Technologies if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and don't forget to hit that
Bell icon to never miss an update from
Simply love now without further Ado
let's get started with the Flash Fill in
Excel for that we might want to start
the Excel to get in the Practical mode
now we are on the Microsoft Excel and
remember the example we discussed so
this is a similar example now the first
column in the sheet is the product
detail so this product detail consists
of the product code that is one one two
next we have the product serial number
that is one zero zero two five six three
seven and lastly the assembly code that
is a s and X now we want to separate
this product detail into three columns
where we have the First Column to be
storing the product code second one to
be storing the product serial number and
the last one to be storing the assembly
code so now if we want to do that using
trim function you might want to apply
the trim function here and trim out the
left part and again for the product
serial number you might want to use
certain function again which might go
into a little complicated pattern So to
avoid the complications and and decrease
the time spent we might want to use the
Flash Fill in Excel now let us help
Excel about the pattern that we might
want to generate so the pattern is 112
and the next one is
three two two so now you can see that
the text was highlighted that was the
intimation from the Excel that it
understood the pattern now going into
the next cell and holding the Ctrl key
and pressing the E button will help us
to fill the remaining cells in the
column B
so that's how it is done and similarly
let's try out for the serial number
for that the serial number is one zero
zero two
five six three seven
now in the next cell we have one zero
zero three six five eight two
now we can go to the third cell and
press Ctrl e for Windows and if you're
using a Mac operating system then you
have to press command e and all these
serial numbers will be filled so this
will reduce the time in separating the
pattern and filling the columns
now let's try the last column that is a
s x which happens to the assembly code
next we have f g and V now the
shortcut method that is Ctrl e and there
you go
now you might be wondering will it work
only for numbers etc etc or the text
which is properly aligned or separated
using a hyphen no it can also be used
for some random text which is like this
so let us imagine that we have a text
which is of length like 20 or 30 and you
wanted to print only a part of it so
here I'm going to print the alphabets
from position fourth to position eight
so I've already tried the first one that
is taking out the alphabets from fourth
location to the eighth location or the
pattern of the text that is i f e r from
Jennifer Lopez and in the next cell we
have the numbers starting from the
location four to eight so that is 7767
and similarly we have the other cells
consisting of the names of few cars that
is Alpha Romeo Bugatti Veyron and next
we have Superman Returns text so now
let's press the shortcut key that is
Ctrl e and make sure that all the
remaining cells are filled so that's how
the Flash Fill works
so the Flash Fill in Excel will reduce
the time consumed to fill all the
columns by separating the text in your
main cell that is the column A which we
have here in this example and it also
reduces the complexity of using a frame
function in Excel yes hyperlinks in
Excel
now hyperlink is something which is
clickable and when you click on it it
will redirect you to a different web
page to a different worksheet or a
different location in your local system
so there are a variety of options and we
will explore all of them using Excel
now creating a hyperlink is really
simple we have multiple ways now let's
write some text on the Excel worksheet
I'll write simply down
now creating a hyperlink is really
simple you have multiple ways the first
simplest shortcut is clicking on the
cell where you want to place the
hyperlink and holding Ctrl key and
pressing k
now this will enable the hyperlink menu
box or the dialog box this is the first
way and let me close it now again we
have selected the cell there is another
option where you have to click on the
insert menu on the toolbar and navigate
to Links group click on the link option
and you will again have the dialog box
of the hyperlick in Excel and the Third
Way is right click on the cell and you
can see the link option in the last
and this will enable the hyperlink
option in Excel now let's create a
hyperlink the simplest way again Ctrl K
now we have a variety of options that is
existing file or web page placed in this
document create a new document and an
email address so we will address all of
these one at each time so first one
existing file or a web page now you can
select an existing PDF file or any file
in your local system and hyperlink or
create a hyperlink to the text or you
can select a website a link and place it
over here and create it as a hyperlink
let's explore both the options
first let's try to explore the web page
option so since I have written as simply
learn let's use the website link of
Simply learn and create a hyperlink
let me open Google
Newton and let me type simplylearn.com
let me copy the hyperlink and now let's
get back to the Excel workbook now here
let's place the hyperlink
now you can press ok
and there you go the hyperlink has been
successfully created now this link is
clickable when you click on it it will
redirect you to a new simply launch home
web page right so this is how you create
a hyperlink to a website
now we shall explore another option that
is using an existing file right let's
create a new text box here let's name it
as existing
file and okay existing files should be
good again the same you can either click
uh you know right click and select
hyperlink or Ctrl k
now let's select existing file or web
page option now here you can see
navigate key press on that and let's
navigate the files
let's select all files here remember to
select all files okay by default it
shows as office files and let's explore
our file option
so let's select a fundamentals of
computer programming option which is a
PDF file press OK and there you go we
have created a hyperlink so when I click
on this you can directly navigate to an
existing PDF file in your local system
and it will be open as a web page
click on it and you can see the PDF file
now close
now another thing when you navigate onto
this you'll see the lengthier HTTP
address and same happens here right so
if you're a little uncomfortable
watching this lengthier link you can
also edit it you can choose the option
of edit hyperlink
and
see the screen tip option
click on it
and here you can change the text to
display option
and write it as
click here
to no more
press ok
again press OK and now if you navigate
onto it instead of seeing a Lambda
hyperlink what you can see is click here
to know more okay I think I made a
spelling mistake
so I think I forgot an e
somewhere over here yes click here to
normal
and press OK right so here you can see
click here to normal let's try this
again over here
so edit
edit hyperlink screen tab option and
instead of dealing with your text box or
hyperlink you can write as click to open
notes
or PDF
click ok
and click another okay and you are done
so instead of seeing that length here
hyperlink you can see click here to open
PDF right so so far we have explored two
options that is existing file and
existing web page
right now let's try to explore another
option again a hyperlink right click
hyperlink and here you have seen places
in document all right so which is like
uh okay let me
show this to you instead of telling you
so here what it is doing is you have to
sell A5 and you wanted to refer to A1 or
any other cell in the same worksheet so
you can do that right so now for your
reference let me cancel it and let me
create a new sheet and here
navigate me to here right let me write
this navigate me to here
okay
so now what we will do is
so here we will create that navigate
link
from using the haplink option place this
in this document you can see the sheet
to option and the cell references A1
where we have written navigate me to
here so when I click this A5 cell
okay let me also rename it
write it as navigate cell navigating
cell
right now
create that
Ctrl k
let me select sheet 2 and the select
recipe is A1 press ok now what did what
what's the change right when you click
on this you will be redirected to sheet
to cell A1 navigate me to here right so
this can be like a shortcut when you
have multiple sheets like 100 sheets
then you can you know have yourself run
a different column over here and add the
navigation address to all those cell
links you can just click on that cell
and go into the different sheet and to
the specific cell which you have given
the address in our case I have given
sheet to address cell A1 right so this
is another trick now let's get back to
the hyperlink thing again uh Ctrl K and
another option is create new document so
you might have been through you know
option of uh having
let's say some cheat sheets or clip-on
clipboards right so let us imagine that
you're working through a huge worksheet
and you wanted to you know have a track
of everything and keep notes updating
right so it might be a little
complicated to understand so let me show
it practically so let me write it down
as clipboard or sticky note
okay I think this has a hyperlink let us
okay this can't be used no worries
go back to
uh hyperlink option again
create new document
now here you can create a variety of
documents right so it can be a text
document it can be an Excel document it
can be a PDF document right for now
we'll create a text document okay uh
we'll name it as a Tracker
Dot txt
so this should create as a text document
and the location can be anything so you
can you know take it as a desktop
documents download so let me take
documents here and select ok so I'll be
having this tracker.txt located in the
documents folder
and you can also choose to edit a
document later or edit the document now
let us select edit the document now
press OK and there you go so you have
your text tracker here so let us imagine
that we have worked on the Excel sheet
and we wanted to write down as a sticky
note so that we can remember what we
have done on the Excel sheet so update
one
and update to now we can close it so
it'll ask for a save option save it and
done and let us imagine that you did
something else and you also updated
something else on the sticky note I'm in
Excel sheet and you wanted to update
that on your sticky note so click on it
and you'll see a miner notice over here
from Microsoft Excel based on potential
security concerns you can select PS and
you'll be having access to your text
document again and write down your
update again here update three what you
have written right in the latest update
we have
foreign
so that's how you keep track of your
sticky note and you'll have all your
updates right
now getting back to the hyperlinks again
so the last one is email address
so you can also try to add okay let's
imagine that you're working with a
colleague and every time you make an
update in your Excel sheet or anything
and you wanted to send them out an email
right so it would be a little time
consuming that you open your email and
come post something and send it over
here but what if we had a one single
click and access to the email compose
option right that can be done so let us
write down email
actually
let me with the spelling
so again the Ctrl K and hyperlink select
email option and you can write down your
email
which can be anything so you can write
down your friend's email address
so I'm just writing down some random
email here
friend gmail.com and
you can write a subject about update
and press OK this will navigate you to
the Gmail option or the mailing address
options
click on it and you'll have a variety of
mailing options Outlook Office 365 Yahoo
iCloud Google Etc so you can select any
one of those since we have written as
gmail.com we'll navigate to Gmail and
all you have to do is log in you know
all the formalities and you're good to
go with emailing
so let's get this one now so yeah you
know how to do the rest parts
so so far we have you know covered all
the hyperlink options in Excel that has
existing file or a web page place this
in the current executive worksheet or
document creating a new document for
your update thing and also including the
email right so so far we have covered
everything around happening in Excel and
if you have anything to know more about
or if you feel that we have missed out
anything important regarding hyperlink
in Excel you can feel free to let us
know so you can see that we have got
started with Microsoft Excel and on the
left hand side we have a simple table
with all the teams in an ID industry
starting from it admin testing
development to client consultant support
we have got everything in this
particular table
now our main idea is to find out the
index of these particular elements for
example if you wanted to find the index
of the element of marketing then how
could you do it so here let's try to use
the match function in Excel for that we
found lookup value and position so on
the right hand side you can see that
I've created two separate columns as
lookup value and positions so in the
lookup value column we will be inserting
the value of which you want to find the
index now
for example let us consider that we want
to find the index value of Team
marketing
so I'll be writing Marketing in this
particular lookup value
now how to find the index value of the
element marketing for that we will be
using the match function in Excel
now after writing the match function you
can see that it is asking for three
different parameters so the first one is
the lookup value second is the lookup
array and lastly we have match type so
lookup value is the value of which you
are trying to find the index that is
marketing this particular cell so we
have selected the lookup value which is
the first one next we have to select the
lookup array that is from which set of
elements you want to find the index so
the set of elements are this it admin
testing the column which we have created
the a column now we have selected the
lookup array and lastly the match type
is it you're looking for less than or is
it you are looking for exact match or is
it greater than match so for now I want
exact match so I will be selecting the
exact match that is 0.
now there you go you have the exact
index of the element that is 5. now we
have selected all the 10 teams starting
from it1 admin 2 testing 3 development 4
marketing 5. so that's how you find the
index of a selected element in Excel
now we just have like 10 elements so we
have got the uh writing of the elements
or you know choosing the elements in an
easy way but what if if we had like 100
elements right it could be a little
different okay so let me put it simple
now you wanted to find the index value
of Finance so right now we have
marketing and you wanted to type in
finance and
you missed out a letter A
okay now you're not finding the right
index
to avoid such problems you can always
take the help of data validation in
Excel that is using the list in data
validation in Excel you can see a small
drop down icon here right you can choose
that and here you can see all the teams
that we have created in the left column
right so here I can scroll down and
choose the finance and there you go I
have the index value okay again we need
to copy paste the same match function in
Excel over here
equals to match
lookup value
lookup array
and exact match
so there you go that's how you make use
of data validation in Excel and using
the list you can comprehend all the list
elements in this particular column into
the list of data validation and we can
choose the team whichever you want to
find the index for so this is how you
can make use of match function in Excel
or index match function in Excel to sort
data in Excel so on my spreadsheet you
can see some employee data and on the
column F and the g you can see employee
date of birth and employee native
joining for example you wanted to sort
the employee data in the form of
earliest joining employee and the latest
joining employer right that is who is
the employee who joined first to this
company and who is the employer who
joined loss to this company so for that
you just need to select the column of
date so let's select both the columns
and go to home and check or verify if
the data type is date or not so
generally the data type will be set to
General by default by Excel so we need
to make sure that we have the proper
data type which is State now that we
have the proper data type select the
entire column and go to the data option
and here select the sort option add in
the sort option select the expand
selection click on sort and here
sort by employee date of joining and
hold us to news that's what we wanted
the oldest template or the you can also
set it to the newest employer to hold
this according to your requirement but
we'll go to oldest to newest according
to the case study right now just click
on OK and that should be done so Emily
was a manager is the oldest employee who
joined the company and Chris who's a
trainee and it support is the latest
employer who joined the company now
that's how you sort date in now on my
screen you can see the sales of four
quarters from different regions that is
east west south north and Central now
you might want to calculate the sum of
sales happened from all the regions in
q1 or you might want to calculate the
sum of sales happened in one region of
all the four quarters
that is either you want to calculate the
sum of all the regions from quarter 1 or
you might want to calculate the sum of
all the quarters in one region right so
to do this you have some simple
functions in Excel so you might say me
you have some function Etc right so that
you might want to go into the you know
equals to mode and fetch some option and
subtotal or sum UPS you have to select
the function from here but what if I
tell you that there is one simple easy
shortcut where you just have to make one
single click and you'll have all the sum
right so that seems interesting so on
the top in the home bar select home and
in on the top right corner you have the
editing group in editing group you have
aggregation function that is summation
so you have different aggregations here
some average count numbers maximum
minimum more functions here you might
want to select the sum and you can get
all summation numbers here
so I'll select one cell so the second
query where we wanted to calculate the
sum of all the sales happened in east
region with all the quarters included
that is this one C2 to f 2 right so let
us select J2 and
select the autosum option and here it
will automatically select the range for
you that is C2 to F2 if you want to
change it can also you know change it
like minimize the number if you just
wanted to calculate the sum of three
quarters you can do that so now we want
to four quarters so select enter and
there you go you have all the sales of
all the four quarters of east region now
if you simply drag it you will have the
sum of all the four quarters of all
different regions
now let us calculate the summation of q1
of all the regions that is this one
select autosum and it will automatically
select all the cells for you
that is from C2 to C6 right press enter
and you'll have the summation similarly
you can you know drag it and you have
the numbers here of all the Q2 sales for
all the regions Q3 sense of fall region
and Q4 sales of all region
now let us try to change the colors that
you can have a reference that is it's
different it's it's this total sum or
right you just have a reference to
identify it
now similarly to this one as well
so that's how you implement Auto sum in
Excel now we are on the Excel
spreadsheet so you can see that I have
five different sheets of the same data
so why do we have that so I'll be
explaining you how to sort data for
multiple parameters so firstly we will
try to sort data in the form of numbers
right so let us imagine that this data
is being shared with you by your manager
and he wants you to sort this data based
on the salary numbers so he wants you to
arrange the data in the form of
ascending order or descending order may
be which will help him find the employee
with the highest salary right so how
could you do that
so it's really simple you could sort the
entire data just within a few clicks so
how would you do that so since you're
focusing on salary select any cell from
the salary column only right select this
particular column and select any cell in
the salary column get into the sort and
filter options and here select this sort
of arrangement you need that is largest
or smallest or the smallest to largest
since the problem statement was to find
the highest salary click on largest to
smallest and there you go so you have
Tony and the designation senior and he
works in IIT support and he draws the
highest salary of eighty thousand right
and there's also another one which is
pepper and she works for the analytics
team
and now
the next sheet let's get into the sheet
too and this time let us imagine that
you wanted to you know uh arrange or
sort the data based on the employee date
of joining or date of birth right again
if you wanted to arrange the data in
which you find the youngest employee or
the oldest employee of the organization
you can do that click on any cell in the
date of birth column and go back to the
sort and filter and here you will be
seeing the options sort oldest to the
newest or the sort the data from us to
the oldest so since we want the oldest
employee select oldest and newest and
the echo so the oldest employee is
Alfred who is an associate designation
employee and he works in the admin
department and he's throwing the salary
of 25 000. so that's how you can sort
the data when you are trying to sort the
data based on date wise so first we try
to sort the data on the number wise so
you can apply the same for your employee
ID salary and if there is any
possibility you can do that as well and
if you want to apply the same sorting
based on dates you can do that as well
using the Sorting function in the same
way now let's get back on to the third
sheet and here
now uh single column wise is perfectly
fine there is no issues with that now
you wanted to you know uh let us imagine
that you have two columns okay let's
eliminate a few columns here
Maybe
we can eliminate the employee ID and
okay let's keep a few columns so we'll
just keep employee name and employee
salary
okay so here we are trying to
demonstrate if you are trying to sort
the data using one cell in the column B
will it maintenance relationship with
the cell a okay uh that's our query
right so let's see I'll go a little
detail so let us imagine that you wanted
to sort this data based on highest
salary okay so when you do that will it
also impact the cells in the column A so
it will basically impact but just uh
it's a query right any of you viewers
might have that variable I uh if in case
if I try to sort the data based on this
will it affect the sales on the rest of
the data set okay so in basically it
will impact so I'll try to you know sort
the data based on ascending order
foreign
[Music]
and pepper so since I selected the cell
in the column B it also impacted the
change on the cells of column A so
that's how the Sorting works now we'll
get to a little Advanced sorting
techniques so here we try to I mean
already we try to sort the data based on
numbers based on alphabets based on you
know uh date of birth right so I think
we forgot the uh ascending or you know
sorting based on alphabets let's do that
as well select any um cell in the column
A and go to certain filter try selecting
a to z or okay let's try to Z to it okay
so here you can see the names have been
sorted based on the descending order
from Z to A right so so far we tried on
alphabets so far we tried on numbers
date of birth and
a couple of more things so let's dig a
little deeper and try to sort based on
colors right so for that you don't uh
you know find that uh extra setting here
in the regular certain filter so you
might want to get into the data option
and yeah you'll find another sort
function which is a little at once so
that's how you do it so since we have
colored in this cell or column of salary
select that salary and we're going with
cell value so in the cell values section
select the cell color and here on the
cell color options you'll have green
blue and yellow that's what we have used
in our cells so let's keep Green in the
first position which is on top and press
ok now you'll see greens means ordered
at the first position now yellow and
blue are left up so why is that so
because you didn't provide it right so
you can do what that as well I mean you
can always add the setting to it
right select any cell go to sort and add
a level and then again select the salary
and sell values to sell colors and now
the cell color in the second position
would be blue
and that will be on bottom and I can add
another level
the same salary
the cell values will be cell color and
cell yellow will be somewhere in between
our bottom
okay so based on hierarchy it will be
selecting press ok
and
there you go so you have cell yellow and
blue at the bottom and green at the top
position as per your suggestions
now we are on the last sheet so here in
this last sheet we are going to you know
um dig a little deeper into the advanced
sorting methods so previously we tried
to apply the advanced sorting methods
for colors now we'll try to apply the
advanced sorting methods based on the
data set we have here I mean the data we
have in our data set right so select the
sort option and let's add a few details
right so firstly let's sort the column
employee ID okay so let's have this
smallest to largest or
yeah now that would be good now let's
add another level where we will sort
okay uh I think we will sort based on
employee that would be a little better
so let's try to uh sort it on employment
name here and here will be employee
salary
okay now the cell values and this would
be from A to Z and the salary will be
from the smallest to largest so
basically what we are trying to do is we
are trying to sort the employee list
based on employment from A to Z so the
employee's name starting from A to Z
will be ordered first and another subset
of the Sorting will be done based on
highest salaries that is smallest
highest so let us imagine that we have
three employees with name starting from
a and their salaries are ten thousand
twenty thousand and thirty thousand so
how would it sort Circle sort basically
uh in the alphabetical order first so
first three names will be sorted and
then it will also have another condition
to sort the data where keeping the lower
salary on top and higher salary and the
last right so uh this is how the
algorithm works for sorting now let's
press OK and see the output
so there you go the names are Alfred and
you have the highest salary here
smallest to highest so this is 25 000
next we have Banner bonds and Ben so
here you might be seeing why we have
been in the third position despite he
has a low salary and name starts with B
right so here it is trying to work based
on the alphabets in the order right so B
A and B E it's not just comparing the
first letter it's also comparing the
following letters as well right so n
comes first R comes later so bonds is
pushed to the second position a comes
first and E comes later so B A let us R
push to the first position and Ben is
pushed to the third position so that's
how A2 works right so accordingly the
set for B A is created here 3540 next
Ben 12 and next you have Bobby Brown
Brock Chris Clark right so that's how
the data has been organized and sorted
based on multiple levels of parameters
you provide for sorting so that's how
you use sorting in Excel slicers and
filters in Excel
so slices in Excel are software filters
used along with Excel tables or Excel
pivot tables over a large amount of data
not just filtering out data but slices
also help you with an easy understanding
of the information being extracted and
displayed on the screen now Microsoft
Excel slices are compatible with Windows
and Macintosh operating systems now let
us understand how to implement slicers
in Excel so for that we might want to
get back to the Practical mode that is
starting a Microsoft Excel
now we are on our Excel sheet and as you
can see on my screen there is some data
available on the Excel spreadsheet and
this table is not just any table this
table from Microsoft Excel has been
converted into an actual table as you
know by default Excel considers all the
data which has been inserted into the
spreadsheet as a database and to
implement this slices in Excel we might
want to create or convert the format of
database into a normal table for that
you can select all your data and just
press Ctrl T and that will allow you an
option called convert the data into
table
now since this table is already
converted as a table we can directly
start implementing or inserting slices
into the spreadsheet
now for that select all your data
then go into the insert option
and in the insert ribbon you can see the
filters group and and the filters group
select the option called slicer now you
will be provided with multiple options
since we have the columns employee ID
employee name Zone designation
Department salary employees date of
birth and employees date of Journey so
we can choose any of the options
available according to our columns and
create the slices now let me select the
first one that is Zone next designation
department and let's also select
employee name
now press OK and there you go we have
our slices
now let's try to rearrange these slices
all you can do is just select and drag
them up
and done now let us imagine that we want
to see or take a look at the employees
who are working in the East Zone then we
have all the information displayed on
the screen who are working in the East
Zone they are Jack Tony Banner Fred Etc
and their Department designation etc etc
all on one single screen so this really
helps you while you're presenting your
data in a presentation now for a change
let's try to select the department now
if your client wants to select the data
from only analytics Department then you
might want to select on the analytics
key on the department slicer and there
you go you have an employee called look
hops who works in the East Zone and his
department is analytics and his
resignation is contract based and the
salary he is getting is 65
000.
now similarly
uh you can see that we have only
selected analytics and your client also
wants data from it support now you can
see that analytics is gone
but what if we want both analytics and
ID support then you have an option
called selected multiple then you can
select analytics and ID support and if
you want HR you can also do that and in
this Zone if you want West along with
East then you can do the same east and
west and you have all the employee
details and in the designation let's try
to select the senior trainee okay select
multiple senior trainee and manager so
that's how you do it
so that's how it's done and that's how
you implement slicers in Excel to
simplify the filtering options using
slicers during a presentation it is
really simple to add filters in Excel so
we are on a practical mode right now so
on my screen you can see an Excel
spreadsheet of sales data so here you
have various columns regions category
state subcategory sales quantity and
much more right so now let us imagine
that we want to add filters on the
region part so we have southwest east
Etc right so we want to you know let us
imagine that you want to extract the
data of only west region and you wanted
a filter so doing it manually could take
a lot of time so using filters will be
helpful now select one cell on the
headers part and select the filter
option in the data toolbar you can see
the date option on the toolbar right so
click on the data option and navigate to
sort and filter group and in that select
the option of filter now you can see the
film are been added to all the column
headers region category state
subcategory sales quantity right now we
wanted the West category so when you see
or when you click on the drop down icon
you can see all the options are selected
right the central east west south every
everything right but now we just want
West one so click on West and select OK
there you go so you have everything from
the west region now let's imagine that
you wanted to look into office supplies
only or technology only right you can do
the same with technology and press OK
and now you'll have all the technology
related sales in the west region right
so that's how you use filters in Excel
or that's how you add filters in Excel
allow me to introduce post graduate
program in data analytics by simply
learn just take a quick look at the
features followed by the skills you will
gain through this course some key
features of this comprehensive program
includes exclusive hackathons and
editing sessions by IBM eight times
higher LIVE edition in live online
classes by industry experts Capstone
from three domains and 14 plus data
analytics projects with industry data
sets from Google Play Store Lyft World
Bank Etc masterclass was delivered by
Purdue faculty and IBM experts simply
learns job assist helps you to get
noticed by top hiring companies and much
much more it is well said when skills
Empower possibilities flourish to grab
the opportunities gain skills like data
analytics statistical analysis using
Excel data analysis Python and R data
visualization Tableau and power bi and
much more so what are you waiting for
hurry up and enroll Now find the course
Link in the description box
so what is data validation in Excel so
it is a feature by Microsoft Excel where
it can restrict data entry into certain
cells by using data validation
and it will prompt the users to enter
valid data in the cells based on the
rules and restrictions provided by the
creator of that particular sheet now
this would be a little confusing to
understand so to understand it in a much
better way let's get back to the
practical way where we will start
entering some data validation rules to
our Excel sheet and try to enter data
into it now we are on the Microsoft
Excel and this particular sheet is based
on employee ID employee name employee
Department employee salary fiscal year
and work timings of the employees
now we will be applying some data
validation rules to each and every
column and try to enter data based on
the rows we have entered now for the
first one which is the employee ID we'll
enter rules based on the employee ID
number so to apply the data validation
you need to go into the data tab on the
toolbar
and inside the ribbon you can see data
tools group and in the data tools group
you have the option of data validation
now select the entire column go to the
data tools group select data validation
option and you will have this particular
pop-up menu
and here you can see different types of
options so since we are entering
employee ID it would be a whole number
so let us select whole number option and
now here you can see the option of
between not equal to equal to not
between greater than less than Etc
so let us select between
and let us assume that your employee ID
has five numbers and it should be
between 10 000 to
11 000.
so let us provide 10 000
and 11 000.
now select ok
and now the new rule has been applied
so now the minimum value of each and
every employee ID should be equal to or
more than 10 000 and less than 11 000
and it should have five digits
now let's try to enter a wrong employee
ID that is just one
there you go you can see that Microsoft
Excel is not allowing you to include a
wrong number it says this value does not
match the data validation restrictions
defined for this cell so now you can
press retry and try to enter some number
which is in between 10 000 to 11 000.
now it is 10901 and this will take the
entry
now let us assume that because I am the
creator of this I know what should
be entered here but what if I give this
to you and you are the person who
is trying to enter the number and it
shows the error and you don't know what
was the error right to avoid this kind
of confusion what you can do is you can
do some uh ways where you can provide
the message to the user so that can be
done by okay let's select this sheet
again and go to the data validation and
here you have the same settings now here
you have another option saying input
message
so before input message let us go to
error alert now here
the error title will be data entered
is not valid
please enter this is the error message
please enter
EMP
ID
between
10 000 to 11 000.
press ok
now when you try to enter the wrong
number it will show that particular
error alert message
see data entered is not valid please
enter employee ID between 10 000 to 11
000. now this is fine but how long this
will be you know what if there is an
option where you just hover over to the
cell and it automatically tells you to
enter the value between ten thousand to
eleven thousand without having to face
the error yeah even that can be done so
you can select
the entire column go to data validation
and here this is the input message this
is where you can do that
so here you can write the message name
valid data
please enter
data between
10 000 to
11 000 now when you hover over to any
excel in this particular column it will
automatically show you this message
where you can avoid all the errors
just select OK see when you select any
cell in this particular column it will
automatically tell you please enter data
between ten thousand to eleven thousand
so here you don't have to face any
errors right now let us try to enter the
valid data
1 0 9
0 2
and it will take it as the correct value
and again 1 0 9 0 3.
now in case if you try to provide the
wrong number it will show the error
see
so that's how it is now we have finished
the whole number part now let's get into
the employee name where we have to
provide
the second type that is
text length now let us imagine that uh
in your company you're trying to provide
ID cards to your employees and you know
that ID card is really small and inside
that ID card you need to include the
employee photograph and your company
name employee ID blood group phone
number address everything and also you
need to include the name of the employer
so what if there is an employer with
very lengthy name like 30 characters 40
characters yeah in India it is really
possible that you might have a lengthy
name so what you can do is you can
provide the text length where the text
is limited to like 15 or 20
characters so you can include that name
in the ID card so you can do that by
allowing the data validation criteria
with text length minimum can be anything
so minimum can be one and maximum here
you can provide 15. and press ok
OK minimum will change it to at least
two
and
yeah let it be one so minimum is one and
maximum is 15 characters and press ok
and let us also provide the input
message
enter
character type character data
please enter valid name
error alert
invalid data
please enter validator
please enter characters
less than
50.
press ok
now let us try to enter a random name
okay we'll enter characters more than 15
here quality
0 ID
yeah it's like one two three four five
eleven
okay now this is more than 15.
okay I think it's not more than 15.
let's try to enter a little bit more
characters
foreign
more than 15 characters and it is
showing please enter characters less
than 15. so now we can retry and try to
enter some valid name
um
now we have characters less than 50 so
it will take as the proper name
now let us try to enter another name
oh
so I'm just entering some random data
so another name maybe
great now the next type of data
validation is also done now let us get
into employee Department employee
department is something really superb so
I'll tell you about it it's actually a
list now let us finish the other ones
first that is employee salary fiscal
year and work timings after that we'll
learn about the list one
now let's come into employee salary so
salary is something where you have to
include decimal points so now let us go
to a data validation and inside the
values we have already dealt with whole
number
uh text length
yeah now we'll deal with employee salary
that is decimal
now minimum is okay what is the uh
minimum can be one
point zero zero and maximum can be
one lakh
point zero zero or let us
put that as 10 lakhs
press ok
okay not not just them and enter valid
salary
okay now let's change it to minimum is
10 000.
so the employee minimum salary will be
10 000 and input enter valid salary
and uh
salary
between
ten thousand
to 10 lakhs
let us include a comma here too
now error alert
salary
please enter
between
10 000
to 10 lakhs
press ok now the message and the data
validation conditions are applied to
this column now let us try to enter some
invalid data first
it will show the error
now we need to enter the valid data
CM now it is taking the valid data let
us provide twenty thousand
and this is 35 000.
now the next one is fiscally let us
imagine that we wanted to you know work
on the employees for current working
gear that is 2020 to 2021 and or you can
consider 2021 to 2022 not more than 2021
and not less than 2021. for that you can
provide the year option as well so for
that you need to select the entire
column go to data validation settings
and inside here you have an option of
date
so let us provide the date option as
between and start date is 0 1 0 1 slash
2021 and end date is
0 1 0 1 slash
and input message
let us provide it as current
fiscal year
Current financial year
date
between
2021 to 2022.
let us copy this and go into error alert
error message will be saved
invalid
[Music]
select ok now there are message and and
the data input message and the data
validation rule has been applied for
this column so let's try to enter some
date here
you can enter 0 2 of February
2021 it will take as the correct data
now let's try to enter some wrong data
which is apart from 2020 to 0 to 0 2
22 it will not take this it will throw
error
so that's how it works now let us try to
enter as 2021
and this is March
it will take it now another data
0 4 this time and 2021
so that's how your date data validation
will work now coming into the next type
of data validation that is time
so we have time here let us imagine that
you are providing some work timings to
your employees that should be from 9 am
to 5 PM not more than that so you want
to keep your work life balanced for all
your employees so you just want them to
work between nine to five and that
should be fine and anything apart from
that time should be invalid so you can
do that by selecting a Time option
between it should be in between and the
start time will be 0 9
0 0
and this should be
uh
17.
that is 5 PM in the evening
and input message
please enter
time between
9 am
to
okay
5 PM
this should be the input message
now error alert
invalid time
error message
now
okay work timings now
this should be okay
we can do this as two columns actually
let us
cancel
let us copy this and paste it here
you can do it as login
timing and this should be okay
this should be a log out
so this should be
okay so this will be considered as login
and logout times
now let us provide the login time
this should be the right time and let's
try to provide wrong timings zero eight
now it will not take it it will throw as
error
so it's working fine let us provide 10
now let us provide the logout time it
should be below 5 PM
so let us provide five it will take it
okay
let's try to provide something just one
minute less than five
that is 59
okay there is some problem in this let's
check it
okay it is taking uh three that is
including seconds
okay let's provide seconds as well
zero five zero zero so
Crystal there is some problem
[Music]
foreign
timing right
okay it should be 17. I think this will
work yeah
now we are following 24 hour timing here
so let's provide another timing that is
300 this will be valid and 1530
this is also value now we have finished
almost all types of uh data validation
things that is we have finished with any
value whole number decimal date timing
test length and the last one is list so
this is where things get interesting now
let's cancel this now
select the employee column now if you
are running a company then definitely
you will not have only one Department in
it you might have multiple departments
right so let us consider that you have a
software development company
so in that the basic departments will be
software development team and software
testing
so what you can do is you can provide a
list
so using that list you can just hover
over to that cell select the drop down
menu and inside that you can select the
option so we will try to work something
like that if we have selected the entire
column
the selection up here
yeah let us select the entire column
again go to data validation
the selection contains some cells
without data validation settings do you
want to extend data validation to the
cells yes
now let us provide the list option
and
here Source you can provide us
developer
and test
press OK OK
now input message
select one
error alert
invalid
data
select from drop down
only
press ok
now when you select the cell you can see
small drop down icon right so when you
press it you will have developer and
tester option
so you can select developer for first
one and for second one you can select
tester
right okay this is good for uh one or
two options maybe three or even maybe
like five but what if you have more
departments okay let's go to this uh
second sheet where we have the
department data so here we have like 14
departments no 15 departments or 15
employee type names so the first one is
see your second list developer tester
quality analyst system analyst Finance
human resource so so many options are
there so you cannot keep on typing all
of them right so here it is 15 what if
you have like 25 like 50 departments
right it will be tough so for this you
have another option so let me select all
this data and copy this from this sheet
to our employee sheet
let us paste it somewhere
here
let's expand this
okay now we have our list over here now
let us remove the data validation from
this column
clear all okay now everything is clear
let's select ok now let us erase this
data as well
now let us apply the list data
validation again from scratch go to list
now here we can select the source
select this particular cell
and drag it until here and it has been
loaded
now go to input message
data options
select one
from the menu or the drop down
copy error alert
select only from the drop down menu
invalid entry yeah
now let's select ok
fine now you have the icon here you have
all the provided options
you can scroll down and select any one
of these you can select knowledge
transfer for the first one
and second one would be
system analyst
and the last one would be
human resources
now in the list everything is fine okay
this is showing you the menu options and
everything
so but what if you provide this sheet to
your new Journey or new employee in your
company and by mistake he messes up
something like deleting this okay so we
have deleted systems analyst and when
you click on the options here you don't
have systems analyst in that place you
have blank space right so there is a way
where all your you know data can be
messed up so to avoid this what you can
do is
you can actually
um
save this data in a different sheet like
I did here like Department data you can
hide this sheet or you can protect the
sheet with password or something so that
nobody can mess this up so now let us
get back to the employee data and select
this column and uh clear everything
press ok
and let us also clear this
and this as well in this one too
now let us eliminate the rows our cells
the employee everything
okay now we have basically removed this
data from here
now let us try to apply the data
validation once again
now here
let us select as list
and
here let us provide the option
let us go to next sheet let us select
all these options
press ok
OK let's provide input message
data options
are Department options
particularly
yeah now let's select ok
now let's hide this sheet
the sheet has been hidden and you still
have the options
developer
or let us provide see you
then we have developer
then we have
test
so that's how you can protect your how
to protect and lock cells in Excel now
why do we need to lock our protect cells
in Excel
let us imagine that there is an Excel
sheet with really confidential data and
you need to pass that data to your
subordinate or equally to make some
minor edits now let us imagine that the
edits are supposed to be done to only
one or two columns and the rest of the
columns should be left as they are now
there is a huge possibility that
sometimes unknowingly or unwillingly
there might be some edits done by a
curly or your subordinate So to avoid
such kind of unexpected mistakes you
might want to protect and lock yourself
that you don't want your subordinate or
your colleague to edit so before we
begin be kind enough to get subscribed
to our YouTube channel and don't forget
to hit that Bell icon to stay updated on
the latest it Trends and Tech content
now without further Ado let's get
started with our one point agenda that
is lock or protect cells in Excel now
let's get back into the Practical mode
and start our Microsoft Excel now we are
on the Microsoft Excel and this
particular spreadsheet is related to
employer details
yeah now the screen is visible a bit
better now let us imagine that this is
our confidential data and you want to
edit only two columns that is the
designation column and phone number
column now let us imagine that the
company has finished one annual year and
now there are some promotions happening
in the company and let us also imagine
that the phone numbers of the employees
provided by the company have undergone
some changes so now the minor edits that
you want to make are related to the
designation column and phone number
column now you can see that all the
columns that is the blood group new
salary salary hike current salary and
name of the employee serial number
employee number everything is editable
so in such kind of scenarios when you
pass on this data there might be a
possibility where your colleague or
subordinate might end up making some
mistakes right so you want to avoid that
so you can do that by locking the cells
now let us rename this sheet
now the sheet has been renamed
successfully so now you can log the
cells by the following process
so in this process you have two major
steps first one is to lock the cells and
the next one is to protect the cells by
a password now when you select all the
cells in this particular sheet you can
just click on this edge here and you
have all the cells selected and now
right click somewhere on the sheet and
you can see an option called format
cells
so in this particular option you have
some options provided which is number
alignment font and you want to go into
the protection part so you can see by
default Excel keeps all the cells locked
now we want the phone number and
designation to be unlocked okay so let's
cancel it for now and get back to the
sheet and select the columns D and I
and now let's right click and go into
format cells and in the protection
option make sure that you uncheck the
locked icon now select OK and now
okay so you cannot include the merge to
sell fine we have a cell here which is
merged okay let's remove that
foreign
okay now again select the entire column
right click get into format cells and
uncheck the log option select ok
now we have finished the first part that
is locking all the cells which you don't
want to get added and unlocking the
cells where you want to make some edits
now the second stage is protecting the
sheet now right click on the sheet name
and you can see an option called protect
sheet click that and now here you can
see select love cells and also select
unblocked cells so let us provide a
password here so let us use some simple
password so that we don't forget that so
I'll be selecting one two three and now
select ok
re-enter the password to proceed now let
us type 1 2 3 again now select OK and
now the sheet is protected
now we have successfully locked and
protected all the cells in Excel now let
us verify that the cells you wanted to
protect are really protected and locked
or not so we have unlocked phone number
and designation and everything else is
locked now let me try and edit the blood
group so when I double click or try to
edit this particular sheet then I'll be
receiving a warning from Excel it says
the cell or chart you're trying to
change is on a protected sheet to make a
change unprotect the sheet you might be
requested to enter a password
so it says that this particular cell is
locked and you cannot edit it now let us
try to edit the phone numbers which we
kept as unlocked
so you can see I can really edit the
unclogged cell here now let me try to
change this phone number let me enter
some random phone number
so you can see the cell is editable now
let us go through the designation column
and try to edit this particular column
now since I said that there is a
promotion happening in the company so
the deputy CEO is now the current CEO of
the company
and software developer happens to become
the senior software developer
and the tester as well let us imagine
that he will become the senior
and so on
okay so this proves that this particular
sheet is editable not the entire sheet
but only the sense that we kept in the
analog mode
okay
now this is how you lock and protect
your cells in Excel you can see that I
have sales data on my worksheet so let
us imagine that your manager asks you to
find the average of sales happening in
your company right so let's navigate to
the bottommost cell and you know write
it down as average here
okay average sales
so here this is a cell where you want to
keep your average right so here we'll be
writing a small formula that is average
and tap to select it now you must select
the array of data right
so this is my array since average is an
array function and now press enter so
there you go you have the average sales
data that happened in your company
so to understand the page setup in Ms
Excel we will go through a demo
inventory in Excel where we'll be
considering some restaurant data
now without any delay let's get started
with the Practical demo now we are on
the extent sheet and this is the data I
was talking about the restaurant data
where we have the First Column that is
Rank and next we have the restaurant
name followed by that we have the sales
happening through that restaurant and
then we have the segment category that
is what kind of service does that
particular restaurant offers now this is
the list what we made and what if we
wanted to represent this data and form
of a printed paper right so I guess you
can see all the columns and rows here so
you can see that we have almost like 250
rows so there is no chance or there is
no way to print all those 250 rows in
one page of course it is practically
possible but when you try to read the
content it'll be so tough to read
Because all the rows will be club
together so closely so that you cannot
read it so uh you need to print them
Page by page so and you need to also
take care of the data is aligned
properly according to the page size
everything and even you need to take
care of the margins of your page right
so that's what page setup basically
means
so we had a detailed overview of our
data and what actually we are trying to
make now let us see how page setup is
possible in Ms Excel so to go to the
page setup menu or go to the page setup
options we have three methods let's
start with the simplest method so the
simplest method is by just clicking on
file and go to print option
and you'll see all the page setup
options right over here
and you can also go to print menu by
pressing a shortcut method that is Ctrl
p
so you'll directly end up on the page
setup options now let's look at the
second method so the second method is
you can see the toolbar over here right
which has file home insert draw page
layout formulas data review View and
help so the second method we can use
page layout option from the toolbar and
you can see when you click on the page
option from the toolbar you have a new
ribbon over here so this ribbon is all
about page setup options so it will
offer you margins it will offer you
orientation size print area breaks
background print tiles etc etc right so
all these options are menus in this
ribbon belong to page setup now let us
look at the third method so the third
method is something similar you have
view option on the toolbar so just
select View and you can see we have few
page setup options over here as well the
normal page break page layout custom
views and we have gridlines formula bar
heading zoom and zoom out select to zoom
free certain pins right so all these are
also the page setup options so we have
the three methods to enter the page
setup options now we are familiar
earlier with those now let's get started
with the Practical mode on page setup
for that let me use the simplest method
that is holding the control key and
pressing P which navigates me to the
print option
now we have various set of options here
we have no scaling normal margins letter
portrait orientation collated print
active sheets and Note 1 for Windows you
can see this option is the printers
option for example if you are connected
to a printer which is the hardware
printer then your Ms Excel will show the
printer's name here so other than
printer you can also make some other
arrangements where you can just directly
print your complete data in the form of
PDF and then you can export your PDF to
your recipient that's also possible okay
now let's get started with the first
option that is print active pages okay
to understand this better we need to
create a new sheet not a problem so you
can see that we just have one sheet over
here
so let us kind of select all the items
and create a new sheet and try to paste
it over here
or let's try to paste it over here
okay now let's try to extend these
yeah this should be fine now let's
rename this sheet
sheet
or let's rename it as
restaurant
sheet 2.
for our reference now let us get back to
the print sheet option so I'll use the
shortest method that is holding the Ctrl
key and press P now you can see that
here we have six pages in total from the
active sheets so the current active
sheet is the top 250 sheet so this
particular sheet is the current active
sheet so if we print the entire data in
this particular sheet then we will end
up printing six pages now let us select
the other option where you have to print
the entire workbook
right so now you can see that there is a
change in the number that is 12 pages so
what is a workbook so basically workbook
is the collection of entire sheets in
your Excel home page so in this
particular Excel homepage you have the
first sheet that is top 250 and the
second sheet that is the restaurant
sheet 2 right so the combination of
these two sheets make up a workbook
so when you select the entire workbook
option you'll have 12 pages so that's
how we use this setting where you select
the active sheets the entire workbook
and there is another option where you
can only print a selected item so if you
want to do this then let's get back here
now what if your customer or what if
your client wanted the top 10
restaurants only so you can select the
top 10 restaurants
bye doing this
now you have the top 10 restaurants
let's go to print
so you can see Excel has automatically
selected the selection only print the
selected content only so you can see we
have only the top 10 restaurants or top
11 restaurants that we have selected in
our sheet and it is ready to get printed
so this is how we use the first option
now let's get back
let's not select that and let's make the
pages normal now get back to the print
option again now you can see the next
option that is collated
right so in collated you have different
different options that is one two three
one two three and one two three and the
next one which is uncolated one one one
two two two three three three so why are
these numbers uh present here and what
does collected mean anyway so this is
your question right now the answer for
this question will be a little similar
to your examination Hall okay let us
imagine that you are an examination Hall
and you are the invisilator and you have
10 students in your room
so you wanted to provide question papers
to all the 10 students okay so you have
your question paper distributed into
three sheets that is you have marked
questions and your questions are fit
into three papers right in this scenario
we have 250 rows and all the data is
split into six sheets that is sheet 1 or
page 1 page two page 3 page four right
now if you wanted to print 10 copies
then the arrangement of papers will be
page 1 page 2 page three page 4 page
five page six in continuous order right
that is collated if you wanted 10 copies
of different different ways where you
wanted to print the first sheet first
then you wanted to print the second
sheet second and the third sheet third
that is you'll have 10 copies of first
page 10 copies of second page 10 copies
of third page and so on that particular
approach is called uncollated approach
and if you are printing the pages in
continuous order for 10 times then that
particular approach is called as
correlated approach so this is what we
had to learn about collated and
uncolluted now let's get back to the
third option
now let's press again print now we have
our data over here
there is something wrong
select all the elements Ctrl VP yeah now
we have our detail pack now we have the
third option that is the portrait
orientation okay so when we click that
we have two options that is portrait and
landscape so you might be having a good
idea like when you try to click a
picture in your phone we have two modes
as well that is portrait mode and the
landscape mode so when you click on the
portrait mode this is how your data will
be looking now to understand the
difference let's click the landscape
mode so when you click the landscape
mode this is how your data
representation will change you'll have a
wider page to print so this is why we
use the page orientation for now let's
keep the page orientation as portrait
orientation
and we have now the fourth option so
what is the fourth option we have
various sets of options in here that is
letter and A4 size there are also some
more page options over here where you
can select the page types you want to
print
so basically you'll be having few more
options that is A4 A5 A3 Etc but here we
just have two that is A4 and letter so
basically you will get those options and
followed by that next we have margins so
here you can see we don't have any
margins for our data okay so now we can
add some margins by setting up this one
as an option like last custom setting or
you can also choose normal wide narrow
right so your page will be changed
according to your margin size
right so this is how you can change the
margins now let's keep it as default
let's set the
normal one
now we have the next option that is
scaling option
so here you can see we are trying to fit
the page so when you're trying to print
these sheets using no scaling then the
actual size of the page will be printed
now you can also modify that you can fit
and print these sizes so you can
remember the first option that I said of
printing all the 250 rows in one single
sheet this is how you can fit it so fit
the sheet on one page where you can see
all the 250 rows are fit into one page
but the data is not readable so but we
don't want this type of an approach
right so let's keep it as the default
one which is no scaling so these are the
variety of options in print
now if you wanted to print the all the
six pages into the PDF format and mail
it to your client you can also do that I
think I have explained it in the first
place so you can see we can do it by
just selecting this option where you can
print all the six pages and into PDF
format and then you can mail them to
your client
and you can also select the number of
copies you want you can increase the
copies to 2 3 and any number of copies
you want for now I'll keep it as one
copy
[Music]
now let's print this
now let us select the
location
rename it and publish
now let's get back to documents and see
if the page is printed or not
here here we have the restaurant data in
the form of PDF
so we have our entire six pages of data
in the PDF format
now we are back on the home page now we
have some limited functions in the print
functions over here
we have tried to export the data so you
can also export the data or try to print
it from the print option over here you
can just select that as well
you need a new file
PDF
yes the pages are printed now
and then we have the restaurant to PDF
data
so that's how you can print all your
data you can either choose
the export option or you can either
choose print option now when you see
into the print option we have limited
number of page setup options over here
now let's check out what we missed so we
are in the page layout here so we had
gone through the margins we had set all
the margins and then we have also gone
through the portrait and landscape now
you can see this size when we were in
the print menu option we had only A4 and
letter but here you can see there are a
wide variety of options that is other
than later we have tabloid legal
statement executive A3 right we have A5
and many more other options and if you
want some more paper options you can go
to more and you can always select few
more options that's how you do it and
yeah we didn't had the break option so
remember when we had been through the
print option we did not have the break
option there
let's select this to normal A4 so you
cannot see the break option over here
right so here we have the brick option
so what does break option does right you
can actually break the page remember we
spoke about the top 10 things or the top
10 rows you can always do that so you
can just keep the top 10 restaurants in
your first page and then break the
remaining after set page breaks you can
select the cell now I need the top 10 so
I'll select this particular cell which
is in the 11th position
and now I'll try to implement the page
break insert a page break and now you
can see on my sheet there is a thin line
which is separating the two pages that's
how you can see the indication of app
page break implemented onto your page
now how do you see it you can see it by
selecting Ctrl P where you can see the
first top 10 restaurants being printed
on your sheet so there you go we have
the first top 10 restaurants printed on
our sheets so that's how you use the
page break
now let's try to eliminate all the page
breaks so you can select clicks and
reset all page breaks so the page break
has been eliminated
now you can always choose a background
for your data as well you just if you
want you can add a picture to your
background I think that's not
available for now
okay you can work offline as well let us
select this one
so you can see that we have added a
background to our data
we can select all the
text files and then you can change the
color so that the text becomes a little
visible
yeah that's how you do it now if you
don't want the image to be added on your
file you can also remove that delete
piece background and there you go all
the images are gone
now the next important part that is the
print titles
now why do we need print titles for that
let's try to print this
so now you can see the first page in the
first page we have the title rank
restaurant sales segment category but if
you go to the second page you don't have
that title right you don't have the
title rank name of the restaurant sales
and their service category so if we want
that then we need to add titles
now for that let's select the print
titles option now let's select the rows
to repeat on top
now for that we need the first row
select the first row and this particular
row will be repeating into all the pages
now let's try to print it
so yeah now you can see the titles are
being added to all the sheets you can
see the page 2 page 3 page 4 page 5 and
page six so you can see the title is
added to all the sheets now we are on
the spreadsheet so here what exactly are
page breaks so page breaks are something
which help you during your trying to
print your data or present your data in
the form of a web page right in those
times you cannot fit your entire Excel
data in one spreadsheet or one paper or
one web page right so in those scenarios
Excel will try to eliminate a few parts
of your spreadsheet or it will try to
split the spreadsheet
so how exactly it looks like so go to
the view option and click on The View
and click on page break review here you
can see the dotted lines right so these
are the things which separate your data
in form of pages so that it can be
printable on one single page
so some of the times the user or the X
User manually inserts a page break right
so how do you insert it just go to the
page layout and here you can see the
page breaks insert a page break and we
have successfully inserted a page break
again go to the view go to page preview
and here you can see the solid line so
these solid ones are the ones which are
inserted by the users or anyone who had
the access to the data now how do we
eliminate eliminated the page break and
face break preview to make sure that the
page break has been successfully removed
so you can not see that anymore so
that's how you try to insert or
eliminate a piece trick in Excel so
conditional formatting is a method to
visualize your worksheet we already have
the charts in Excel to visualize our
Excel sheets in graphical form but what
if you had to see or visualize the data
in your worksheet as it is so that is
where the condition formatting comes
handy now let's get back to the
Microsoft Excel and try to implement
some condition formatting now we are on
the Excel worksheet this particular data
set is based on a store now we have
various columns in this particular data
set we have row ID order ID customer
name Etc and finally we have quantity
discount and profits now let's go to
profits let us imagine that we have
provided this particular store with a
target of minimum 15 percent profits now
let us find out the stores that have hit
the 15 Target and the one specific note
so for that let us select the entire
column now you can find the conditional
formatting option in the home toolbar
and in that ribbon the ribbon with
Styles has the condition formatting
option click on that
and you have various options over here
highlighting the cells top bottom rules
data bars data scales and icons so data
bars are actually the bar graphs which
highlight themselves on each and every
cell if you implement them and these are
the color scales if you want to
implement some colors you can go through
that and if you want to represent
yourselves well icons you can also do
that for now let's highlight the cells
so select that and inside this select
the greater than option and here you can
provide the percentage that is 15
percent
and the cells or the stores which hit
the target should be highlighted with
the green color and select OK and there
you go you have your stores that hit the
15 Target and the ones which did not hit
the 15 Target now if we want to
highlight the ones which did not hit the
15 Target you can highlight them with
the color red
so
conditional formatting you highlight the
cells less than 15 percent with color
red and text dark
and there you go it's done now let us
consider another example so this
particular example is based on train
data set and here we have the passenger
ID survived passenger class name Etc now
we have a train accident incident over
here now one is indicated that there are
11 0 is indicated that they are not
alive now let us use this column and
conditional formatting highlight the
cells containing the text as one with
color green
okay
and
highlight the cells
that contain text 0 as the red that
indicates they are not alive
and let us select the icons
now we have the icons over here the X
indicates that they are not alive and
the green check mark indicates that they
are alive
now that is how you use conditional
formatting in Excel Excel now here on my
spreadsheet you can see some data so
this particular data has some color
markings so we have used color codes to
Mark the designations of all the
employees with different colors so for
example blue for manager purple for
senior and so on right now our duty is
to count the total number of employees
present in a company based on the color
code this can be done using filters but
let's try with color tools now we don't
have a readily available function in
Excel to count cells based on their
colors but we can make use of macro now
to make use of macro you might want to
enable the developer options so by
default these will be disabled in Excel
to enable them right click on the
toolbar
and you can see this particular option
click on the customize ribbon option and
you will be provided with various set of
options
now on the right side you can see
developer options
so make sure the check box is clicked to
enable developer options and press on OK
to completely enable developer window
right now when you click on developer
options you can see various options here
visual Basics macro Etc now click on the
macro to create a macro now just give a
name to the macro function so I'll give
simply learn
and press on create to create that
particular macro function so we have
already created a macro that is Count
colors as which we will be using in our
current spreadsheet for counting the
colored cells now let us erase the newly
created function
now getting back to the original code so
how does this particular count colored
cells works so let us understand the
function first then we will try to make
use of it in this spreadsheet so the
function name is Count colored cells as
you can see and this particular function
will have two parameters current cell
and spreadsheet area so the current cell
will be the cell address where the color
you want to count is present and then
the spreadsheet area so what is the
range of cells where you want to locate
that particular color and count the
number of repetitions that is the
spreadsheet area
and then comes the variables used
colored cell range color code and color
cell count so the colored cell which
particular cell is having that
particular color and what color code is
involved in that colored cell and
colored cell count so what is the total
count what is the total number of
colored cells you have in that
particular range that is colored cell
count now let us consider color code is
equals to current cell interior color
that is current cell dot interior dot
color so this is the function which will
identify the interior color of a
selected cell let us imagine that
initially color code is equals to the
current cells color code okay now we
will have the for Loop and that for Loop
will include colored cell which is the
current cell in the spreadsheet area and
if the colored cell the currently
selected colored cell dot interior dot
color is equals to the color code that
we have selected then colored cell count
the variable which is used to count the
number of colored cells is equals to
plus one initially by default it will be
0 in case if this particular if
condition is true that is the current
cell color and the color code given is
equals to same then the value of colored
cell will increase by 1. and this
particular if Loop will run as many
number of times the condition is true so
let us imagine that the condition will
remain true for five times then we have
obtained five similarly colored cells in
the given range of cells in a
spreadsheet and once the condition fails
then the latest value present in color
cell count variable will be displayed
which will be a final result so this is
how the macro function works now let's
close the macro window and get back to
our spreadsheet now let us try to make
use of the macro function that we just
created so that is equals to count
colored cells press tab to select the
macro function and the first one is the
current cell so this is the current cell
where the current color has been
provided comma this cell range so our
cell range will be from c 2 to c31
right so this is the range where we want
to count the similarly colored cells
that is sky blue colored cells close the
function and press enter now you can see
the function has identified six
repetitions of sky blue color in this
particular range of cells now you can
drag the same formula across all the
cells and it will be
providing the results of the scene so
six senior colors that is pink or purple
color then two repetitions of this
particular color two repetitions of
trainee color five for dark blue and 6
for green right so this is how the macro
function works and the key point to
remember here is this particular macro
will work only for manually colored
cells so there are situations where we
have used conditional formatting to
color a single cell let us imagine that
we have used conditional formatting to
recognize the employees with salary
above 30 000 as green color and if we
try to use that particular green color
to be counted by the color count cells
function now it will not happen it will
not consider that color as a feedback or
an input now in future we will also try
to design a macro which can recognize
the colors made by conditional
formatting as well but this particular
function will be exclusively used for
manually colored cells only dated F
function is majorly used to find the
differences between two individual dates
so it is also called as dated F by a few
people and a few people also reference
it to date diff that is State difference
so anything is good now to find the
difference between any two dates let's
select a few dates so the first date
would be let us imagine that you're an
employee and you wanted to find out how
many errors that you've been working
with an organization so for that you
might want to need today and the date
where you join the company right so it
might be native joining and today
so what's the difference
right so let us imagine that you joined
the organization somewhere around 2010
0 1
0 5
and
today so for today can you can give any
particular date
let us imagine that today is first of
January 2021 or 2022
now we have about the date status the
joining date and the current date which
can be the current date so that they can
be anything so you might be watching
this on a different date as well so the
date of that day for today would be a
little different so we'll imagine that
today's date as an imaginary date now we
might want to find the different status
in terms of years so you wanted to find
the difference in terms of years so here
you can find the difference in terms of
Errors days and months as well so
currently let's try to find out the
difference in terms of years so for us
you might want to specify the third
parameter in the dative function as y if
you wanted once you have to give the M
as the third parameter and if you wanted
to find the days you might want to give
d as the third parameter uh so we have
discussed the third parameter so what
are the first two parameters right so
the first two parameters are the first
date and the last date so the first date
in this situation is your date of
joining and the last day or the final
date which you won't hear as your today
so let's find the difference so for that
equals to
so it can be dated if or date div
idend F and the first date which is the
A2 and comma the last state that is P2
and your parameter third parameter in
terms of years that is Y close the
bracket and press enter so there you go
you have your date here so it's been
like 11 years that you're working with
your organization so that's how you find
out the differences so we have 11 years
because we did not finish the 12th year
completely so if we had given the month
as maybe six
where we have finished our total years
then it will automatically change to 12
years
so
now
for this particular task we will be
considering the student database now
let's get into practical mode and start
our Excel so on my screen you can see
some data related to students now let us
try to duplicate some of the rows here
foreign
so we have selected the rows 8 9 10 and
11. now we shall copy them and paste
them so now these are the duplicate
elements right
now there might be possibilities about
the duplication of class because all the
students all the 10 students are in same
class so they might be a duplication but
we are not looking for such kind of
duplications right we are looking for
the duplication of the entire row for
example we have the details of mic over
here in the eighth row which has the
roll number of serial number S7 name as
mic roll number class blood group and
subject scores percentage round of
percentage and total marks so the entire
eighth row has been copied here and it
is in the row number 12 we have the
exact same details so what if you have
the exact same rows duplicated so that's
what we're gonna deal with we're gonna
eliminate the duplicate rows all
completely together
now to carry over this task we have to
select the data from toolbar so you have
various options file home insert Etc so
you need to select the data and inside
the data toolbar we have the ribbon and
inside ribbon you have got the duplicate
values or remote duplicates option in
the airplane so select all the data
select remove duplicates and now you can
see that we have all our column names
over here and make sure that you have
selected my data as headers and then
select ok
and now you can see that Excel has
automatically removed four duplicate
values so four duplicate values are
found and removed 10 unique values
remain
now another type of remove duplicates
can also be done so you can see that
here we have another data set which has
phone numbers or phone names that is
phone makers that are Samsung Huawei
Vivo Oppo Etc so there are some
duplicate values and this I have copy
pasted it then so now you can also do
that so
just select all the data
and now go into home
and select conditional formatting and
here select highlight cell rules and
inside that you have duplicate values
selecting this option will help you
identify the duplicate values in your
data set but not to remove them
so you can select that and you can see
the duplicate values are highlighted
over here in the red column
now again you can get back to data and
select the option of remove duplicates
and select power key and the duplicate
values will be automatically eliminated
so that's how you delete or eliminate
duplicate values in a data set and you
can also see that we have another
duplicate in this particular row and if
you wanted to select a particular row
and eliminate the duplicate signals to
that now for that you need to go to the
same process remove duplicates and here
Microsoft Excel is asking you if you had
to expand the selection to the entire
data set or you want to continue with
the selected data set Etc or selected
column itself so for that you need to
select the continue with the current
selection and remove duplicates and
press OK and you can see one duplicate
value is found and it has been removed
and six unique values remain
so that's how you use the function of
removing duplicates in Excel so what is
summers in Excel
now you might want to calculate uh the
total sum of sales right so let us
assume that this is your entire stores
sales data and you wanted to calculate
the entire sum of sales so there is a
sum function in Excel where you just
have to you know select all the cells
and apply some function onto it and
you'll get the sum of all the sales
right so what's something like this
you'll select all the cells and then
you'll apply assumes function and you'll
get the sum here and average everything
right so this is fine but what if you
just wanted to find the sales that are
happening in only western region as you
can see our column f is based on region
so we have four regions Southwest East
and Central so your manager asks you to
find the sales happening in suppose say
a west region so how do you calculate it
would you manually go into each cell and
check if it's Western calculate that
will be time consuming right so what if
you had a method which could do it for
you just in a matter of few steps or few
clicks right so that's exactly Summers
so it will basically add a condition
calculate the sum of sales where the
region is equals to West simple to like
or similar to SQL query right so that is
exactly what we're going to do in Excel
today that is using Summers now let me
add here sales of
west region now in the next cell let's
add a summers function remember there
are multiple sum functions in Excel so
when you type in sum you can see so many
options based on sum right you just have
some followed by that you have some if
it is just sum if not some ifs today we
are concentrating on some F's so not
just sum if we'll go to some ifs so
we'll be having an option of placing
multiple if conditions there so let's
also try that more on that later now
let's press tab to select our sum ifs
function now okay we forgot another
important step so before we apply sumifs
we need to convert our table into a
table format yes it looks stable but
right now it's not in tabular format it
is in the format of database we know
that Microsoft Excel considers s data as
a database by default so to convert the
database into table just click anywhere
on the data and and press Ctrl T so that
you'll have a new dialog box and it will
ask if your table has headers just make
sure that you have ticked in it our
table does have headers so select ok now
our database has been converted into a
perfect table and it's ready for
applying Summers function so now you can
see our database has been successfully
converted into our table now let's begin
with our Summits now again remember we
are using some ifs here not some if or
sum so select some ifs and press Tab and
we have SMS function now the first step
which column are we looking at what are
we finding out right which is a sum
range what sum do you want for now we
need sum of sales so select the sales
column and we have a simple key function
here let's hold Ctrl again press shift
and hold shift together so we're holding
Ctrl and shift key together and now we
are pressing lower Arrow key once yes
the entire sales column has been
selected comma Now where do you want to
look so we want to look I mean which
part of the table you want to fetch
right so this is the region part we want
to fetch right now so again hold Ctrl
and shift together lower Arrow key the
entire column is selected now the next
last part so we want to look into the
both of the columns that is sales column
and region column now which type of data
you want so for now we want to Western
type of data so that is the sales data
which is happening only invest right so
we'll select this cell with the data as
fast or you can also manually enter it
for now let's select the data so I'm
selecting this cell F7 which has data as
best right now let's close the
parenthesis and press enter so there you
go you have the sales happening in the
western region now you can also try to
format it in the form of currency so
let's use
dollars since it is based on American
states so let's use dollars so there you
go now we are having the sale state of
West now let's try to copy the same to
all the four cells and for now here
let's type in East
and this can be South right and this can
be your central
there you go
right
now you can also copy the same formula
and make minor edits to it so here
instead of f8 you can select a East
so where is East here and press enter so
you have the sales related to East now
let's try to edit F9 with South
select South Region enter so you have
South sales and what remaining is
Central so let's edit Central as well
and press enter so there you go right
now you have all the separate sales data
from west east south and Central now
again
uh you might want a bit more granularity
in data right or in your reports right
like you wanted to find the sales data
happening invest and you wanted to find
out the category based on only
Furnitures so your manager will ask you
okay a fantastic job so now just give me
another minute detail on the data I want
to calculate the sales happening on West
based on category Furniture right so he
wants furniture or he wants office
supplies only right you can also do that
it's not an issue at all now let's try
to copy this cell and paste it here and
sales invest let's add another input
here on furniture
right now you wanted to calculate the
sales happening in west region only on
furniture so you can also do that now we
can use the same formula as well just
copy paste the formula here right and
you can add few things here when you try
to add a comma it will automatically
generate the next criterator so it is
expecting that you are looking for
adding another criteria right now which
column you want you want category so
let's select category you want to select
all the cells same track Ctrl shift
lower key
and again press comma and you wanted to
select Only Furniture so select on
furniture cell then now press enter so
there you go we successfully have the
sales data from west region based on
category Only Furniture so that's how
you do summers in Excel you can also add
a few more details to it like in
Furniture you can also look only for
tables so here you can see in west
region we have furniture sales data and
we have sales data of West Region based
on furniture which includes only tables
you can also do that using sum as
function in the same way all you have to
do is select the subcategory column and
select the cell which has the data as
tables so this is how you use sum UPS in
Excel now creating a pivot table is just
away from a few clicks trust me it's
just a couple of clicks and you'll have
your pivot table ready to operate now
click any cell or select any cell on
your spreadsheet which has the data and
navigate to insert menu on the toolbar
and select pivot table and that's how
simple it is now automatically Excel
will choose your data you can see the
lines over here dotted line that means
the Excel has already selected the range
of data that you want to put into your
pivot table and you can either select
the existing worksheet or a new
worksheet I'll select a new worksheet
over here and just press on OK and there
you go you have your pivot table ready
now here you can see your pivot table is
a little empty all you need to do is
drag and drop the data elements that you
want on your pivot table
so here you can see on a spreadsheet we
have some business data related to a
stop which has furniture and states and
subcategories of the furniture and all
the you know in in category you have
furniture of a surplus technology Etc
right so those have some sub categories
as well and different states and the
regions as well and the quantity total
sales happen right so using this
business data we can find out some key
insights of this particular data using
our pivot table right so here we'll add
the data now let me drag the region into
rows click and drag and let me drag a
categories into columns which are the
different categories which are involved
in sales data and values what are the
sales happened right and there you go
you have Furnitures of a supplies
technology as the three different
categories and those are the sales
happened in central is South and West
regions and this is the grand total and
incentive regions you know you have all
the regions over here right so Central
is south west or instead of uh all the
regions or instead of all the categories
you can you know placed a specific
category in your pivot table for example
let me push the category into the
filters and here you can see the total
sales happen in those particular regions
now what if someone asks you to find the
sales of Only Furniture right so your
manager comes to you and he'll ask you
getting the sales of only Furnitures you
can select that and there you go you
have the furniture sales in all the
regions right or you can also do the
vice versa he can also drag regions into
the filters and if you wanted to find
out the region wise sales of furniture
you can also do that right
so here we have furniture and here you
have all the regions and let us try to
find the sales of furniture in the
central region and there you go right so
this is how
um the pivot table works and you can
also remove the regions for example if
you wanted to remove a certain element
from filters or anywhere if it is
columns rows anything you can just drag
and drop it right so that's how it works
and also you can increase the level of
detail or improve the granularity right
so here we have categories on our you
know columns so you can also include
subcategories into the columns
right and
and you have the reason why sales
show in the region filter select all
press OK and in the category
select all
press ok
and you have the furniture here of a
supplies here and Technology here and
also if you want to include the quantity
how much or how many number of uh you
know things got sold in those particular
categories and subcategories you can
also do that so here in the furniture
section books these are the sales and
these are the number of quantity or
elements sold in the in those particular
you know sectors so you can you can also
improve the level of granularity you can
also include the level of detail using
pivot tables and
now AutoFill in Excel is a feature where
you can add some series automatically
using Excel for example let us imagine
that you wanted to add index numbers
right so starting from 1 to 10 so
manually you will be typing in the
numbers and you'll be doing it right so
instead of this what if I said you there
was a simple way where Excel will fill
all the data for you right so just start
with one
Google and select these two cells and
you can see the flash logo over here
right so that's the indication that
Excel has understood your pattern and it
is ready to fill the remaining numbers
so as long as you drag this logo or that
ending part where you have a small
square box that will fill all the
numbers until where you are printed so
that's how autofill works and you might
be wondering will it work only for
numbers
no it will also work on some Logics as
well okay this was the first part let us
also look at some other tricks with
autofill now most of the time we might
be just adding one number and try to
drag that cell and the result is it will
copy the same number all the time right
so you can change it by clicking on this
menu
you can click on fill series and it will
change to series
and this was one more trick with numbers
now getting back to the next type so let
us imagine now the next type of series
you want to add is weeks in a day right
so you will be having Monday
Tuesday Wednesday right so you can also
do the series of weekdays using AutoFill
in Excel as well so drag that cell and
it will give you all the days or
weekdays in a week
now let's try January
and this will give you the months in a
year
in the shortcut way right since you just
added the first three letters of the
month it will recognize the pattern and
it will do the same field now let us try
the full names of months
right and now let's try to drag it it'll
fill all the full names of all the
months
now
let's try the dates so let us imagine
that this is the first day of the
current year
right it will now give you all the dates
of that current month or until the end
of the year as well
there you go
now let us imagine that your manager
tells you to add the dates of working
days in the month of January so how can
you do that it's simple all you need to
do is select the cell go to the fill
option select series and here select
column wise since you want the dates and
columns and here in the type select date
date unit should be weekday and the
stock value should be the next month
right since your manager asked for the
weekdays of January so your stock value
will be the first of February press OK
and there you go so since the 1st of
January is Friday that's select it over
here and the rest to Saturday and Sunday
are eliminated similarly we have all the
dates here of working days only so
that's how you use AutoFill in Excel so
on my screen you can see a simple
spreadsheet with student names and their
marks on my sheet so we will be
calculating what are the total marks
obtained by the students and overall
subjects and can translate what is the
percentage now we will carry forward a
few simple inbuilt functions in Excel to
calculate that first we will be
calculating the sum of marks so here
equals to sum function
and select the range of cells
close the bracket press enter
so you have the sum now
so we have to calculate it repeat so by
clicking on the same formula now we have
the total of all the subjects for
individual students and now let's
calculate percentage so usually we use
the you know divide by option that is
divide the total number of marks
obtained by the total number of marks
available that is we will be dividing
407 by 500 and then we will be
multiplying that into 100 so that's how
we calculate the percentage so
cell G2 divided by cell H2 press enter
and you will end up with you know the
decimal format that's perfectly all
right
now we have also extended the same
formula for all our cells now select
this overall column or select the
highlighted cells right and get into the
data type here you have General so
that's why we have got that uh similar
format but when you press percentage
you'll have the actual percentage of all
the students according to their Max
achieved now we are on our Excel
spreadsheet and this spreadsheet has
some values of employees that is their
employee ID name designation Department
salary date of birth and date of
churning now our concern is to highlight
some cells which are duplicate in this
or some rows which are duplicate so for
example here you can see on row number
seven we have the details of Martha
and you can see the same details of Mata
in the row number 14 as well right so
you need to eliminate those cells or you
need to eliminate those rows now you can
say there is a quick way just few clicks
and those will be eliminated that is
conditional formatting yes that is also
one way but I'll show you what's the
problem with that okay so let us select
the entire table and get into
conditional formatting and here you have
duplicate values highlight cell rules
where duplicate values
and there you go the problem so here we
have designation which is duplicated in
certain ways department and salary state
of joining right so there are certain
conditions or scenarios where you cannot
directly identify which is the duplicate
rule again you can use the same for this
right so you can select the entire
column of employee ID and you can
identify the duplicate cells here since
the employee IDs are unique for everyone
so this is a way but let's dig a little
deeper and understand the way of
highlighting duplicates with an advanced
technique so let me cancel this and for
that let's create a new column
and let's name this as duplicate
flag
e flag
so the new column has been created which
is d flat so here we will be using a
simple formula that is
count F and here press tab to select the
formula and here we will be adding our
range that is which range are you
considering so the range will be the
employee ID since employee IDs are
unique for every employee
and
and let's press function F4 to fix it
and now
again the criteria and the criteria will
be the same cell that is A2 and now
close the bracket and press enter
now let's track the same formula to all
the rows
okay now here we have now what you can
do is sort it in an advanced way go to
sort and filter
and custom sort and here you'll be
sorting by the D flag and it will be
smallest to largest
so now you can apply the conditional
formatting to highlight it you can
select the column H or the D flag go to
conditional formatting highlight cell
rules and here you can get into greater
than
and give the value as 1
okay
so all the cells which are you know
repeated multiple times will be selected
here and they will be highlighted with a
selected color what you have given so
I've given Red so now you can select
these cells and I'll let them all delete
them from your spreadsheet
and now all your data in the spreadsheet
is unique and clean now let's quickly
get on to the Practical mode where we
will have some data sets over which we
will be trying to apply the charts now
there are various types of charts in
Tableau and those are the pie chart the
column chart the bar chart column versus
line pivot chart and sparkline charts so
we will discuss one after the other
first let us discuss about the pie chart
so as you can see we have a small data
set on my screen which I have personally
created and this deals with the
companies and this deals with the shares
of the automobile industry so now for
this let's create a pie chart
select all the data and then get into
the Google bar and inside the toolbar
you can see various options and inside
that we're gonna use the insert option
and when you select the insert option
you will have a ribbon here and inside
the ribbon you can see groups tables
illustrations add-ins and here you go
these are the charts so now we needed a
pie chart so select on that icon and you
have various types of pie charts you
have two dimensional pie charts three
dimension pie charts donor type of
charts
Etc right so I would like to go over the
three dimensional pie chart as it looks
a little more appealing and easy to
understand and now there you go this is
the title of the chart and these are the
legends of the chart and this is the
chart area and these are the values now
we can you know kind of add the data
labels as well so you can just have to
press the plus icon over here and you'll
have the options you can add the data
labels which will give you a lot more
interesting values
and you can also turn this around
as you can see we on double clicking any
part of the pie chart you'll get this
option which is called as format data
point and let's imagine that you wanted
to show the information related to this
particular one which is a Volvo which
has the biggest share so this is in
front right now now what if you wanted
to show the information related to Tata
which is over here right for that you
can select this particular Arrow key and
you can just twist it and there you go
it is coming in front this will be a
great way of presenting your data to
your clients right
yeah and there is another option where
you can directly explore this like you
can pick it out you can see this right
Point explosion where you can split it
out and you can show that especially
like you can highlight it and show it so
that's the you know a great way of
presenting your data so that's how you
can work with pie charts in Excel now
let's quickly move to the next one that
is the column chart
and in the column chart we have the data
related to some company and the profits
of that company based on a year so you
can see that the year has started from
2008 and it has gone until 2021 and
these are the profits of that company
year after year so since we are dealing
with column chart I'll tell you the
simplest way to create a column chart
there is a shortcut key for that
which is alt F1 and there you go you
have the chart right on your screen
now you can expand the chart just by
dragging it like that and
you can see that there is some problem
with this chat that is we have numbers
here instead of years right you can see
that the First Column is the es which is
2008 to 2021 but here you can see we
have one two three four which is not
proper right so to change the
access status you can see the axis which
is one two three let me expand my screen
a little bit
so if you look at my screen we have two
different columns one column is about
the ears and the second column is about
the revenue now what we want to do is we
want to create a line graph where we
have here on the x-axis and revenue on
the y-axis and we will be generating a
line graph based on the data we have now
for that we have to select the entire
data what we have then we need to go
into the insert option in the toolbar
and then you can see a lot of chat
options in the insert ribbon now here
you can see that we have a line chart or
area chart option select that and here
you can see 2D line graphs now let's
select the first one and there you go
you have the line chart here now let's
rename the title
there is one problem with the chart here
you can see that the x-axis is not
actually pointing the years you can make
a change to that no worries
just right click and then you can see
the select date option and there you go
you have the edit option here just edit
it and now select the range
I am selecting the ears now
let's select okay and there you go you
have the ears here you can just try to
expand it a little more
yeah
so now you have the
revenue on the y-axis and here on the
x-axis and this shows the growth of
Revenue in your company so this is how
you create a line graph in Excel played
on
now let's imagine that you are the CEO
of an IT company and you have taken up
multiple projects let us imagine that
you wish to keep track of all the
projects
so what if there was a tool which could
keep track of all the projects in the
form of a detailed visualization with
the percentage in the form of a graph or
a bar chart
interesting right that's exactly what we
are going to design today using
Microsoft Excel
so without further Ado let's get started
with our one point agenda that is
progress tracker in Excel now to design
a progress tracker in Excel let us get
back to the Practical mode where we
might have to use our Microsoft Excel
now we are on the Microsoft Excel and we
have taken some sample data to make
things look simple so here we are
considering a set of students and their
attendance percentage so we will be
using this particular data and design a
progress tracker
now let us try to increase the size of
the cells
now select all the cells in the
attendance column
now we have selected all the cells in
the attendance column and in the toolbar
select the Home tab and inside the Home
tab you have styles group inside the
Styles group select conditional
formatting and inside the conditional
formatting option select new rule
so in the new rule we want to select the
first option that is format all cells
based on their values
now here you can see format Style
since we are trying to create a data bus
we need to select the option of data
pass here
and under the data bar options we have
some more options on the drop down menu
so here in the type select number
and
the minimum number is 0 it is
automatically stored here and the
maximum value is again a number and let
us provide it as 1.
now here you can select the color for
your pass
now since we have already chosen green
for all the column headers let's choose
blue
and
select ok
now here you can see that the values are
being indicated using bar graphs right
and you can also see the percentage
values but we can make it look a little
more better by shifting them to the left
side and text could be given as white
so that it's more uh vibrant to look at
and now we can also apply some
conditional formatting onto these
attendance columns
so let us try to highlight the students
having attendance less than 65 percent
so highlight cell rules less than
65 percent attendance
with red color select ok
and there you go you have the progress
tracker right on your screen
and using the same principles you can
track the attendance for all the
students
and also you can apply some conditional
formatting onto all your cells and
highlight the ones which are not on the
track now this is how you can implement
progress trackers using Excel
now for this particular example we are
going to use the employees data
now let's quickly get back to the
Practical note and enter into Excel
now you can see that we are on Excel
sheet right now so let me expand my
screen a little bit
huh so that the data is a little more
visible
so here on my screen you can see that we
have employees data so the First Column
is the name of the employees and the
second column is the start dates of the
employees that when have they started
working with the organization and when
they have ended or resigned to their
position in that particular organization
and the duration gives us the number of
days they have worked in that particular
organization so to create a Gantt chart
is really simple you just have to select
the data and then go to the insert
option and in there you can see the
charts icon and select all charts and in
that select the bar chart and here you
can see the Stacked bar chart select
that and press OK and there you go you
have the Stacked bar chart right on your
screen let's expand this a little more
so that we have the clear visualization
of the dates as well
now you can if you want you can change
the title as org data or employee data
and now we are partially done with our
chart now the next thing we have to do
is select the bar chart right click on
it select data and here select the add
icon now you need to select the series
name so the series name is duration for
our gunshot and series values are
let's select this
and select let's move a little
yeah so these are the data series let's
select okay and you can see the Gantt
chart on my screen right here select OK
and it's done and still now it's not
complete yet so to finish it you need to
select the blue colored bars here and
right click on them and select format
data series
go to the fill icon and select no fill
and it's done for now and you can see
that there is a difference in this
particular arrangement we had Joe at the
first place and Susan at the last place
but here you can see Joe is in the last
place and Susan is in the first place so
we need to make some arrangements here
for that right click select format
access and then here you can see
categorize in reverse order
and there you go it should be done
and there you go you have your Gantt
chart right on your screen Excel is a
really powerful tool for data analytics
and Reporting and pivot tables are one
of the features that Excel offers for
creating tabular reports to summarize
our data
let's begin by understanding what is a
pivot table
a pivot table is a tool that summarizes
and reorganizes selected columns and
rows of data in its spreadsheet to
obtain a desired report
it does not actually change the
spreadsheet data it simply pivots or
turns the data to view it in different
perspectives viewer tables are specially
useful with large amounts of data that
would be time consuming to calculate
manually
now let's understand the different
components of a pivot table
so there are four main components first
we have rows when a field is chosen for
the row area it populates as the first
column in the pivot table
similar to The Columns all row labels
are unique values and duplicates are
removed
columns
is the second component
when a field is chosen for the column
area only the unique values of the field
are listed across the top
then we have values each value is kept
in a pivot table cell and displace the
summarized information the most common
values are sum average minimum and
maximum finally we have filters filters
apply a calculation or restriction to
the entire table
so let's jump over to Microsoft Excel
and let me show you the data set that we
will use in this demo so with India
being ready for its 16 census in 2021
that is next year it is a good time for
us to analyze India's last census data
from 2011 and see where different states
and cities across India stood in terms
of population literacy and other
socio-economic factors we will analyze
this data by creating different pivot
tables in Excel and explore some of its
features so let's begin
first I'll show you one of the features
that Excel offers us so suppose I click
on any cell and hit Control Plus Q
you can see our entire table is selected
and at the right bottom there's an
option of quick analysis
now you can see by default Excel has
prompted certain features such as
formatting we have charts totals and
this one more called tables now Excel by
default has created some pivot tables
for us now the first one you say is sum
of district code by state names
next we have sum of sex ratio by state
name
then we have some of child sex ratio
some of male graduates and some of
female graduates by state name and there
are others before creating our pivot
table so let's have a final look at our
data set
so First Column you see is the city
column so there are different cities
from different parts of India then we
have the state code we have the state
name district code we have the total
population followed by male and female
population
next you can see we have the total
literates from each City
then we have the male and female
literates next we have the sex ratio
then we have the child sex ratio
next we have total number of graduates
and finally you can see we have male and
female graduates so using this table
we'll create several pivot tables
now first of all let's create a pivot
table to find the total population for
each state and sort it in descending
order so you can see here we have the
problem statement
so our first pivot table will have the
total population for each of the states
in descending order
so to create a pivot table you can click
any cell in your data go to the insert
Tab and here
left you can see we have the option to
create a pivot table so let me select
pivot table
now my range is already selected the
entire table
and here I'll choose existing worksheet
because I want to place my pivot table
in the same worksheet
and I'll give my location I'll point to
cell Q5
now let me click ok
you can see the pivot table Fields
appears here on the right
now since we want to find the total
population for each state so what I'll
do is
I'll drag my state name onto rows
so here in our pivot table you can see
we have the different state names listed
now
we want the total population for each of
these states
so
in the field list I'll search for total
population which is this one and drag it
under values
you can see
we have a sum of total population for
each of these states by default
Excel built sum any numeric column you
can always change it to average minimum
maximum anything you want now we want to
sort this column in descending order so
I right click go to sort option and
choose Z to A that is largest to
smallest
you can see here in 2011 Maharashtra had
the highest number of population
or the total population in Maharashtra
was the highest then it was uttar
Pradesh we had Andhra Pradesh
and if I come down we have nagaland and
Andaman and nicobar Islands towards
the end
so this is a simple pivot table that we
created now the next problem we have is
we want to find the total sum of
literates in each City belonging to a
certain state so let's see how to do it
I'll click on any cell go to insert and
here I can click on pivot table
my range is selected I'll choose
existing worksheet and give my location
which is Q5
I click on OK
now here we want to find the total sum
of literates so what I'll do is first
let me drag
total literates column two values
you have the total sum of literates from
all the states
next I want to see the sum of total
literates based on states and cities so
let me first drag state name onto rows
and then
will drag City
on two rows
you can see here we have our pivot table
ready
to the left of the pivot table you can
see we have the state names and
the cities per state and on the right
you can see the total number of
literates from each City if I scroll
down we have Assam then you can see we
have Bihar
and if I keep scrolling we have all the
states haryana Himachal Pradesh this
terminal and Kashmir which has now
become a union territory
as well moving on
okay so the next thing we want to see is
what is the average sex ratio and the
child sex ratio for each state
with that we also want to find the
states that had the highest and lowest
sex ratio in 2011.
so let's create a pivot table for this
I'll click on any cell go to insert
choose pivot table
click on existing worksheet I'll select
cell Q5
and click on OK
now
since we want
the average sex ratio and the child sex
ratio so first I'll drag those columns
either you can manually scroll and
drag it or here you have the option to
search for it so if I look for child
you can see we have
the same
column listed
you can just drag it from there let me
delete this
and I also want this x ratio
so I'll place it on top of child sex
ratio
next
we want to see it based on
different states so what I'll do is
I'll take
state name and put it under rows
so here you can see we have our pivot
table ready
on the left you can see we have the
different state names listed and on the
right we have the values
now we want to find the average Now by
default Excel will sum the numeric
columns you can see it tells you sum of
sex ratio and child sex ratio so what
you can do
you can click on this drop down and go
to Value field settings
and here summarize values by you can
choose average
you can see the custom name it says
average of 6 ratio click on OK
our entire column is now
giving us the average sex ratio
similarly for this column let me convert
it into average I'll again click on the
drop down
go to Value field settings
click on average
and click ok
and you can see here we have the average
of child sex ratio for each of the
states now the next question says which
states had the highest and lowest sex
ratio so we'll consider this column
so we'll sort it in any order you want
you can do it either ascending or
descending let me short it in descending
order
you can see we have our
column sorted now
so in 2011 Kerala had the highest sex
ratio and if I scroll down to the bottom
you can see himanshal Pradesh at the
lowest which is around 818.
up next let's explore one more feature
of pivot table so suppose you want to
see the top or bottom few rows of a
pivot table you can do that as well
so here we have a question at hand
we want to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates so let's see from the entire
pivot table how we can filter the top
three cities
so I'll go to insert click on the pivot
table option
go to existing worksheet click on Q5
and hit OK
now since we want to find the top three
cities I'll drag
City column onto rows and then we want
the female graduates so in the search
bar I'll look for female
and I'll choose this column that is
female graduates and drag it
here on to values
so I have
the sum of female graduates for each of
the Cities now since we want to find the
highest number of female graduates in
the top three cities so let me first
sort this column
I'll sort it in descending order
now we have it sorted now from this you
can say that Delhi greater Mumbai and
Bengaluru are the top three cities
but it's displaying all the cities for
us
so let's filter
only the top three so what you can do is
right click
and go to filter
under filter you have the option of top
10 I'll select this
here I only want the top three
so either you can
go down like this or you can directly
type 3
your column is already selected let me
just click on OK
there you go we have the required pivot
table ready and it only displays us the
top three cities with the highest number
of female graduates
now the next thing we want to see is how
to use a Slicer in a pivot table so we
have a question here What's the total
population for all the cities in
Rajasthan and Karnataka
so let's create a pivot table for this
and see how you can use a slicer to
filter the table
click on existing I'll click on a
location this time q6
click ok
now since I want the total population so
I'll drag total population onto values
and then I'll select
the city
onto rows and then the state name also
I'll place it on top of City so you have
in the pivot table all the states and
their cities
and on the right you can see the total
population for each of these cities
but our question is we want to find only
for Rajasthan and Karnataka
now for that what you can do is
go to insert
and create a slicer either you can
create from this option or you can go to
pivot table analyze option and here you
have the option to create or insert a
slicer and click on this
and since we want to slice the table
based on
state that is Rajasthan and Karnataka
I'll choose state name
as my slicer field
you can see this is my slicer here
now
you only want
the data for Rajasthan and Karnataka so
I'll search for
these two so here we have Karnataka so
let me select Karnataka first
and I also want for Rajasthan
so let me select Rajasthan also
you can see in our pivot table we only
have
data for Rajasthan and Karnataka
so this pivot table
shows you different cities from
Karnataka and the total sum of
population from each of the cities and
similarly we also have for Rajasthan
moving ahead now we will see another
very interesting feature of pivot that
is how you can
create percentage contribution of a
table
for example we have a question here
what's the percentage contribution of
male and female literates from each
state
now we want to see in terms of
percentage and not as sum or average
let's do that
I'll create my pivot table
click on existing
and I'll select an empty cell
okay
now here since we want to find the
percentage contribution of male and
female literates so first I'll drag
male literatures onto values followed by
female literates onto values by default
it has summed up the male literacy and
female literates value
and also I want to drag
State column
to rows
so here you can see the sum of male
literates and female literates per state
I want to convert this as
percentage contribution so
what we can do is I'll select any cell
and
I'll right click
and I'll go to so value as and here I
have the option to select percentage of
grand total so I'll select this
you can see we have the percentage
contribution of male literates to the
total
now if I sort this you will get to know
which state contributed or has the
highest percentage contribution
so we have Maharashtra for male
literatures
then we had uttar Pradesh in 2011
if I come down
we had michalia nagaland and Andaman and
nicobar Islands
as two states which had little or
minimal contribution to male literates
similarly let's do it for female
literates
I'll go to show value as and select
percentage of grand total
so you can see here also Maharashtra
uttar Pradesh then Gujarat and all had
the
highest percentage contribution to
female literatures
so this is another good feature
to convert your data in c10 in terms of
percentage
now moving ahead let's say we want to
find the bottom three cities from each
state that had the lowest female
graduates
we can do that as well I'll go to insert
click on pivot
go to existing worksheet select an empty
worksheet and click on OK
now since I want to see based on States
as well as cities so let me drag the
state name first onto rows
and let's drag the city column on to
rows
next
we want female graduates so let me look
for female graduates in the field list
I'll drag it onto values
now we have the list of states and the
respective cities
and to the right of the pivot table you
can see the sum of female graduates from
each City
now
first I'll
sort this column
I'll right click go to sort and click on
shortest to largest
now we have sorted our female graduates
from
shortest or smallest to largest now
since I want to find the bottom three
cities from each state I'll come to this
cell right click go to filter and select
top 10.
now I'll
replace top 10 with bottom and I want
the bottom three cities from each state
I have my
column selected that is sum of female
graduates if I click on OK
you can see here some of the states
don't have three cities so you can see
Andaman and Uber islands has only one
city that is Port Blair while the
remaining you can find
the bottom three cities with the lowest
number of female graduates so Andhra
Pradesh had these three in Assam we had
nagao then there was dibrugar and silcha
similarly if I come down in haryana we
have palwal kathal and zind
if I come further here you can see for
Karnataka this gangavati this Rani
benoor and the scholar similarly you can
see for Kerala as well
now moving ahead
now in the next example I'll tell you
how you can create a calculated field or
a calculated column in Excel with the
help of a pivot table
so in a pivot table you can create or
use custom formulas to create calculated
fields or items calculated fields of
formulas that can refer to other fields
in the pivot table
calculated Fields appear with other
value fields in the pivot table like
other value Fields a calculated Fields
name May proceed with sum of followed by
the field name
so here we have a sales table that has
columns like the items which has
different fruits and vegetables
and those have been categorized as
fruits and vegetables we have the price
per kg and this is in terms of rupees
and we have the quantity that was sold
now let's see if you want to find the
sales for each item in the table you can
create a calculated field
so your sales column is going to be the
product of price per kg
and quantity so let me show you how you
can do that with the help of a pivot
table
I'll create a pivot table first
click on an empty cell
hit OK
now
if you see on the top under pivot table
analyze and under calculations we have
the option Fields items and sets if I
click on this drop down I get the option
to create a calculated field or insert a
calculated field I click on this
I'll give my field name as sales
and
I'll select my formula
I'll first click on price per kg and hit
insert field
I'll give a space hit shift 8 to give
the product symbol and then I'll double
click on quantity
now this is my formula for sales that is
price per kg multiplied by quantity
I click on ADD
and I click on OK
if you see here
there is a calculated field that is
present in the pivot table fields which
is sales but it did not add it to our
original table or original table is the
same but here we have added a calculated
field which is present only in the pivot
table list now we can use this it has
already taken it under values
now let's say I want to find the sum of
sales for
each item
under each category
you can see it here we have our category
fruit and we have our category vegetable
and under that we have different items
like apple apricot banana similarly in
vegetables we have broccoli this carrots
corn eggplant and others
so this is how you can create a
calculated field in a pivot table
now this one more good feature that
Excel offers us in pivot table is to
create a pivot chart so you can use your
pivot table and create different charts
so I'll show you how to do that
if I go to insert
here I have the option of recommended
charts if I click on this Excel gives me
some default charts which you can use
let's say I'll select this
let me drag it
a bit to the right
here you can see I'll close this pivot
field list
this is a nice bar chart that Excel has
created this is called a pivot chart now
here you can see the category fruits and
vegetables and the different fruits and
vegetables or the items
in the y-axis you can see the total
seals if you see from the graph guava
made the highest amount of sales now if
I sort this let's sort this first
you can see it here fruit guava meet the
highest amount of sales now since I
sorted and changed my pivot table the
pivot chart also automatically gets
updated similarly there are other charts
also that you can create let's go to the
insert Tab and
let's click on recommended charts again
let's look for a pie chart so this is a
pie chart that you can create let me
click on OK
so here is our pie chart and each Pi
represents a certain item
and the pi that has the highest area
represents
it had the highest amount of seals in
this case you can see
it is guava and similarly we have other
items as well this is fruit banana
that's corn
and we have spinach and others
let's explore a few other charts so
first I'll
click on my pivot table go to insert and
under recommended charts let's now
select a line chart
if I hit OK
move it to the right so this is a line
chart
you can see it starts
from guava
which had the highest amount of sales
then it drops
and in the x-axis you can see the
different items similarly when it starts
with the vegetables broco limit the
highest amount of sales width 2800
rupees and our lowest was eggplant at
900 rupees for fruits papaya sold the
least at 700 rupees
let's take another chart I'll go to
insert
under recommended charts let's see
this time we'll see a bar chart now this
is a
horizontal bar chart and not a vertical
one we just saw a vertical
column chart like this
this is an horizontal bar chart now you
can always increase and decrease the
size of these charts
let's explore
a last start let's take the area chart
for now
so this is an area chart again it looks
similar to the line chart it starts with
guava which are the highest amount of
sales similarly papaya under fruits had
the lowest amount of sales and the
vegetables it was
broccoli and finally eggplant metal
lowest amount of sales under vegetable
now let's go to our first suite and
summarize what we have done in this demo
for pivot tables in Excel so we had our
data
this is a 2011 Census Data from India we
had the different cities the state names
and we had the total population total
literates female literates mean
literates we had the sex ratio total
graduates and other information
so we began by understanding how to
create a simple pivot table where we
calculated the total population for each
state and sorted it in descending order
we found that Maharashtra uttar Pradesh
had the total population in 2011.
then
we saw
another preview table where we
calculated the total sum of literates in
each City belonging to a certain state
so you can see we had the
different state names and the cities
under each state
then
we saw another feature where you could
calculate the average of a certain
numerical column so here we calculated
the average sex ratio and the child sex
ratio for each state and found out which
one had the highest and lowest sex ratio
after that we saw
how you could find or filter tables
we saw how to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates we found out that Delhi
greater Mumbai and Bengaluru were the
top cities with highest number of female
graduates next we saw how to use Slicer
in a pivot table so we sliced our table
based on Rajasthan Karnataka State and
saw the total population for all the
cities in Rajasthan and Karnataka
in the next sheet
we explored another feature that was to
find the percentage contribution of male
and female literatures from each state
then
here we saw how to find out
the bottom three cities for each state
having lowest female graduates and one
thing marked that some of the states did
not have three cities for example
Andaman had only one city that was sport
player but the others we found out the
bottom three cities that had the lowest
female graduates
finally we looked at how to create a
calculated field in a pivot table so we
saw
how to create a calculated field called
sales
and then we explored how to create
different charts and graphs so this was
an area chart that we saw is a column
chart we also saw or looked at
a bar chart that was a horizontal bar
chart similarly we saw how to create a
pie chart as well
so how to create a puppet chart you ask
it is really simple all you need to do
is just follow few steps and you have
your perfect chart ready which is
completely interactive now all you have
to do is select any cell in the data set
you have and rush into the insert
toolbar then in the group of charts you
have an option called pivot chart select
on it now you'll be asked to select the
data range and you can see Excel has
automatically select all the range that
you want to include in your pivot chart
then you have another option which is
asking you to either create the pivot
chart in the current worksheet or a new
worksheet for now let's select a new
worksheet and there you go voila the
paper chart is completely ready you
might ask me this is completely empty
yes the default pivot chart what you get
from Excel will be completely empty but
you can add the Legends and all the data
that you want to add onto your pivot
chart just by dragon and dropping the
data from the right hand side of your
Excel sheet that is from the pivot chart
Fields so you can see we have various
options region category state
subcategory sales quantity Etc now I'll
add region
I'll add region to access
and comparatively we will see the sales
that are happening in those particular
regions by dragging sales into values
now you have all the data in the form of
pivot chart which is completely
interactive which represents the sales
happening in those regions now you can
also select a particular region right by
default all the regions are selected but
if you want to select only Central then
you can do that by deserting everything
and select only Central and select OK
and there you go you have all the data
related to the sales happening in the
central region now if you want to you
know kind of see all the categories of
sales happening in all the regions you
can drag the category into values again
and in the region part
okay I think we have to add category
into Legends yes now select a region
slab that is all regions and select OK
and you can see the category wise sales
in all the regions at one single go and
I hope you did not observe it clearly uh
the Excel also gives you the completely
prepared pivot table as well right which
is also interactive you can also get to
choose the data from here as well and
select OK and you'll see that being
reflected on the pivot chart so here you
can see both pivot table and pivot
charts are completely Interactive
now here we have four different sheets
of the sales so the first sheet is the
West Zone next is South Zone a Zone and
central zone so all this data belongs to
one single sheet that is Superstore
dataset so I have categorized or I have
taken a part of the data which belongs
to central region South Region west
region and east region now we are going
to use all these four sheets and create
one single sheet which is the pivot
table of all the four sheets now without
further Ado let's start the process now
for that we might want to use the
shortbread key that is alt D now press P
now this starts the pivot chart wizard
now here we have to choose the option
multiple consolidation ranges
then click on next
and here you can see the pivot table is
clicked by default
now we'll go to next now here click I
will create page Fields or the pivot
chart wizard will automatically create
if you want that to create for you now
click on next now here let's select the
range
now I'll be selecting the range
now next we'll Select East
right
followed by that we have South
and finally we have best
now we will name these according to the
regions
so the first one will be West
one will be South
X1 will be East
and the last one will be Central
click on next and here select new
worksheet and finish
and there you go you have the pivot
table here now you might want to change
the summation value
so click anywhere on the pivot table and
change it from count to
sum
so that you have the summation of the
total number of sales subcategory sales
and grand total of sales Etc now
here you can see all option now let's
select Central and you'll get the
details of the central region the grand
total and the sales happening quantity
of sales Etc now here you can you can
see the furniture office supplies
technology and the grand total all in
one single sheet now let's get back to
the original sheet
so as you can see this is the original
sheet and in the original sheet you can
see various more categories
which is the which is the shipment mode
customer segment country city state
and you also have product name
subcategory Etc so if you had added all
these into this sheet you can also
create a separate option of adding my
new details to your pivot table
so that is how the pivot table is
created using multiple sheets
mail merge in Excel is a simple yet
spectacular method to write similar
emails to hundreds and thousands of
recipients without a hassle or even a
single error
let us imagine that you are supposed to
write an interview call letter to
multiple recipients
so what if you had like five recipes you
could do five different emails and you
could send them but what if you had 50
or even 500
right that would seem a little
Troublesome and you might even feel that
you might want a whole team to do that
right but what if I say that you can do
the same with one single mail within a
matter of minutes you send all the
emails to all the 50 or 500 recipients
sounds interesting right so now in this
particular tutorial we are going to do
the scene now without further Ado let's
directly get on to the Practical mode
and start our Excel and try to do some
mail merge in Excel
now we are on practical mode and we have
started our Microsoft Excel so regarding
the example we discussed earlier that is
sending an interview call letter to
multiple people that's what exactly this
Excel sheet does so here we have about
25 members or 25 candidates with their
first name last name and email and their
address written over now where is our
call letter now this happens to be our
call letter so the call letter is been
sent from an imaginary company that has
smart Solutions private limited India
and followed by that we are having one
recipient here who happens to be Mia and
the subject and everything all the text
related to the interview call
now we are trying to send this one
single interview call letter to all the
25 people now the only change that is
going to happen is the recipient's name
and address is going to change and the
addressing for example here you can see
dear Mia so instead of dear Mia we're
going to greet the recipient with their
particular name so that's what we're
going to try to do now so to do that you
have to go into the toolbar and select
mailings option
in the mailings option you can see the
start mail merge select recipients edit
recipient and all other options so here
you might want to select the second
group and inside the second group you
have an option called select recipients
click on that and now it will show you
some options the first one is type A new
list so if you are having Sim list then
you can type in or if you already have
an existing list like what we did
creating an Excel sheet and storing all
the email and address and all the
recipients complete details you can use
that as well
so here we're going to use the existing
list so click on that
now it will show you a new dialog box
using which you have to navigate to the
existing list
so our existing list is named as mail
merge so click on that and select open
now press ok
now the next part is to address all the
details so here you can see that
to address and after that you can see
the addressing of the recipient now we
have to encode this mail in such a way
that to all the recipients automatically
Excel will replace the addresses names
and the greetings right now let's try
that
now let's try to encode the address part
so highlight the address part and in the
same mail links option you can find the
address block and write and insert
Fields ribbon
so let's select that and now you can see
the address of everyone
right
so this is the preview of the
recipient's address now you can see that
the recipient's full name and state is
only available here not this street and
house number Etc now you can fix that by
selecting the match Fields option and
here you can include the address so
which might be the Hauser department and
the second one would be Street and
postal code you can match it with PIN
code
and that's all yeah remaining we have
everything else let's look at the
preview and this is how it looks like
perfect
now let's select ok
that's fine
and similarly we will also try to match
the
just a moment yeah similarly we'll try
to encode the recipient's name now for
that let's go into the greetings line
here you can see you can select the
option Dear Sir or dear Mom or to
whomever makes may concern and here you
have another option two or just dear so
we'll go with deer and this is how the
preview looks like
and if you're happy with that it's okay
and if you want to parallely check for
other things I mean other recipients you
can also do that for example the next
recipient is Santosh shastri and
followed by him we have prabhakar Reddy
Rajesh saho right you can also check
everything and here you can also see the
address changing on the mail so you can
check for jagadish Chari his address and
his name
right so it looks like it's working
perfectly now select OK and that's done
now we are in the final stage and in the
mailings option you can see the last two
options in the address the preview
results and finish so before merging and
finishing the mail merge we shouldn't go
through a quick preview to check if
everything is fine or not so here you
can see we have the address block this
is how the encoding looks like and if
you
replace the encoding with the actual
address and name this is how the actual
address and name looked like and you can
check all the letters you can just click
on the Arrow key here and you can check
all the recipients address and their
names
right so if you can find any errors you
can replace them and if not if
everything is fine then you can just
quickly press on the finish and merge
option when you finish merge option or
finish inverse option you get three
different
options that is edit individual
documents print documents and send all
these to the recipients now if you had
any queries or if you had any doubts
about or if you find any errors on the
emails then you can go to that
particular individual document and edit
it with the first option and in the
second option you can print all the
documents like if you want to send a
hard copy then you can print it
so you can see here all and select OK
and then you can you know kind of save
it as a PDF or you can send the location
of your printer and then just press ok
right you can just save them in the form
of PDF
or you can directly send the emails
right now I'm not connected to any
printer so I'm not going to print any
documents now let us try the last one
this should be interesting
now when you select the mail option
then it automatically selects the email
column from your Excel sheet remember we
had an email column from Excel sheet
right this particular column word
automatically selects that column from
Excel and you can just select OK and all
the mails will be sent to all these
imaginary mailing addresses
so that's how it's done what is Excel
vlookup
vlookup stands for vertical lookup
vlookup lets you search for specific
information in your spreadsheet it
allows you to search for a particular
value in a column and returns another
value from a different column but of the
same row
vlookup takes advantage of vertically
aligned tables to quickly find data
associated with the value the user
enters now let's look at the syntax to
write a vlookup function so vlookup
takes four parameters or arguments you
can see it here there are four arguments
in the Wilco function
so the first argument is called the
lookup value the look of value
represents the value that you are
searching for next is the table array
the table array represents two or more
Columns of information the third
argument is called the column index
number now this represents the column
number in the table from which the value
must be returned the First Column is 1
the second column is 2 and so on and
then we have the fourth parameter which
is called the range lookup now this
parameter is optional now range lookup
is used to find an exact match
so if you want to find an exact match
you need to enter false or 0 meanwhile
if you want an approximate match you
need to enter true or one if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
now let me give you a brief overview on
what's going to be in our demo
so for our demonstration
we'll use a sales data set you can see
the data set on the left
using this data set we'll understand how
vlookup performs an exact and
approximate match we'll see how vlookup
is case insensitive
then we'll perform a wildcard character
search
will understand how to handle errors
when a match is not found and finally
you will look at two-way lookups
now here is a small example of how
vlookup works
so we want to find the units sold by
Morgan using the data set on the left
so here you can see I have the data set
it has
some rows and columns so these are the
columns which are order date region
there's a representative column item
units this unit cost and total and from
this table I want to find the units that
were sold by Morgan if you look at the
table at the bottom you can see the
representative name Morgan and Morgan
has sold 30 units now I want to find
this value using the vlookup function so
here on the right you can see I have my
lookup value which is Morgan and this is
my vlookup formula and using this
formula I am getting the result as 30.
now let's go to our Excel workbook and
perform all the demos one by one so this
is my Excel workbook that we are going
to use for our demo and here is the data
set we'll be using now this is the same
data set that you saw a while ago
so this data set has seven columns you
have the order date the region
representative's name item this units
unit cost and total which is basically
the total or the amount of sales that
was generated
we are going to use a chunk of this data
set and perform our vlookup analysis
so let's see our first example and the
problem we have at hand
let me go to the exact match tab
all right
so here
I am going to use this chunk of data
which is actually taken from the
original data set so we have taken the
first
11 rows from the data set you can see
from Row 2
till row 12 is going to be a data set
that we'll use
so we have a question here
we want to find the items sold by
Thomson
so here
Thompson is my lookup value which means
looking at Thompson I want to find the
item that is sold
so if you consider our table here you
can see we have the representatives name
Thompson right here and from the table
you can see Thompson sold pencil
and I want to get this value which is
pencil using my vlookup function so
let's go ahead and write our vlooker
function
I'll consider this as my lookup value
and here under item I'm going to write
my vlooker formula
to write the vlooker formula I'll write
first equal to
and
I'll write vlookup now if I hit tab it
will auto complete all right now let's
give the parameters so first is going to
be the lookup value which is nothing but
Thomson so I'll just select this cell
which is j17
comma now it's asking to give the table
array so the table array is the table
from which you want to retrieve a value
one thing to keep in mind is that the
value you are looking for should be the
first column of a table and you can
select the table array till the end of
the data set or till the column which
has the value you want to find
so here I'll select my table array
starting from the representatives column
till the end of the item column which is
going to be my table array then I'll
select the column index number so the
column index number is based on the
table array you have selected in this
case my column index number is going to
be 2 because we have selected just two
columns and the value which I am going
to find is in the second column so I'll
give two
comma now the range lookup I am going to
give is false because I want to find an
exact match so either you can hit tab
or you can write 0 which means false
if I close the bracket and hit enter
it will return me the item that Thomson
had sold which is pencil you can verify
from the table that Thompson had sold
pencil all right
now let's try to change the table array
and see what result are we getting so
this time I'll slightly change the table
array so again we are trying to find the
item that Thompson had sold so I'll
write my formula equal to vlookup I'll
hit tab to auto complete I'll give my
lookup value as Thompson
comma this time I am choosing my table
array starting from the representatives
column till
the end of the data set which is
till p12
again my column index number is going to
be 2 because if you consider this table
array the item column is the second
column in the selected table array so I
am going to write it as 2 comma
the range lookup I want to give as false
because I want to find the exact match
if I close this and hit enter you can
see it has written me the same result
that we saw earlier
now suppose let's say this time I want
to start my table array from the region
column which is this column so I want to
select my table array starting from the
region column now this is going to show
me an error because your table array
should always start from the lookup
value column so if you consider Thompson
as the lookup value
my table array should always start from
the representatives column so let's just
try this example
so I'll write vlookup
my lookup value I'm going to give it as
Thompson comma the table array as I
mentioned earlier I am going to choose
from the region column and let's say
I'll select till the item column give
another comma and this time a column
index number is going to be 3 because
since the table array has three columns
and my item column is the last column so
I'm going to give my column index number
is 3 comma I want to get the exact match
so I'll give 0 if I close the bracket
and hit enter you can see it has given
me
an error
okay now let me just show you another
method to use vlookup in Excel so here
on the top you can see there's a
formulas Tab and under formulas tab
under function Library you see we have
an option to select lookup and reference
if I click on this
and if I scroll down below you can see
there's an option
called vlookup let's choose this
all right now here you can give
your lookup value your table array
column index number and the range lookup
under this function arguments dialog box
so here I want to select my lookup value
as
Thompson my table array is going to be
from the representatives column till
let's say the end of the data set
my column index number is going to be 2
I'll write 2
and range lookup I'll write as false
because I want the exact match
if I hit OK you can see
it has given us the exact same result so
this is one of the other ways to use
vlookup in Excel now let's move to the
next sheet which is regarding
approximate match okay so sometimes you
might have cases where you don't have
the lookup value present in the table in
those cases you can tell vlookup to
return an approximate match
now one thing to keep in mind is that
your lookup value column should always
be sorted in ascending order while
trying to get an approximate match so
here we are going to use this table and
my lookup value column which is going to
be the representatives column is already
sorted in ascending order
and let's see the question we have here
so I want to find the item sold and the
unit cost format so my lookup value is
going to be matte now if you see this
table I don't have the representative's
name matte anywhere in the table now
using an approximate match I want to
find the item and the unit cost so let's
do it
so here under item I'll write my vlooker
formula
so I'll type vlookup I'll hit tab to
complete it
and this time meluco value is going to
be matte so I'll select this cell comma
my table array I'll select
from the representatives column till
the end of
item column because I want to find the
item value format
I'll give a comma
my column index number as per the table
array is going to be 2
comma my range lookup this time I am
going to give a true or one
so I'll write 1
close the bracket hit enter
all right it has written me binder was
the item sold by Matt
now let's try to figure out why vlookup
returned binder as the item
now let's see you were asked to insert
the name matte to the representative
column in alphabetical order so where
would you place it ideally you should
Place between qvel and Morgan
since this column is already sorted
matte should appear before Morgan and
after cubelle so in an approximate match
vlookup will consider the previous
highest value
in this case the previous highest value
before mat is qvl and hence vlookup
returned the corresponding item
purchased by kevl which is binder now
similarly
if you wanted to find the unit cost
format
again vlookup will return the unit cost
of cubel which is 125. let's just try it
out so I'll write vlookup
my lookup value is matte comma my table
array for this time is going to be from
Representatives column till the unit
cost column I'll consider
I'll give a comma now the column index
number as per the table array is going
to be 4 will give another comma and this
time I'll double click true because I
want an approximate match we close the
bracket hit enter you can see it has
written me 125 which is actually
cables unit cost okay we have another
question and this time I want to find
the units sold by Rob now Rob is going
to be my lookup value
if you see the representatives column we
don't have Rob now let's see what
vlookup is going to return as the item
for Rob so I'll write vlookup I'll give
my lookup value as Rob comma my table
array
is going to start from the
representatives column I'll select till
here I'll give a comma my column index
number is 2
we give another comma
I'll double click on true
so close the bracket hit enter you can
see vlookup has written me pen now let's
understand why vlookup returned pen for
Rob now if you are asked to insert the
representatives name Rob
into this column so ideally Rob would
appear somewhere between Morgan and
Sorvino because
since this is sorted in ascending order
Rob is actually greater than Morgan and
is less than Sorvino so as you know
vlookup in an approximate match Returns
the previous highest value which is
Morgan here and the corresponding item
for Morgan is pen and hence we look up
returned pen from Rob all right
now moving to the next sheet
which is another property of vlookup
which tells vlookup always looks to the
right this means that your lookup value
must always be on the left
and the value you are going to find out
should always be to the right of the
table now consider this scenario where
you look up value is on the left in this
case it is the representatives value and
I have taken cervino for an example
and we want to find the order date for
Sorvino
now if you consider this table your
lookup value which is sure we know is
actually this column the representatives
column and we are going to find out the
order date so your representative's name
is on the right of the table and the
value we are going to find out is on the
left of the table
now as per the property vlookup only
looks to the right
so if I use the vlookup function for
this example here I'll write vlookup
I'll give my lookup value as sorbino
comma
multiple array I'll consider from the
order date because I want the order date
till
the representatives column I'll give a
comma and this time
index number is actually the first
column if I consider my table array as
the first three columns selected
and my range lookup is going to be false
if I close the bracket hit enter it
returns me an error the reason is
vlookup always looks to the right and
this time the value we were trying to
find out was to the left of the table
now
if you consider
the opposite case suppose you have the
order date and you want to find the
representative's name you can do that
easily because you look up value which
is the order date is on the left and
your representatives column is on the
right so let's just try this I'll write
vlookup my lookup value is going to be
order date so I'll select it from the
table
I'll give a comma my table array will
start from the G column let's say I'll
select the entire table
comma and my column index number will be
3 if you consider these as my table
array
comma my range lookup is zero if I close
this hit enter you can see we have got
Sorvino corresponding to the order date
all right now let's move to the next tab
now this tab says vlookup returns only
the first match so we have a question at
hand the question is
find the units sold by Jardine
if you see this table
we have the representatives name Jardin
twice you see here and if you look down
we have Jardin here as well but the
items sold by Jardin at the first
instance is pencil and at the second
instance it's desk
now as per the property vlookup always
returns the first match now ideally when
we write the vlookup function and look
for the units sold by Jardine you will
see vlookup will return
36 instead of 3. let's just try it out
I'll write the vlookup function
my lookup value is Jardine
comma my table array
I'll select from the representatives
column till the end of
units column
will give a comma my column index number
based on the table array is three I'll
give another comma Now I want the exact
match so I'll select 0
close the bracket and hit enter
as you can see it returns me the first
match of Jardine which is 36 so vlookup
did not consider the second match
now similarly
if you consider this table
we have Jones repeated Thrice so you
have Jones here
you have Jones here for the second time
and also we have Jones for the third
time
and let's see you want to find the unit
cost for Jones so if I write the vlookup
function
I'll consider my
lookup value as Jones comma my table
array
I'll select from the representatives
column till the end of unit cost column
I'll give a comma based on the table
array my unit cost column is at the
fourth index so I'll write 4 comma the
range lookup is 0.
if I click on this
and hit enter you can see it here
vlookup has returned the first instance
of Jones and it did not consider the
second and the third instance so our
unit cost
for Jones is 1.99 because vlookup only
Returns the first match
okay moving ahead to the next example we
have here is vlookup is case insensitive
if you consider this table
I've added another
Row in green
so if you see here I have a
representative name called Gill which is
in proper case or
popularly known as sentence case here I
have added Gill's name in
capital letters are all in uppercase so
I want to find the total revenue
generated by Gill the total revenue is
basically the total column
let's do it all right vlookup
my lookup value is Gill which is
actually in upper case
I'll consider my table array from the
representatives column till the end of
total column or the sales column
based on the selection my column index
number is 5.
comma the range lookup is false so I'll
just double click on false
if we close the bracket hit enter
you can see it here
our vlookup function has returned the
total as
539.73 which is actually
the value for this row so clearly
vlookup did not consider Gill which was
present at the bottom of the table in
upper case
so this shows that vlookup is clearly
case insensitive
all right
now moving to the next example the
vlooker function supports wild cards
which makes it possible to perform a
partial match on a lookup value for
instance you can use vlookup to retrieve
values from a table after typing only
part of a lookup value to use wildcards
with vlookup you must specify the exact
match by giving false or 0 for the last
argument that is range lookup now we
have a question here
I want to know how much sales did the
representative whose name starts with Ki
make now here sales represents the total
column actually
so I want to find out the person whose
name starts with Ki
so if you consider the representative
column I have one representative whose
name starts with Ki that is key well so
using Ki as my lookup value I want to
find the total so let me show you
how to use wildcard characters and find
the value using vlookup
so I'll write my function vlookup
okay now in lookup value I'll give Ki
after that I am going to write Ampersand
followed by
double inverted commas
then I'm going to write a star
and close the inverted comma this means
the value starts with Ki Amber sent
actually represents concatenation and
star represents anything followed by Ki
so this is going to be my lookup value
in total
I'll give a comma
next I'll select my table array starting
from the representatives column till the
end of total column because I want to
find the sales
and give another comma
my column index number based on the
table array we have selected is 5
comma the range lookup is 0 because I
want to find an exact match
let's close the bracket hit enter you
can see it here
vlookup has returned me 999.5 which is
actually Cable's total
now there's another way to do it
instead of selecting the cell in which
we have the lookup value I can directly
write it in the vlookup function
so I'll write the vlooker function
something like this so my lookup value
I'll pass Ki within double inverted
commas because k i is a character value
So within double inverted commas I'm
writing Ki followed by Ampersand which
is for concatenation
followed by
a star
within double inverted commas so this is
going to be my lookup values this in
total means anything that appears after
Ki will be considered as the lookup
value
again the table array I'll select as
these rows and columns
comma my column index number would be 5
comma the range lookup is zero if I
close the bracket hit enter you see we
have the same value so this is another
method or another way of using
vlookups
okay now moving ahead let's explore
another feature of vlookup so if the
vlookup function cannot find a match it
returns a has an a error now if you want
you can use the if any function to
replace the hash any error with a
friendly message so suppose
you want to find the region in which an
order was placed on 10th of May 2018.
now if the order date is not found I
want to return a message that is invalid
date
so
if you look at the order date
column we don't have any value for 10th
of May 2015. you can see these values we
don't have any value corresponding to
this date
so
if my vlookup function cannot find this
lookup value I'll return invalid date so
let me show you
how to write this
I'll type my vlookup function
I'll give my order date as 10th of May
2015.
as my lookup value and then
I'll consider my table array starting
from the order date column till the end
of
region column
will give another comma my column index
number would be 2 this time based on the
table array we have selected comma
I want an exact match
so I'll give 0 close the bracket and hit
enter
there you go it has returned me an error
now I want to convert this error to a
friendly message saying invalid date so
let me show you how to do it I'll do it
here so to return a valid message
I'll use the if any function
and within if any function I'll give my
vlookup function so let me type if n a
I'll hit tab
now for the value parameter I'll use my
vlookup function so my lookup value is
going to be the order date
comma my table array I'll select from
the order date column till the end of
region column comma where column index
number is going to be 2
comma my range lookup is 0
I close the bracket give another comma
Now if this expression results in an
error I want to display a message that
is invalid date so I'll put invalid date
within double quotes
since it is
a text message
I close the bracket hit enter you can
see
the result which is invalid date
now moving on to the final section of
the demo
we have two-way lookup
now in the vlookup function the column
index parameter is normally hard coded
as a static number however you can also
create a dynamic column index by using
the match function to locate the right
column
and this technique allows you to create
a dynamic two-way lookup matching on
both rows and columns
now let me first show you how a match
function works so suppose
I want to find the index where unit cost
column is present
so here I'll use the match function
I'll give my lookup value as the unit
cost column name
comma suppose I'll choose my lookup
array starting from Representatives
column till the unit cost column comma
I'll give my match type as 0 for exact
match
if I close the bracket hit enter it
returns me 4 because
my array was selected from the
representatives column till the unit
cost column and in this array unit cost
is at the fourth index
all right now using this idea let's
solve the following problem I want to
find the cost of each item sold by
Morgan
so let's
write our vlookup formula
write vlookup
my lookup value is J5 which has the
representative's name as Morgan comma
my table array I'll select from
C2
till
F12
I'll give a comma and this time I know
that my column index number is at
4 but I'll be using the match function
to find the same
so I'll write match
my lookup value is
unit cost comma
my lookup array is from C1 till F1
comma my match type is 0
I close this bracket give another comma
and I'll give my range lookup as 0
close the bracket hit enter you can see
for Morgan the unit cost is 19.99 you
can verify from the table for Morgan the
unit cost is 19.99
all right now
we have another question here
I want to find how much sales did
Andrews make in the central region so
here I have
two lookup values one is Central one is
Andrew's now looking at these two values
I want to find the total
to solve such problems
let me first create
another table
I'll place the table somewhere here
okay so let me just paste the table here
all right now I'll create another column
where I'll merge the values of region
and representatives so here let me
create another column okay I'll just
name this column as
region
rep
all right now this column
I'll use the concatenation operator
so I'll Select East
use Ampersand and then select Jones I'll
hit enter
now the same thing I'll just duplicate
it
for the other rows as well so I have my
new column created Now using this table
I can easily solve the problem
now to find the total I'll write my
vlookup formula
so my lookup value
will be a combination of j11
ampersand
k11
comma well table array will start from
the region rep which has the values of
region and rep combined
till
the last column
and from this table array my column
index number is 5
and my range lookup is zero if I close
the bracket hit enter you can see
for central region which is this one
and for Andrews representative the total
is 149.25
all right now we are done with our demo
let's have a quick glance at what all we
did in this demo
okay so first of all we saw our data set
which was a sales data set that we used
then we started with our first example
to see how vlooker performs an exact
match we also saw how using the formulas
Tab and lookup
and reference you can
write vlookup in
another way so you can use the function
arguments to give your vlookup
parameters next we saw how vlooker
performs an approximate match so we had
matte and raw which were not present in
the representatives column
after that
we saw an important property of vlookup
that is vlookup only looks to the right
followed by
vlookup only Returns the first match
following which we saw
that vlookup is case insensitive so here
we had added a new row where Gill was
present in uppercase but still we look
up
found the total revenue for Gill which
was in sentence case or proper case next
we saw how we can use wildcard
characters to
use vlookups
and here we saw how to use an if any
function along with vlookup and finally
we saw how to use two-way lookups choose
from over 300 in-demand skills and get
access to 1000 plus hours of video
content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more now we are on
the sheet of Microsoft Excel and here
you can see some data on my sheet
that is employee name employee ID and
salary
so here we are going to perform our
horizontal lookup but before that let me
show you that this particular drop down
menu so this particular drop down menu
has all the names of the employees in
this particular table and we have
created this using data validation in
Excel if you want to create the drop
down menus just like this then feel free
to check out our data validation in
Excel tutorial link to which is in the
description box below now let's try to
implement each lookup in Excel so here
we have employee name but we want to
find out the employee ID so for that
let's create the hlookup now for that
equals to hlookup
now the first one is a lookup value so
this one is the cell which is the
employee name now after that the table
array we have to select all the table
arrays here
now
the row index number so the employee ID
is in row index number 2 according to
the table so for that provide 2 and
close the bracket and before closing
brackets you might want to give the
exact match so for exact match select
false and close the bracket press enter
and there you go and if you select Jack
then you'll find the employee ID of
check and if you select Jerry you'll
find the employee ID of cherry
reflecting here now similarly let's find
out the salary of all the employees
using hlookup so equals hlookup
and lookup value that happens to be the
name of the employee now the table array
and next we have row index number that
is salary happens to be the third row in
the table so three and
exact match
close the bracket and enter so now if
you change the values in this particular
drop down menu you will find the
employee ID and their particular salary
so Jack happens to be carrying the
employee ID as one zero zero one and his
salary is ten thousand so similarly
let's try to find out Peter's employee
ID and salary
so there you go one zero zero five and
fifty thousand as salary so that's how
you use hlookup in Excel here you can
see the first chart so this particular
data is converted into a table format to
avoid confusion while you're fixing the
data so here you can see the name of the
employee employee ID Department salary
and date of Channel and here you can see
the salary column and the bonus
percentage of each and every employee
based on their salaries now coming to
the new data table and here on the
tables 2 which is an updated table here
you can find we are going to find out
the department of the employee and the
current Department of employee and the
bonus percentage based on his or her
salary so why are we finding current
Department again so here you can see
that we have an intern Emily who has
joined in the year 2020 but recently she
got promoted as a developer so her
department has been changed from
Department in turn to Department
developer in 2021 so that's what we're
gonna find out here in the current
Department using X lookup now let's
start to implement X lookup so for that
equals to X lookup
and for lookup you can see we need to
find out the lookup value lookup array
return array and all the other two are
not important right now but you can use
them to get some exact matches in the
future we'll also use that in the future
for now let's try to use the first three
parameters that is lookup value lookup
array and written array so the lookup
value is the name of the employee Mary
and lookup array is right here which is
this one
now we are going to select the lookup
array then comma and we're going to look
up the department so this is the
department lookup array
and that's all we need
close the bracket and press enter
okay I think we missed out the lookup
value
so the employee or the lookup value
which we required was missed so I've
added it here so that is the lookup
value the first one which is midi and
there you go
press enter and you have the department
here now let's add it to all the rows
and here you have all the rows and all
the data related all the employees now
we will find out the current Department
as you can see here you have Emily as
intern which is the older data but what
if he needed the latest data that is the
developer in the year 2021 right for
that you might want to throw up the X
lookup formula a little bit so let's try
that X lookup
lookup value which is the scene and
comma now where you have to look for the
array that is lookup array this one and
the return array which happens to be
this one
and next
you can find the exact match for this
one so that's all right exact match and
here comes the important part where you
have to search last to first by default
X lookup searches for first to last
there is like this in the starting place
to the last place so that's the reason
why we had Emily as intern so now if we
give last to first then it retrieves the
latest data where Emily will be shown as
developer now select that and now you
can close the brackets and press enter
so let's add that to all the rows there
you go now you can see Emily Clark Peter
and James all they have got their
updated job profiles as you can see in
the original data Emily is a developer
now so is Clark who was originally a
tester and he got promoted to
development team in 2021 similarly Peter
became a senior Finance executive in
2021 and James the manager of sales now
let's try to find out the bonus for all
these employees based on their salary so
this one is quite simple
so X lookup
now the lookup value is their existing
salary
comma and the bonus part so the lookup
array is the salary range
then here is another important point so
here you might want to find the exact
match but finding an exact match will
not help you here you might want to
declare another type of value where you
can get exact match or next smaller item
so you'll understand it why I'm
selecting that so now let's close the
bracket and enter so
so now we have the bonus values now
let's add the bonus value to all the
factors all the rows I mean so you can
see we have different variety of
salaries that is thirty eight thousand
twenty two thousand thirty nine Etc but
here in the ranges we have provided 10
20 30 1450. so what if the value is
between 30 and 20 that's when you want
the less number right that's when you
want the number which is equivalent to
30 or less than 30 which happens to be
15 percent so that's how it has worked
here that is 0.15 bonus to the actual
salary now we are on our Excel sheet
here you can see the employee names and
employee IDs of different employees from
different zones let us imagine that the
blue one is from East Green one is from
West and the black one is from or the
purple one is from South and the orange
one is from North so this data is a
little small but what if we had a data
with hundreds or thousands of rows
including all the Android names employee
IDs or another relevant data type like
sales of an employee and his employee ID
and you are supposed to combine all the
data from all the four different zones
into one single sheet it would consume a
lot of time right so recently Microsoft
has released some latest updates based
on arrays and details so one of those is
v stack function in Excel so how to use
it since it is a latest function I
recommend you to go to the file menu and
in the file menu you can navigate to
account and in the account you can see
the option of update options then you
can select update now and your Microsoft
Office will be updated to the latest
version and you'll get access to the
latest functions in Excel and all the
other office related things like power
one presentation Etc
now we are going to implement the
v-stack function in Excel it is
completely simple all you need to do is
equals to stack and then select the data
remember to select the data from column
A and cell to other row 2. we are not
selecting the employment and employee ID
we are just selecting the data now
separate them by comma then again this
one here this set and again this one
and again lastly in this particular last
set
now close the bracket and press enter
and there you go you have all the
employee names and their respective
employee IDs all together in one data
set so this is how you use restack
function in Excel and there are also a
few more new updates from Microsoft
Excel and we will discuss on them sooner
so the name itself conveys that it is
something like a reference function
right so it refers to a cell which is
present in a particular sheet or the
current sheet or it refers to a
particular range in the current sheet or
it can also refer to an entire workbook
in a current window right so you can
stay here on the sheet number one and
you can refer something which is present
on the sheet number 10 or 11. you can
stay in this current workbook and refer
to something which is around in a
different workbook altogether so that's
exactly how the indirect function in
Excel works okay so I guess the
definition was a little uh difficult to
get let me show you a simple demo here
so that it becomes a little easier for
you So currently I am in the cell number
A2 right now here I will implement the
indirect function
press tab to select it and now I'll
refer to the cell C2 and let's enter and
there you go let me properly close the
window it's there
so let me implement the indirect
function here so equals to indirect and
press tab to select now I'll be
selecting the cell C2 and inside C2 we
have E2 address now the formula is fine
I have implemented the indirect function
and selected the cell E2 and now if I
press enter see the magic there you go
so in the cell E2 we have the text hello
open so when I use the indirect function
to refer which is something in C2 it is
indirectly referring to another cell
address that is E2 which has a text
hello world now this one was a little
pretty simpler now let's check some
complicated ones
and we'll move to sheet number one
here we have some student names and
their uh you know uh marks on the
individual subjects that has math
science English computer science and
here and here you can see I'm selecting
the student names and accordingly I'm
getting their average score and the
total marks obtained right seems
interesting how did I do this so this is
done exactly using the indirect function
so let's do it again so this is how you
do it now here I will be using okay
before we get into this we need to do
some fundamentals before we do it right
so the fundamentals are you need to name
your individual columns so here I have
Brian and his marks so I'll select
entire marks of brine ranging from B2 to
B for right click and here you can see
Define name and I'll be naming it as
brine
it's already new we might get an error
so it's already name okay let's add
another one maybe
uh Jennifer let's cancel this
so let's add
Jenny
and her marks will be 96
87 I'm selecting some random numbers
here
so 87.
so we have the new column here now we
need to name this column Define a name
and it's Jenny so Excel has
automatically selected the name for this
column so let's press ok now we have our
columns ready now here if you see the
drop down we have Amy Banner Brian Brock
Emily Jenny John everyone over here
right so the columns are new the
individual columns are named so now the
student name so here you can use some
simple trick called Data validation here
select the data option in the toolbar
navigate to data tools here select data
validation
and in this instead of any value select
list and here give the source as this
particular set
press ok so that you get the drop down
menu over here you can also type the
individual names again when you type the
individual names you might go wrong with
the case or spelling right so it's
better always to use this kind of list
options which will make things easier
for you now getting into the average
calculation so here the average will be
uh equals to average
press tab to select now the indirect
function indirect of
the cell address
and close the bracket first you might
get an error because currently it is
empty so select some name and you will
get your average score now same thing
applies to you know total you can press
the sum function select the sum function
and type in the indirect function and
the cell
v11 close the brackets and press enter
so that's how you do it as
post graduate program in date and date
Analytics
textbook look at the features followed
by the skills you will gain through this
course some key features of this
comprehensive program includes exclusive
hackathons and anything sessions by IBM
eight times higher LIVE edition in live
online classes by industry experts
Capstone from three domains and 14 plus
data analytics projects with industry
data sets from Google Play Store Lyft
World Bank Etc masterclass was delivered
by Purdue faculty and IBM experts simply
learns job assist helps you to get
noticed by top hiring companies and much
much more it is well said when skills
Empower possibilities flourish to grab
the opportunities gain skills like data
analytics statistical analysis using
Excel data analysis Python and R data
visualization Tableau and power bi and
much more so what are you waiting for
hurry up and enroll Now find the course
Link in the description box
now at times you might be working on a
really important spreadsheet on your
Excel or you might have the sales data
of your company or some confidential
data of your organization and you might
have shared the file with your junior or
you might face some pocket issue and you
forgot to save or you must to save your
data and what to do if you cannot save
your data and how can you recover it
right so this might be a really big
hassle today we are exactly going to
discuss the same and see how to do it in
multiple ways so Excel comes up with an
option to automatically save the data
also it will try to warn you that your
data is not being saved would you like
me to save it or not right so we'll do
the first one so here you have the auto
save option you can either say ok to it
or you can ignore it in case if you
ignore it if you choose to ignore it or
if you choose to manually save it and
then if you want to close the file
remember we haven't saved the file if
you wish to close it Excel will
automatically come up with a dialog box
asking you want to save your changes to
your data.xl SX that means it is asking
you if I have to save it or not let's
try to ignore this and forcefully let's
try to close it you can go to task
manager option here we are trying to
simulate the option of Parker tissues
so we are forcefully closing Excel
without saving any data
so we have closed it now here you can
see we do not have Excel running in the
background now when you directly open or
try to start Excel when you get the
power backup again and if you want to
open that same data file it will ask you
the document recovery option it says you
have close the file without saving the
changes and you can choose to you know
come back from the same place where we
left last time okay now that was the
Parker tissue and now let's see uh
another way okay let's imagine that
somebody
eliminated a few important data files
from your organization's confidential
data employee ID employee name Etc and
again let's simulate the force uh close
of the Excel
now we are closing it again without
saving no data was being saved
now it will also ask the same data it
has another version here the original
one which wasn't saved so here you can
recover the same file again however it
was initially so you can save it and it
will get back to the original place
so this was one way also we have another
few multiple ways just we have to
navigate to file and here you can open
and in the open menu you have a button
called recover unsaved workbooks not
just the current workbook it will also
have all the remaining files which are
related to excel that are not saved so
here you have a few workbooks which was
not saved this is one option and we also
have another option we can just navigate
to info and there you have another
option called manage workbook and in the
manage workbook you have another option
called recover unsaved workbooks which
will also redirect you to the same file
that is Microsoft Office and set files
and you'll have all the unsaid workbooks
which are related to excel so this is
how you can recover the unsaved data in
Excel using multiple ways first thing
Excel will automatically ask you if you
have to save the file or not and in case
if you forget to save it you can
directly recover it by default by Excel
it will automatically show that some
folder was not saved on the left side of
your Excel spreadsheet by default and in
case if you missed out on that one you
can manually go to file and you can
either choose open option or info option
to recover the unsaid folders from your
default file location from your page see
that as Microsoft Office and saved files
Etc
which will have all the list of all
unsaved workbooks related to excel let's
see what is a project plan project plan
is a basic thing that is needed to
execute a project according to project
management book of knowledge a project
can be defined as an approved
elaborative document that guides the
team during project execution and
project control when we are making a
project plan a project plan must answer
several questions for us these questions
are like what are we expecting our
project to deliver how are we expecting
to get our deliverables within the
desired time who all will be a part of a
project and what tasks they will have in
the project when will the project start
and when it is expected to end that is
the deadlines of the project now let us
learn about project management in Excel
Microsoft Excel is one of the most
common application these days it is used
in both offices and at homes Microsoft
Excel is an easy project management tool
that allows the team members to easily
see the tasks in a project develop a
plan and track its progress before we
learn more about project management in
Excel let's first have a look why do we
use Excel Microsoft Excel is an easy
tool to plan a project so it can be used
by people who are beginners in terms of
project management in Excel one can find
several analytical tools like
concatenate Len and counter so this
makes data analysis easy and effective
as the entry of data is easy same is
tracking and controlling our project
status then there are several project
management templates in Excel that help
us to have an effective distribution of
project data we will be checking several
project management templates towards the
end of this video now let's have a look
at the process of making a Gantt chart
in Excel before we begin this it's
important we know what is a Gantt chart
a Gantt chart is like a horizontal bar
chart that is used for project
management with the help of a Gantt
chart we can check the status of the
task the date they start the date they
end and their dependencies on each other
Gantt chart helps in coordinating and
monitoring different tasks in a project
now let's have a look at the steps that
will help us in making a Gantt chart
first step we have is make a project
table we have several rows in columns
like here we have three columns in the
First Column we have the tasks in a
second we have a start date and in the
third column we have the duration or
tenure of the task the second step is to
make a bar chart in Excel for this we
will select the entire second column
then we will go on the insert Tab and
click on the bar graph chart there we
can select stacked bar graph in 2D bar
charts as a result we will have the
entitled bar graph on the screen in the
third step we will add the duration to
the bar graph we will right click on the
chart and in the menu that appears we
will select select data option a window
that appears on the screen in that
window we will select add option as
shown we can also see the start date is
already in the entry section then in the
dialog box that appears type tenure in
the series name and click on the rain
selection icon that's shown in the
figure now select the relevant data from
the tenure column and click on ok now we
can see a bar graph that has two colors
on the screen this bar graph now has the
duration of the tasks the fourth step we
have is adding description to the Gantt
chart now we will open the box again and
in that box we will select the edit
option as shown in the figure then we
will select the tasks as we have
selected the duration of the tasks
before and click on OK we can now see
the tasks have appeared towards the left
side of the Gantt chart the fifth and
the remarkable step will help us convert
this bar graph into a Gantt chart we
will now click on the bars and select
the format data series option from the
menu that appears then in the format
data series dialog box we will select no
fill option we can find our Gantt chart
on the screen now in accordance with the
data that we had entered now we can see
the tasks on the left side are in the
reverse order so what we will do next is
we will click on the task panel then go
to the format access dialog box and
select the categories in reverse order
option now we can find a tasks in the
right order one more thing we can notice
is Gantt chart is starting with some
other date and not with the dates that
we had entered so for this we will copy
the first date in some other cell then
clicking on the copied cell we will go
to the home menu to select the dialog
box as shown in the figure then in that
drop down menu you will select the
number option we can now find a value
displayed in the copied cell we'll copy
that value click on the dates on the
chart and add the format access dialog
box opens you will paste that value in
the box that says minimum shown in the
figure as a result we will have our
final Gantt chart on the screen in the
last step we can give several designs to
a Gantt chart change colors and make it
more presentable for us now when we know
the basic steps of making a Gantt chart
I will show that practically to you in
Microsoft Excel our first step is to
open Microsoft Excel and in Microsoft
Excel we will make a project table in a
project table we will have three columns
the First Column will be task the second
column will have the start date the
third column will have tenure or the
duration of the task so beginning with
tasks we have task one in Task 1 we have
1.1 1.2 1.3 then comes task 2. in task 2
we have 2.1 2 0.2 2.3 and 2.4 then we
have task 3 in task 3 we will have two
subsections 3.1 and 3.2 then we will
start with the starting dates in
starting dates we will put 1st January
the Task 1 1.1 will be first of January
then this will be 4th January let's say
this is 5th January then we will put
this as 11th of January and this will be
again 11th January only this will be
15th January let's put this as 17th
January let this be 19th January task 3
begins on 23rd January
and it the 3.2 section begins at 26th of
January now let's put the tenure or the
duration of the task we will begin with
task one it takes 12 days then 1.1 takes
7 days we say this takes four days and
this takes 8 days then for task 2 it
again takes 12 days it takes 5 days 5
days and let's say this takes 6 days and
this takes four days then we come to
task three this takes eight days and
let's say this takes six days and the
3.2 section takes five days so this is
how a project table is ready in the
second step we will select the entire
second column after we have selected
this column we will go to the insert tab
in the insert tab we'll go to the bar
columns and in this we will select 2D
stacked bar charts now we have the
entitle bar chart in accordance to our
data on the screen then comes the third
step we will add the duration of the
tasks to the bar graph we will click on
the chart and after you click on the
chart we will select select data option
in the select data source dialog box we
find the start date is already there now
we will click on ADD and after we click
on add in the series name section we
will put tenure then in the series value
we will click on this icon and select
the entire tenure series and click on OK
so this is the bar graph that we have
now this is now in two colors the orange
color and the blue color this bar graph
now has the duration of all the tasks in
our project table now in the fourth step
now it's time for us to add description
to our Gantt chart instead of this one
two three four five we will put Task 1
task 2 and the sub tasks so what we will
do is we will again go to that box we
will left click on the Gantt chart
select the select data option and then
we'll go to the start date here we'll
select the edit option in the edit
option we will select all the tasks and
click on ok now we can see all the tasks
are aligned towards the left of the bar
chart as we can see this is a bar chart
or a bar graph and not a Gantt chart the
next step we have is converting this bar
graph into a Gantt chart so we will
click on the bars and select the format
data series option from the menu that
appears here we have this format data
series option now we can see the dialog
box on the screen here we'll go into the
color section fill section and then we
will select no fill now we can see the
blue lines have disappeared so this
looks like a Gantt chart so now when we
have a Gantt chart on the screen we can
notice that the task here are in the
reverse order so what we will do is we
will click on these tasks and select the
format access option here we will select
categories in reverse order we can see
our Gantt chart is now in order like we
have a task 1 on the top and task 3 at
the bottom the dates are starting from
11th of December but the dates we have
provided are from 1st of January now we
will copy this cell then go on the dates
box here we'll go to format access in
the format access we can see minimum in
this minimum we will paste this value
and press enter as we press enter we can
see our Gantt chart starting from the
date that we wanted to start and that
too in the correct order starting from
Task 1 to task 3. now as a result we
have our final Gantt chart on the screen
in the last step what we can do is make
our Gantt chart more representable we
can change the color of These Bars we
can give them shapes and we can do many
other things to make it more presentable
we will first select the bars like what
we will do is we will select Task 1 and
let's say we give it the color blue then
task 2 we will give it color green and
in task 3 we'll give it give it the
color black so here the sub sections
will give different colors to the
subsections as well then we come to task
2.1 this is how we can change the color
of these cells or apart from changing
colors we can select a bar graph and do
the gradient fill so this is how we can
make a Gantt chart more presentable
after changing the colors or changing
the shapes we have our final Gantt chart
on the screen finally let's have a look
at some Microsoft Excel templates for
project management Microsoft Excel
templates help in collecting data
putting them into order and check the
dependencies with each other with the
help of these templates we can monitor
the status of the tasks and we can also
check the progress our project has made
moving forth we will check some
important Microsoft Excel templates the
first template we have is Excel project
review template this template helps us
have an overview of the project we can
have a clear understanding of all the
tasks that are planned and that are
completed this helps project managers to
measure the progress of the project and
take further steps accordingly second
template we will check is Excel budget
template in this template it we can
monitor all the expenditures of our
project it helps us in managing the
budget of a project and also helps in
comparing the budget of a project at
different phases let's have a look at
the budget template in Excel ones we can
download this template from Office
timeline.com the Gans are towards the
right is in accordance with the dates
towards the left if we fluctuate the
date we can see the template working the
start date for Task 1 could be changed
to 10th June if we change this date to
10 June we can see the fluctuation in
the Gantt chart so this is how we can
use this template directly let's have a
look at the third template now third
template we will see is Excel Sprint
Project tracker template this template
is used majorly in agile projects where
the project is made in several Sprints
or sessions this template includes the
start date the end date and the duration
of each task we can also see the
percentage completed of each task let's
have a look at the Sprint Project
tracker template as well we can see the
Gantt chart towards the right and the
data towards the left so if we change
any data we can see the ants are
changing for example we can change the
data in Sprint to feature 3. let's
change the start date to July 2nd we can
see the Gantt chart changing this is how
we can use this template directly to
track our sessions let's have a look at
the fourth Excel template this template
is Excel project tracker in this
template we have the data of all the
tasks with the status and owners we can
track the percentage of tasks completed
and also compare the plan duration of
the task to the actual duration of the
task after the critical part tracker
let's check the Excel project schedule
template this template helps in
effective management of the project as
it helps in monitoring the time that
each task of the project takes it
provides a clear view of all the work
associated with the project let's have a
look at this template in Excel once we
can see the Gantt chart in accordance to
the data if you change the estimated
hours at two places let's say at the
design review we make it 15 hours
instead of 5 hours and at the create
Staffing plan and we make it two hours
instead of 20 hours we can see the Gantt
chart fluctuating this is how we can use
this template to manage the schedule in
a project moving forward the next
template we will see is Excel project
status report template this template
helps us having a list of project
deliverables and the risks associated
with that project this template helps
the project managers about different
crucial activities involved in a project
after this we have Excel Milestone
tracker the Milestone tracker helps us
in tracking or monitoring different
tasks in a project project managers use
this template to monitor the project
performance with respect to the
timelines the last template we will see
is Excel project planner Excel project
planner includes a list of tasks with
the respected owners along with the
start date and the end date of that task
this helps in monitoring each task and
comparing the estimated task rate with
the actual ones let's have a look at
this template in Excel we can see the
Gantt chart with respect to the data
entered let's make changes at several
places in the data we can make this 22
to 24 you will make this 23 go to 2 and
we can make this 5th September go to 15
September and when we make the changes
we can realize the Gantt chart is
fluctuating so this is how we can use
this template to plan a project
effectively and efficiently so first
let's understand what exactly is Mis
report in Excel
so Mis stands for management information
system Mis reports provide data on
different categories for accurate
decision making so Mis in Excel is a
procedure to create interactive report
using Microsoft Excel so Mis reports
help management to access the
performance of organization and allow
faster decision making so if you know to
create the Mis reports using various
business intelligence tools such as
Excel then you might find a very good
job opportunity in a well established
company now let us try to learn how to
create Mis report using Excel in a
practical mode so let's get back to the
Microsoft Excel IF getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so here you can see that I've got some
sales data of various car manufacturing
companies and I've also got some slices
so using these slices I can get the
real-time information from the dashboard
so I'll select an ear from the first
slicer and I'll go into the second
slicer and I'll select a company now
I'll select BMW and SUV tag so we have
the data of all the SUV types cars
manufactured by BMW car manufacturing
company in the year 2018. now let's
start and create something similar to
this one
so how did I create this mis report
let's go through this in a step-by-step
way
so on my screen you can see that we have
created a completely new Excel workbook
and we have some sample data with five
rows and 20 columns
so this particular data is based on the
manufacturer and the car manufacturing
company and the type of the car
manufactured and number of cars
manufactured in that particular year and
also the price of that particular car
Now to create Mis reports we need to
play around favor tables so we also have
tutorials on pivot tables and you can go
through that in our simply learn YouTube
channel and also we will try to link
those in the description box below
now let's select the entire data and go
into the insert ribbon and there you can
see the first option that is pivot table
so after selecting the pivot table
option it will show this particular
dialog box where It'll ask you for the
range of cells you need to select and
the next one is to
create the pivot table in the same sheet
or a new sheet so we'll take a new sheet
here now select OK and there you go you
have the pivot table here so first you
have an empty pivot table and on the
right side you can see we have pivot
table Fields now you can either drag
these options into the rows and columns
or you can also click it so now let's
drag and drop these first we will select
here
and card
followed by that we will take type
quantity and price to columns
so there you go we have our pivot table
now
let's select all the data in the pivot
table
and again let's get back to the insert
option
and here you can see an option called
pivot chart select that and you will
have various paper chart options here
now you can select any one which you can
prefer or which you like or whichever
you think can represent your data in a
best way possible so now let's go with
column chart first
let's select OK and we have our column
chart over here
now this happens to be our first chart
now let's create a few more charts so to
create few more charts we'll go back to
the same original data select again
insert and pivot table
now again a new worksheet
so here we have another empty pivot
table in the similar way let's drag the
same data into rows and columns
there you go and again we will select
all the data and create a pivot chart
go to insert option
favorite chat and now let's try to
select pie chart
select ok
and we have our pie chart over here
now let's try to create one more
same procedure select table select pivot
table then create new worksheet for the
new pivot table and now drag and drop
the data
now let's go to insert again
let's select all the data go to insert
option and pivot chat now let's try to
select the bar chart
select OK and there we have our bar
chart
now
remember the first chart we created that
is in sheet 2 this one so we will try to
move all the charts to this particular
table or this particular worksheet
so let's get back to the sheet number
three right click and you can see an
option called pivot chart analyze so
from here you can move the chart select
the option as moving the chart and don't
select the first one select the object
in option and select the sheet number to
which you want to move this chat for now
we want to move this chart to sheet
number two select that press ok now we
have the chart moved to the sheet number
two
and in the same way let's go to the
sheet number four and let's move this
particular chart to sheet number two
there you go the chart got moved to
sheet number two
now you can insert the slices
so we have selected the third sheet our
third chart and inside the pivot chart
analyze option we have an option of
inserting the slicer now we will insert
the slices for year
car
and
type
now select OK and you will have all the
three slices onto your sheet
now let's rearrange them
so I'm just organizing them in a
neat way
there you go
and you can also customize your designs
for all the charts
so that they look a little more better
now if you see
if I make some changes only one chart
will be interacting for this
right so if I select Ferrari and year
2020 and optional Sports you can see
only one chart is interacting to these
particular slices why because all these
slices are connected to just one chart
here so you need to make sure that all
the slices are connected to all the
three charts what we created so let's
erase all the filters and select one
slicer at a time right click and you
will see an option of report connections
select that and you see that the
connections are only connected to the
pivot table 3. so select the remaining
pivot tables as well select OK and in
the same way select the second slicer
select the report connection option
connect pivot table 1 and 2 and select
copy and in the same way the third one
so now all the slices are connected to
all the pivot charts now if you make
some changes here they will respond
automatically in the same way
now let's select the fourth company the
year 2019 and hashback option and you
have all the cars which were made in the
year 2019 from Ford Company in the
segment of hashback
so this was the sample data set that we
worked on now you can also work on some
complex data sets such as this Superstar
data set
now one thing you need to make sure that
when you're working with Excel Mis they
need to make sure that all the macros
are disabled on your data set and you
convert the entire data into the regular
table format of excel right now Excel is
considering this particular data as a
database so for that you need to select
all the data press Ctrl T and then
convert the entire data in the form of
tabular data and also don't forget to
click this icon which reads my table has
headers so the first row is the headers
now let's select OK and your entire data
will be converted into tabular form now
let's reset this to the normal
type which has the clear color not all
the fancy colors now the entire data is
converted from the dbms to the tablet
form and now he can start implementing
the Mis reports in pivot tables and so
why exactly do we need to do time series
analysis typically we would like to
predict something in the future and it
could be stock prices it could be the
sales or anything that needs to be
predicted into the future that is when
we use time series analysis so it is as
the name suggests it is forecasting and
typically when we say predict it need
not be into the future in machine
learning and data analysis when we talk
about predicting we are not necessarily
talking about the future but in Time
series analysis we typically predict the
future so we have some past data and we
want to predict the future that is when
we perform time series analysis so what
are some of the examples it could be the
daily stock price the shares as we talk
about or it could be the interest rates
weekly interest rates or sales figures
of a company so these are some of the
examples where we use time series data
we have historical data which is
dependent on time and then based on that
we create a model to predict the future
so what exactly is time series so time
series data has time as one of the
components as the name suggests so in
this example let's say this is the stock
price data and one of the components so
there are two columns here column B is
price and column A is basically the time
information in this case the time is a
day so that primarily the closing price
of a particular stock has been recorded
on a daily basis so this is the time
series data and the time interval is
obviously a date time series or time
intervals can be daily weekly hourly or
even sometimes if there is something
like a sensor data it could be every few
milliseconds or microseconds as well so
the size of the time intervals can vary
but they are fixed so if I am saying
that it is daily data then the interval
is fixed as daily if I'm saying this
data is an hourly data then it is the
data is captured every year and so on so
the time intervals are fixed the
interval itself you can decide based on
what kind of data we are capturing so
this is a graphical representation the
previous one here we saw the table
representation and this is how to plot
the data so on the y-axis is let's say
the price or the stock price and x axis
is the time so against time if you plot
it this is a Time series graph would
look so as the name suggests what is
time series data time series data is
basically a sequence of data that is
recorded over a specific intervals of
time and based on the past values so if
we want to do an analysis of Time series
as data we try to forecast a future and
again as the name suggests is time
series data which means that it is time
dependent so time is one of the
components of this data time series data
consists of primarily four components
one is the trend then we have this
seasonality then cyclicity and then last
but not least irregularity or the random
component sometimes is also referred to
as a random component so let's see what
each of these components are so what is
strength trend is overall change or the
pattern of the data which means that the
data may be let me just uh pull up the
pen and show you so let's say you have a
data set somewhat like this a Time
series data set somewhat like this all
right
so what is the overall trend there is an
overall trend which is upward Trend as
we call it here right so it is not like
it is continuously increasing there are
times when it is dipping then there are
times when it is increasing then it is
decreasing and so on but overall over a
period of time from the time we start
recording to the time we end there is a
trend right there is an upward Trend in
this case so the trend need not always
be upwards there could be a downward
Trend as well so for example here there
is a downward right so this is basically
what is a trend overall whether the data
is increasing or decreasing all right
then we have the next component which is
seasonality what is seasonality
seasonality as the name suggests once
again changes over a period of time and
periodic changes right so there is a
certain pattern
um let's take the sales of for warm
clothes for example so if we plot it
along the months so let's say January
February March April May June July and
then let's say it goes up to December
okay so this is our December D I will
just mark it as D and then you again
have Jan Feb March and then you get
another December okay and just for
Simplicity let's mark this as December's
as the end of the year and then one more
December okay so what will happen when
if you're talking about warm clothes
what happens the sales of warm clothes
will increase probably around December
when it is cold and then they will come
down and then again around December
again they will increase and then the
sales will come down and then there will
be again an increase and then they will
come down and then again an increase and
then they will come now let's say this
is the sales pattern so you see here
there is a trend as well there is an
upward Trend right the sales are
increasing over let's say these are
multiple years this is for year one this
is for year two this is for year three
and so on so for multiple years overall
the trend there is an upward Trend the
sales are increasing but it is not a
continuous increase right so there is a
certain pattern so what is happening
what is the pattern every December the
sales are increasing or they are peaking
for that particular year right then
there is a new year again when December
approaches the sales are increasing
again when December approaches the sales
are increasing and so on and so forth so
this is known as seasonality so there is
a certain fluctuation which is uh which
is periodic in nature so this is known
as seasonality then cyclicity what is
cyclicity now cyclicity is somewhat
similar to seasonality but here the
duration between two cycles is much
longer so seasonality typically is
referred to as an annual kind of a c 6
like for example we saw here so it is
pretty much like every year in the month
of December the sales are increasing
however cyclicity what happens is first
of all the duration is pretty much not
fixed and the duration or the Gap length
of time between two cycles can be much
longer so the recession is an example so
we had let's say recession in 2001 or
2002 perhaps and then we had one in 2008
and then we had probably in 2000 2012
and so on and so forth so it is not like
every year this happens probably so
there is a usually when we say recession
there is a slum and then it recovers and
then there is a slump and then it
recovers and probably there is another
bigger slum and so on right so you see
here this is similar to seasonality but
first of all this length is much more
than a year right that is number one and
it is not fixed as well it is not like
every four years or every six years that
duration is not fixed so the duration
can vary at the same time the gap
between two cycles is much longer
compared to seasonality all right so
then what is irregularity irregularity
is like the random component of the time
series data so there is like you have
part which is the trend which tells
whether the overall it is increasing or
decreasing then you have cyclicity and
seasonality which is like kind of a
specific pattern right uh then there is
a cyclicity which is again a pattern but
at much longer intervals plus there is a
random component so which is not really
which cannot be accounted for very
easily right so there will be a random
component which can be really random as
the name suggests right so that is the
irregularity component so these are the
various components of Time series data
yes there are conditions where we cannot
use time series analysis right so is it
can we do time series analysis with any
kind of data no not really so what are
the situations is where we are we cannot
do time series analysis so there will be
some data which is collected over a
period of time but it's really not
changing so it will not really not make
sense to perform any time series
analysis over it right for example like
this one so if we take X as the time and
Y as the value of whatever the output we
are talking about and if the Y value is
constant there is really no analysis
that you can do leave alone time series
analysis right so that is one another
possibility is yes there is a change but
it is changing as per a very fixed
function like a sine wave or a COS wave
again time series analysis will not make
sense in this kind of a situation
because there is a definite pattern here
there is a definite function that the
data is following so it will not make
sense to do a Time series analysis now
before performing any time series
analysis uh the data has to be
stationary and typically time series
data is not stationary so in which case
you need to make the data stationary
before we apply any models like arima
model or any of these right so what
exactly is stationary data and what is
meant by stationary data let us take a
look first of all what is non-stationary
data time series data if you recall from
one of my earlier slides we said that
type series data has the following four
components the the tram seasonality
cyclicity and random random component or
irregularity right so if these
components are present in Time series
data it is non-stationary which means
that typically these components will be
present therefore most of the time A
Time series data that is collected raw
data is non-stationary data so it has to
be changed to stationary Data before we
apply any of these algorithms all right
so a non-stationary Time series data
would look like this which means like
for example here there is an upward
Trend the seasonality component is there
and also the random component and so on
so if the data is not stationary then
the time series forecasting will be
affected so you cannot really perform a
Time series forecasting on a
non-stationary data so how do we
differentiate between a stationary and a
non-stationary Time series data
typically or technically one is of
course you can do it visually in
non-stationary data the the data will be
more flatish the seasonality will of
course be there but the trend will not
be there so the data May if we plot that
it may appear somewhat like this right
it's a horizontal line along the
horizontal line you will see compared to
the original data which was there was an
upward Trend so it was changing somewhat
like this right so this is not
stationary data and this is our
stationary data would look visually what
does this mean technically this means
that stationarity of the data depends on
a few things but the mean the variance
and the covariance so these are the
three components on which the
stationarity of the data depends so
let's take a look at what each of these
are for stationary data the means should
not be a function of time which means
that the means pretty much remain
constant over a period of time right so
there is there shouldn't be any change
so this is how the stationary data and
this is a non-stationary data Outlook
I've shown in the previous slide as well
so here the mean is increasing that
means there is an upward Trend okay so
that is one part of it and then the
variance of the series should not be
also a function of time so the variance
also should be pretty much common or
should be constant rather so this is a
if we visually we take a look this is
our time series stationary's data look
where the variance is not changing here
the variance is changing therefore this
is non-stationary and we cannot apply
type series for casting on this kind of
data similarly the covariance which is
basically of the ith term and the I plus
MTH term should not be a function of
time as well so covariance is nothing
but not only the variance at the ith
term but the relation between the
variance at the ith term and the I plus
M meth or the I plus NF term so as again
once again visually this is how it would
look if the covariance is also changing
with respect to time so these are the
three all three components should be
pretty much constant and that is when
you have stationary data and in order to
perform time series analysis the data
should be stationary okay so let's take
a look at the concept of moving average
or the method of moving average and
let's see how it works we'll do simple
calculations so let's say this is our
sample data we have the data for three
months a January February March the
sales in hundreds of in thousands rather
not hundreds thousands of dollars is
given here and now we want to find the
moving average so how do we find the
moving average we call it as moving
average three so moving average three is
nothing but you take three of the values
or the readings add them up and divide
by three basically the way we take a
mean or average of the three values so
that is as simple as that so that's the
average first of all so what is moving
average moving averages if you now have
a series of data you keep taking the
three values the next three values and
then you take the average of that and
then the next three values and so on and
so forth so that is how you take the
moving average so let's take a little
more detailed example of car sales so
this is how we have the car sales data
for the entire year let's say so rather
for four years so year one we have for
each quarter what a one two three four
and then year two quarter one two three
four and so on and so forth so this is
how we have sales data of a particular
car let's say or a showroom and we want
to forecast for year five so we have the
data for four years we now want to focus
for the fifth year let's see how it
works first of all if we plot the data
as it is taking the raw data this is how
it would look and uh what do you think
it is is it stationary no right because
there is a trend upward Trend so this is
not a stationary data so we
um we need to later we will see how to
make it stationary but to start with
just an example we will not worry about
it for now we will just go ahead and
manually do the forecasting using what
is known as moving average method okay
so we are not applying any algorithm or
anything like that in the next video we
will see how to apply an algorithm how
to make it stationary and so on all
right so
um here we see that all the three or
four components that we talked about
um are there there is a trend there is a
c seasonality and then of course there
is some random component as well
cyclicity may not be it is possible that
cyclicity is not applicable in all the
situations for sale especially there may
not be or unless you're taking a sales
for maybe 20 30 years cyclicity may not
come into play so we will just consider
uh primarily the trend seasonality and
irregularity right so Random it is also
known as random irregularity right so we
were calling the random or irregularity
components so these are the three main
components typically in this case we
will talk about so this is the trend
component and we will see how to do
these calculations so let's take a look
re-draw the table including the time
code we will add another column which is
the time code and uh this is the column
and we just number it like one two three
four up to 16. the rest of the data
Remains the Same okay so we will do the
calculations now now let us do the
moving average calculations
um or ma4 as we call it for each year so
we take all the four quarters and we
take an average of that so if we add up
these four values and divide by 4 you
get the moving average of 3.4 so we
start by putting the value here so that
will be for the third quarter let's say
one two three the third quarter then we
will go on to the next one so we take
the next four values as you see here and
take the average of that which is the
moving average for the next quarter and
so on and so forth now if we just do the
moving average uh it is not centered so
what we do is we basically add one more
column and we calculate the centered
moving average as shown here so here
what we do is we take the average of two
values and then just adding these values
here so for example the first value for
the third quarter is actually the
average of the third and the fourth
quarter so we have 3.5 now it gets
centered so similarly the next value
would be 3.6 plus 3.9 divided by 2 so
which is 3.7 and so on and so forth okay
so that is the centered moving average
this is done primarily to smoothen the
data so that there are not too many
rough edges so that is what we do here
so if we visualize this data now this is
how it looks right so if we take the
centered moving average as you can see
there is a gradual increase if this was
not the case if we had not centered it
the changes would have been much sharper
so that is the basically the smoothening
that we are talking about now let's go
and or do the forecast for the fifth
year so in order to do the forecast what
we will do is we will take the centered
moving average as our Baseline and then
start doing a few more calculations that
are required right in order to come up
with the prediction so what we are going
to do is we are going to use this
multiplicity or multiplicative model in
this case and this is how it it looks so
we take the product of seasonality and
the trend and the irregularity
components and we just multiply that and
in order to get that this product of
these two We have basically the actual
value divided by CMA YT value divided by
CMA will give you the predicted value of
y t is equal to the product of all three
components therefore s t into y t is
equal to y t by CMA so this is like this
is equal to y t right so therefore if we
want s t into y t the product of
seasonality and irregularity it is equal
to y t by CMA so that is how we will
work it out I also have an Excel sheet
of the actual data so let me just pull
that up all right so this is how the
data looks in Excel as you can see here
year one quarter one two three four here
two quarter one two three four and so on
and this is the sales data and then this
is the moving average as I mentioned
this is how we calculate and this is the
centered moving average so this is the
primary component that we will start
working with and then we will calculate
since we want the product of s c into i
t that is equal to YT by CMA so if you
see this values are nothing but the YT
value divided by CMA so in this case it
is 4 by 3.5 which is 1.14 similarly 4.5
by 3.7 1.22 and so on and so forth so we
take we have the product St into it and
then the next step is to calculate the
average of respective quarters so that
is what we are doing here average of
respective quarters and then we need to
calculate the D seasonalized values so
in order to get decisionalized value we
need to divide y t by St that was
calculated so for example here it is 2.8
by 0.9 so we got the decisionalized
value here and then we get the trend and
then we get the predicted values so in
order to get the predicted value which
is basically we predict the values for
known values as well like for example
here one quarter one we know the value
but now that we have our model we
predict ourselves and see how close it
is so we predicted as 2.89 whereas the
actual value is 2.8 then we have 2.59
the actual value is 2.1 and so on just
to see how our model works and then
continue that into the fifth year
because for fifth year we don't have a
reference value okay and if we plot this
we will come to know how well our
calculations are how well our manual
model in this case we did not really use
a model but we did on our own manually
so it will tell us the trend so for
example the predicted value is this gray
color here and you can see that it is
actually pretty much following the
actual value which is the blue color
right and the gray color is the
predicted value so the ACT wherever we
know the values up to year four we can
see that our predicted values are
following or pretty much very close to
the actual values and then from here
onwards when the year 5 starts the blue
color line is not there because we don't
have the actual values only the
predicted value so we can see that since
it was following the trend pretty much
for the last four years we can safely
assume that it has understood the
pattern and it is predicting correctly
for the next one year the next four
quarters right so that is what we are
doing here so these four quarters we did
not have actual data but we have the
predicted values so let's go back and
see how this is working in this using
the slides so this is we already saw
this part and I think it was easier to
see in the Excel sheet so we calculated
the St it product of St and it using the
formula like here y by YT by CMA you got
that and then we got ST which is
basically y t so this is the average of
the first quarters for all the four
years and similarly this is the average
of the second quarter for all the four
years and so on so these values are
repeating these are they are calculated
only once they get repeated that's see
here and then we get the decisionalized
data and that is basically YT by St so
we calculated St here and we have YT so
y t by s t will give you the DCS analyze
data and we have got rid of the seasonal
and The Irregular components so far now
what we are left with is the trend and
before we start the time series
forecasting time series analysis as I
mentioned earlier we need to completely
get rid of the non-stationary components
so we are still left with the trend
component so now let us also remove the
trend component in order to do that we
have to find the or we have to calculate
the intercept and slope of the data
because that is required to calculate
the trend and how are we going to do
that that we will actually use what is
known as regression tool or Analytics
tool that is available in Excel so you
remember we have our data in Excel so
let me take you to the Excel and here we
need to calculate the intercept and the
slope in order to do that we have to use
the regression mechanism and in order to
use the regression mechanism we have to
use the Analytics tool that comes with
Excel so how do you activate this tool
so this is how you would need to
activate the tool from Excel you need to
go to options and in options there will
be add-ins and in add-ins you will have
analysis tool back and you select this
and you just say go it will open up a
box like this you say analysis tool pack
and
okay and now when you come back in to
the regular view of excel in the data
tab you will see data analysis activated
so you need to go to file options and
add-ins and then analysis tool pack
typically since I've already added it it
is coming at the top but it would come
under inactive application add-ins so
when you're doing it for the first time
so don't use VBA you just say analysis
tool pack there are two options one with
VBA like this one and one without vda so
just use the one without VBA and then
instead of just saying okay just take
care that you click on this go and not
just okay so you say go then it will
give you these options only then you
select just the analysis tool pack and
then you say okay all right so and then
when you come back to the main view you
click on data okay so this is your
normal home view perhaps so you need to
come to data and here is where you will
see data analysis available to you and
then if you click on that there are a
bunch of possibilities what kind of data
analysis you want to do if there are
options are given right now we just want
to do regression because we want to find
slope and The Intercept so select
regression and you say okay
and you will get these options for input
y range and input X range input y range
is the value YT so you just select this
and you can select up to here and press
enter and input X range you can for now
you start with the baseline or you can
also start with the D season value so
you can just click on these and say okay
I have already calculated it so these
are the intercept and the coefficients
that we are getting for these values and
we will actually use that to calculate
our Trend here right so this is which is
in the J column so our trend is equal to
intercept plus slope into the time code
so The Intercept is out here as we can
see in our slide as well so if you see
here this is our intercept and the lower
value is the slope so we have calculated
here and it's shown in the slides as
well so intercepts the formula is shown
here so our trend is equal to intercept
plus slope into time code time code is
nothing but this one t column a one two
three four okay so that's how you
calculate the trend and that's how you
use the data analysis tool from Excel
using these two we calculate the
predicted values and using this formula
which is basically trend is equal to
intercept plus slope into time code and
then we can go and plot it see how it is
looking and therefore so we see here
that the predicted values are pretty
close to the actual values and therefore
we can safely assume that our
calculations which are like our manual
model is working and hence if we go
ahead and predict for the fifth year so
till four years we know the actual value
as well so we can compare our model is
performing and for the fifth year we
don't have reference values so we can
use our equations to calculate the
values or predict the values for the
fifth year and we can go ahead and
safely calculate those values and when
we plot for the fifth year as well the
predicted values we see that they are
pretty much they capture the pattern and
we can say if you assume that the
predictions are fairly accurate as we
can also see from the graph in the Excel
sheet that we have already seen okay so
let's go and plot it so this is how the
plot looks this is the CMA or the
centered moving average the green color
and then the blue color is the actual
data red color is the predicted value
predicted by our handcrafted model okay
so remember we did not use any regular
forecasting model or any tool we have
done this manually and the actual tool
will be used in the next video this is
just to give you an idea about how
behind the scenes are under the hood how
forecasting Works a Time series analysis
how it is performed okay so it looks
like it has captured the trend properly
so up to here is the known difference we
have reference and from here onwards is
purely predicted and as I mentioned
earlier we can safely assume that the
values are accurate and predicted
properly for the fifth year so let's go
ahead and implement moment a Time series
forecast in r first of all we will be
using the arima model to do the forecast
of this time series data so let us try
to understand what is arima model so
arima is actually an acronym it stands
for auto regressive integrated moving
average so that is what is arima model
and it is specified by three parameters
which is p d and q p stands for auto
regressive so let me just mark this so
there are three components here Auto
regressive integrated moving average
okay so these three parameters
correspond to those three components so
the P stats for auto regressive D for
integrated and Q for moving average so
let us see what exactly this is so these
three factors are p is the number of
autoregressive terms or ar we will see
that in our as well and D is how many
levels of differences that we need to do
or differentiation we need to do and Q
is the number of lagged forecast error
so we'll see what exactly each of these
are so AR is the number of Auto
regressive terms and which is basically
denoted by the p and then we have D
which is for the number of times it has
to be differentiated and then we have q
which is for the moving average so what
exactly AR terms so in terms of the
regression model autoregressive
components refer to the prior values of
the current value what we mean by that
is here when we talk about time series
data focus on the fact that there is
regression so what exactly happens in
regression we try to do something like
if it is simple linear regression we do
have some equation like Y is equal to MX
plus C where there are actually there
are two variables one is the dependent
variable and then there is an
independent variable let me just
complete this equation as well MX plus C
right so this is a normal regression
curve or a simple regression curve now
here we are talking about Auto
regression or or Auto regressive so Auto
regressive as the name suggests is
regression of itself so which means that
here you have only one variable which is
your maybe the cost of the flights or
whatever it is right and the other
variable is basically time dependent and
therefore the value at any given time
and that we will denote as Y T for
example so there is no X here there is
only one variable and which is y and we
say y t which is basically the predicted
value at a time interval T for example
is dependent on the previous value so
for example there may be A1 and then y t
minus 1 and then there will be a like
plus A2 and right plus A2 and Y T minus
2 and all right and then plus A3 into y
t minus 3 all right so basically here
what we are saying is there's only one
variable here but there is a regression
component so we are doing a regression
on itself so that's how the term Auto
regression comes into plane so only
thing is that it is dependent on the
previous time values so there is a lag
let's say this is the first lag second
leg third lag and so on so the current
value which is y t is dependent on the
previous time lag values so that is what
is auto regression component so this is
what is shown here for example in this
case instead of Y we are calling it as X
so that's the same and this is
represented by some equation of that
sort depending on how many lags we take
so that is the AR component and the term
p is basically determines how many lags
we are considering so that's the B4 now
what is d d is the degree of
differencing so here differencing is
like to for the non-seasonal differences
right so for example if you take the
values like this which are given for
five four six and so on and so forth if
you take the differencing of one after
another like for example 5 minus 4 or 4
minus 5 the next value with the previous
value so 4 minus five so this is known
as the first order differencing so the
result is minus one similarly 6 minus 4
is 2 7 minus 6 is 1. so this is first
order differencing and here we call it
as D is equal to one okay and same way
we can have second order third order and
so on then the last one is q q is the
actually right we call it moving average
but in reality it is actually the error
of the model so we also sometimes
represent as e t all right so now arima
model works on the assumption that the
data is stationary which means that the
trend and seasonality of the data has
been removed that is correct okay so
this we have discussed in the first part
how what exactly is stationary data and
how do we remove the non-stationary part
of it now in order to test whether the
data is stationary or not there are two
important components that are considered
one is the autocorrelation function and
the other is the partial order
correlation function so this is referred
to as ACF and pacf all right so what is
sort of correlation and what is the
definition or correlation is basically
the similarity between values of a same
variable across observations as the name
suggests now how do we actually find the
article relation function the value
right so this is basically done by
plotting and autocorrelation function
also tells you how correlated points are
with each other based on how many time
steps they are separated by and so on
that is basically the time lag that we
were talking about and it is also used
to determine how fast and future data
points are related and the value of the
autocorrelation function can vary from
-1 to 1. so if we plot this is how it
would look autocorrelation function
would look somewhat like this and there
is actually a readily available function
in R so we will see that and you can use
that to plot your nautical relation
function okay so that is ACF and we will
see that in our R studio in a little bit
and similarly you have partial order
correlation function so partial order
correlation function is the degree of
association between two variables while
adjusting the effect of one or more
additional variables so this again can
be measured and it can also be plotted
at its value once again can go from -1
to 1 and it gives the partial
correlation of Time series with its own
lagged values values so lag again we
have discussed in the previous couple of
slides this is a psef plot would look in
our studio we will see that as well and
once we get into the r studio and with
that let's get into our studio and take
a look at our use case before we go into
the code let's just quickly understand
what exactly is the objective of this
use case so we are going to predict some
values of four plus some values and we
have the data of the airline ticket
sales of the previous years and now we
will try to find the or predict or
forecast the values for the future years
all right so we will basically identify
the time series components like Trend
seasonality and random Behavior we will
actually visualize this in our studio
and then we will actually forecast the
values based on the password sorry
history data historical data so these
are the steps that we follow we will see
in our studio in a little bit just
quickly let's go through what are the
steps reload the data and it is the time
series data and we try to find out what
class it belongs to the data is actually
air passengers data that is already
comes pre-loaded with rstudio so we will
be using that and we can take a look at
the data and then what is the starting
point what is the end point so these are
all functions that are not really
available we'll be using and then what
is the frequency which basically
frequency is 12 which is like yearly
data right so every month data has been
collected so for each year it is 12 and
then we can check for many missing
values if there are any and then we can
take a look at summary of the data this
is what we do in exploratory data
analysis and then we can plot the data
visualize the data how it is looking and
we will see how the data has some Trends
seasonality and so on and so forth all
right then we can take a look at the
cycle of the data using the cycle
function and we can see that it is every
month that's the cycle end of every 12
months the new cycle begins so each
month of the year is uh the data is
available then we can do box plots to
see for each month how the data is
varying over the various 10 or 12 years
that we will be looking at this data and
from exploratory data analysis we can
identify that there is a trend there is
a seasonality component and how the
seasonality component varies also we can
see from the box plots and we can
decompose the data we can use the
decompose function rather to see the
various components like the seasonality
trend and the irregularity part okay so
we will see all of this in our studio
this is how they will look this is the
Once you decompose and this is how you
will actually you can visualize the data
this is the actual data and this is the
trend as you can see it's going upwards
this is the seasonal component and this
is your random or irregularity right so
we call it irregularity or we can also
call it random as you can see here yes
so the data have a constant variance and
mean which means that it is stationary
before we start any analysis time series
analysis and without so basically yeah
if it is stationary only then it is easy
to model the data perform time series
analysis so we can then go ahead and fit
the model as we discussed earlier we'll
be using arima model there are some
techniques to find out what should be
the parameter so we will see that when
we go into our studio so the auto arima
function basically tells us what should
be the parameters right so these
parameters are the p d and q that we
talked about that's what is being shown
here so if we use Auto arima it will
basically take all possible values of
this PDQ these parameters and it will
find out what is the best value and then
it will recommend so that is the
advantage of using Auto arima all right
so like in this case it will tell us
what if we use this parameter Trace we
set the parameter Trace is equal to true
then it will basically tell us what is
the value of this AIC which has to be
minimum so the lower the value the
better so for each of these combinations
of p d and q it will give us the value
values here and then it will recommend
to us which is the best model okay
because each other has the lowest value
of this AIC it will recommend that as
your best PDQ values so once we have
that we can see that we will basically
we can potentially get a model or the
equation model is nothing with the
equation and based on the parameters
that we get and we can do some
Diagnostics we can do some plotting to
see how whether there is a plot for the
residuals so which shows the
stationarity and then we can also take a
look at the ACF and pacf we can plot the
ACF and pacf and then we can do some
forecasting for the future here so in
this case we have up to 1960 and then we
can see how we can forecast for the next
10 years which is 1970 up to 1970 and
once we have done this can we validate
this model yes definitely we can
validate this model and uh to validate
the findings we use uh jump box test and
this is how you just call box.test and
then you pass these parameters and you
will get the values that will be
returned which will tell us whether this
how accurate this model is how accurate
the production s are so the values of P
are quite insignificant in this case we
will see that and that also indicates
that our model is free of
autocorrelation and that will basically
be it so let's go back and into our our
studio and go through these steps in
real time so we have to import this
Library forecast package is not
installed you have to go here and
install the forecast package okay so
that's the easy way to install rather
than so click on this install I will not
do it now because I have already
installed so the first step that's only
one time then after that you just have
to load it into memory and then keep
going so we will load this data called
air passengers so by calling this data
method and if you see the the data
passengers is loaded here and if we
check for the class it is a Time series
data TS data so we can check for the
dates you can also view the data in a
little bit and the start date is 1949
and January
and our end date is 1960 December and
the frequency is 12 which is like
collected monthly so that is the
frequency which is uh 12 here and then
we check if there are any missing values
there are no missing values and then we
take a look at the summary of the data
this is all exploratory data analysis
and then if you just display the data
this is how it looks
and then we need to decompose this data
so we will kind of store this in an
object yes data and then use that to
decompose and store the new values let
me just clear this for now and if we
decompose basically as we have seen in
the slides decomposing is breaking it
into the transitionality and irregular
or random components then you can go
ahead and plot it so when you plot it
you can see here let me Zoom this this
is our original plot or observed value
as it is known as then we have
decomposed the three parts which is
basically the trend as you can see there
is a upward Trend then the seasonal
component so this is some regularly
occurring pattern and then there is a
random value which is basically you
cannot really give any equation or
function or anything like that so that's
what this plotting has done and then you
can actually plot them individually as
well so these are the individual plots
for the trend for the seasonal component
and the random component all right so
now let's take a look at the original
data and see how the trend is in a way
so if we do this linear regression line
it will show that it is going upwards
and we can also take a look at the cycle
that are there which is nothing but we
have a frequency of 12 right so the
Cycles will display that it is January
February to December and then back to
January February and so on and so forth
and if we do box plots for the monthly
data you will see that for each of the
months right and over the 10 years that
the data that we have we will see that
there is a certain pattern right this is
also in a way to find the seasonality
component so while January February
sales are relatively low around July
August the sales pick up so especially
in July I think the sales are the
highest and this seems to be happening
pretty much every year right so this is
every year in July AI there seems to be
a peak in the sales and then it goes
down and slightly higher in December and
so on so that is Again part of our
exploratory data analysis and once again
let's just plot the data now as I said
in order to fit into an arima model we
need the values of PD and Q now one way
of doing it is there are multiple ways
actually of doing it the earlier method
of doing it was you draw the
autocorrelation function plot and then
partial order correlation function plot
and then observe that and where does
this change and then identify what
should be the values of PE and Q and so
on now R really has a very beautiful
method which we can use to avoid all
that manual process that we used to do
earlier so what R will do is there is a
method called Auto arima and if we just
call this Auto arima method and it will
basically go and test the arima model
for all possible values of this
parameters PDQ and then it will suggest
to you what should be the best model and
it will return that best model with the
right values of PD and Q so u v as data
scientists don't have to do any manual
you know trial and error kind of stuff
okay so we got the model now and this is
the model it has PDQ values are two one
one PDQ and this is the seasonal part of
it so we can ignore it for now and so if
we want to actually understand how this
has returned these values to one one as
the best one there is another
functionality or feature where we can
use this Trace function or Trace
parameter so if you pass to Auto arima
the trace parameter what it will do is
it will show you how it is doing this
calculation what is the value of the AIC
basically AIC this is what you know
defines the accuracy of the model the
lower the pattern okay so for each
combination of PDQ it will show us the
value of AIC so let's run it before
instead of me talking so much let's run
this if we run Auto arima with Trace you
see here there is a red mark here that
means it is performing it's executing
this and here we see the display right
so it starts with certain values of PDQ
and then it finds that value is too high
so it starts with a gain with some 0 1 1
0 and so on and so forth and ultimately
it tells us okay this is our best model
you see here it says this is our best
model two one one let's go back and see
did we get the same one yes we got the
same one when we ran without Trace as
well right now Y is 2 1 1 let us see
where is two one one here is our two one
one and if you compare the values you
see that 1 0 1 7 is pretty much the
lowest value and therefore it is saying
this is our best model all other values
are higher so that's how you kind of get
your model and now that you have your
model what you have to do you need to
predict the values right so before that
let us just do some test of these values
so for that you install T-Series again
if you are doing it for the first time
you would rather use this package and
install and say T-Series and install it
and then you just use this Library
function to load it into your memory all
right so now that we got our model using
Auto arima let us go ahead and forecast
and also test the model and also plot
the ACF and psef remember we talked
about this but we did not really use it
we don't have to use that but at least
we will visualize it and for some of the
stuff we may need this T-Series Library
so if you are doing this for the first
time you may have to install it and my
recommendation is don't use it in the
code you go here and install T-Series
and I will not do it now again because I
have already installed it but this is a
preferred method and once you install it
you just load it using this library's
function and then you can plot your
residuals and this is how the residuals
look and you can plot your ACF and psef
okay so this is how your tacf looks and
this is how your ACF looks for now there
is really nothing else we need to do
with ACF and pacf is just to visualize
how that how it looks but as I mentioned
earlier we were actually using these
visualizations or these graphs to
identify the values of p d and q and how
that was done it's uh out of scope of
this video so we will leave it at that
and then we will forecast for the next
10 years how do we focus that so we call
forecast and we pass the model and we
pass what is the level of accuracy that
you need which which is 95 percent and
for how many period right so basically
we want for 10 years which is like 10
into 12 time periods so that's what we
are doing here and now we can plot the
forecast value so you see this is the
original value up to I think 62 or
whatever and then it goes up to 72. this
blue color is the predicted value let's
go and zoom it up so that we can see it
better so from here onwards we are
forecasting and you can see that it
looks like our model has kind of learned
the pattern and this pattern looks very
similar to what we see in the actual
data now how do we test our model so we
can do what is known as the Box test and
we pass our model here residuals
basically with different lags and from
those values here the P values here we
find that they are reasonably in low P
values which means our model is fairly
accurate we'll be creating two
dashboards using a sample sales data set
so if you want to get the data and the
dashboard file that we'll be creating in
this demo then please put your email IDs
in the comment section of the video a
team will share the files via email
now let's begin by understanding what is
a dashboard in Excel
a dashboard is a visual interface that
provides an overview of key measures
relevant to a particular objective with
the help of charts and graphs
dashboard reports allow managers to get
a high level overview of the business
and help them make quick decisions
there are different types of dashboards
such as strategic dashboards analytical
dashboards and operational dashboards an
advantage of dashboards is the quick
detection of outliers and correlations
with Comprehensive data visualization it
is time saving as compared to running
multiple reports
with this understanding let's jump into
our demo for creating our dashboards
we'll be using a sample sales data set
let me show you the data set first
so here is the sales data set that we'll
be using for our demo so this data set
was actually generated using a simulator
and is completely random it was not
validated though we have applied certain
transformations to the data using power
query features
so this data as you can see has
1000 rows so using the simulator we had
generated thousand rows of data
oh
similarly if I go on top you can see
this data set has 17 columns
now let me give you a brief about each
of the columns so first we have the
region column so we have Middle East and
North Africa there's North America Asia
sub-Saharan Africa and others
similarly we have the country names from
which the item was ordered
the third column is the item type so we
have different items Cosmetics
vegetables there's baby food cereal
fruits
Etc
then we have the representative's name
or you can see this as the customer name
who ordered the product
then we have a sales Channel column so
there are basically two channels whether
the item was sold offline or online
next we have the order priority column
now here C stands for critical
then we have H which is for high
priority orders then we have M for
medium priority orders and finally we
have L which is for low priority orders
you can see the order date column then
we have the order ID the ship date next
we have
units sold
which is basically the total number of
units sold for each item
then we have the unit price column this
is the price at which each product was
sold
then we have the unit cost column which
is basically the production cost for
each of the items
next we have the total revenue the total
revenue is actually the product of unit
sold and unit price
then we have the total cost column now
the total cost column is actually the
product of units sold and the unit cost
similarly we have the total profit
column so total profit is the difference
between total revenue and the total cost
and finally we have created two more
columns that is order year and then we
have order month now these two columns
were actually generated using the power
query features so we use the order date
column which is this column and
extracted order year and Order month
so first we are going to create a
revenue dashboard where we'll focus on
generating reports for Revenue by order
year Revenue by year and region Revenue
by order priority and much more we'll
create separate po tables and po charts
and format them to make them look more
interesting and presentable
we'll add slices and timeline to our
dashboards in order to filter it based
on specific fields
now let's create our first report to see
the total revenue generated each year
so we need to create a pivot table for
this
I'll click on a cell in my data set and
then I'll go to the insert tab here we
have the option to select the pivot
table
I click on this
you can see
my table range is selected
next I want to place my pivot table in a
new worksheet
and let's just click on OK
there you go so we have a new sheet
where I can place my pivot table
so first I need to find the total
revenue generated by each year so what
I'll do is
I'll drag my order here column
under rows
and then
I'll select the total revenue column
under values
you can see I have my Pivot chart ready
now if you want you can sort this
so from the data you can see we have
order Year from 2010 to 2017
now based on this data let's create our
pivot chart so I'll click on any cell
go to insert and here you have the
option to select recommended charts I
click on this
now actually I want a line chart so I'll
click on
line here and select ok
there you go so we have successfully
created our first pivot chart
now
let me show you how you can format this
chart to make it more readable
so first let me delete
these so I'll right click and select
hide all field buttons on the chart so
this will delete the buttons present on
the chart now let me go ahead and edit
the chart title
so the title I want is total revenue
I'll type it down
by year
all right
next
let's do a few more transformations
so if I click on this plus sign
which is actually for chart elements we
have some options like to add access
access titles chart title data labels
this grid lines Legend and others
Okay so
let's remove the legend now
you can see the total Legend is gone
now let me
add access titles so we label our x-axis
and y axis so here under x axis
I can
write it as
year
similarly on the y-axis I'll put Revenue
okay now you can move a bit
all right now
let me select this chart Style option
and go to Colors first
here I'll select yellow color okay
and then let me go back to style
let's select a new style from this list
I want
this die
okay
now you can also add
data labels so I'll just click on data
labels
you can see we have
the revenue for each of the years now
this is not readable at all so we'll
format this a bit
if I click on this Arrow here I have
more options
if I scroll down you can see we have
something called as number here
I'll expand this
and under category I'll select custom
now here
will give a format code
which is a bit different
so this is actually a kind of a formula
so I'll write if my Revenue value
is greater than
let's say
9 lakhs
000.
let me make sure there are six nines
here so one two three four five and six
okay we are good to go
I'll close the bracket
I'll give a hash
give to commas
so if the revenue is greater than 9
lakhs 99
000 I'll put it in the format of
millions So within double quotes I'll
write m
I'll give a semicolon
followed by
another hash
and if the value is less than
the desired number
it should be 0 million let me click on
ADD
all right you can see how nicely we have
formatted our data and you see here we
have
added the new format which is in
millions
all right now if you want you can go
ahead and adjust the
boxes let me move this a bit up I'll
delete this
now if you notice this line chart you
can make a few conclusions for example
if you see here in 2010 the total
revenue generated was nearly 175 million
now this came down to 150 million in
2011 then the revenue constantly grew
from 2011 till 2014
it reached 195 million
and after 2014 it again came down to 180
million and the revenue dropped
significantly between 2016 and 2017. in
2017 the revenue was just 96 million
now before moving ahead to my next chart
let me just rename this sheet so I'll
write it as
Revenue
by year
all right
now
let's analyze the revenue generated each
year in different regions so for this
we'll create another pivot table
let me close this
I'll click on any cell go to insert and
select pivot table
I just click ok so that my PO table is
placed on a new sheet
all right
now this time we want the revenue by
each year and region so first of all
let's drag region to
columns
then
let's drag the order year column under
rows and then
I'll select total revenue onto values
so here you can see we have the pivot
table ready so for 2010 you can see in
Asia
this was the revenue generated
similarly if you see for 2013 this was
the total revenue generated in Europe
and we have for other years as well
now let's create a line chart based on
this pivot table so I'll select any cell
in the pivot table I'll go to insert and
I'll click on recommended charts from
this list I'll select my line chart and
click on OK there you go so we have our
next pivot chart ready
so on the right you see the different
regions that are present in different
colors let me just expand it so that you
can see all the regions we have
so in total we have
seven regions
and each of the regions have been
represented in different colors
so if you notice this graph
for the
sub-Saharan African region
in 2012
sub-Saharan Africa meet the highest
amount of sales
now from the sample data you can also
tell
that the revenue for North America has
been significantly low compared to other
regions
similarly if you see
for Europe
this was the revenue Trend between 2010
and 2017. so if you see here in 2011 the
sales
where at this level then it
significantly dropped in 2012 then in
there was a huge Spike and then in again
came down in 2015 and so on so you can
make your own conclusions by looking at
these line charts now let's
format this chart so first of all let's
delete the field buttons present on the
chart and we'll also
delete the Legend all right now let me
just reduce the size of the chart
next we'll add a chart title so
will
give the title as Revenue
Buy
year end
region
okay
you can also format the
Y axis in terms of Millions
so I'll right click on this axis and
I'll select format access
I'll scroll down and here we have
the number drop down
let me scroll again
under category I'll select custom
and
we will use this format that we created
for our previous chart there you go you
can see
our access labels have been changed in
terms of millions now
so let's close this and let me save it
now you can reduce the font size or
increase the font size let me just show
you suppose you want to increase the
font size of the chart title so you just
select it and from here you can either
reduce or you can increase you can see
now it's 12 if you want you can make it
16. similarly you can also edit the
access labels also
by selecting the chart title you can
also move it to left or right or you can
place it in the center as well for the
time being let me just keep it to the
left
all right
now
we'll see the revenue and total cost
by each region and will create a combo
chart for this so let me show you how to
do it
I'll go to my data sheet
I have my cell selected
go to insert and click on pivot table
let me just click on OK all right
so for this
I'll select
my region onto rows
and then
I'll have
two columns under values the first one
is going to be total revenue
and the next column will be the total
cost column all right so here we have
the pivot table ready now based on this
pivot table let's create our pivot chart
so I'll go to recommended charts and if
you see below
at the bottom we have combo chart so
this is the preview of the combo chart
all right now let me just click on OK
there you go so we have a nice combo
chart ready here
now the way to look at it is the bars
represent the total revenue which is
this column
now
the line represents
the total cost
so
let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so first of all let's delete the
field buttons all right and let's also
remove the legend from here
next
we'll add
data labels so I'll click on data labels
here
okay so these are the data labels for
the bars or the revenue column
now
let's format the data labels in terms of
millions so I'll click on this Arrow go
to more options
if I scroll down
I have number
from here I'll select custom and
I'll choose my type that is in millions
all right so you can see we have
formatted our data
next thing we'll add a chart title
so here I'll write as
Revenue
by
region
it's actually revenue and total cost
by region
before moving ahead let me
rename the sheets as well I'll write
revenue and
total cost
similarly
sheet 3 also I am going to rename it as
Revenue
by
year and region
so this
make sure sheet more readable
all right
now moving ahead
next we are interested to get the
revenue generated by order priority and
for this we are going to create a pie
chart
so let's go to the data sheet
and create our pivot table first
I click on OK
now
I'll select order priority under rows
and under values I'll select total
revenue
so this is a very simple pivot table so
you have your order priority so C is for
critical H is for high L is for low and
M is for medium now based on this let's
create a pie chart so I'll go to
recommended charts and here you have pie
chart
I want to select
this 3D type of pie chart and I'll click
on OK all right so we have our pie chart
ready let me just resize it
and from here I'll remove the field
buttons
and I also don't need the legend so I'll
delete this as well
all right now let's give a chart title
so this is going to be
Revenue by
order
priority
now let's add
our data labels
I'll check this option
okay now let's again format this in
terms of Millions
so here
I click on the last option I'll go to
numbers
under category I'll select custom and my
type is going to be in terms of millions
there you go
let me close this
I will just
move this
to the center
all right
now if you want you can change the color
of the text as well so let's
have it in white color and see how it
looks okay so this looks pretty decent
cool
now
moving to our next report
so this time
we are going to find the total revenue
by countries so we have multiple
countries present in our data set we
want to visualize the revenue generated
in each country
so for this we are going to create a
horizontal bar chart so let me show you
how to do it but before moving ahead let
me just rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue
by
I'll just put op which stands for order
priority all right
now
let's create our horizontal bar chart
I'll go to insert
click on pivot table
and select ok
so I want my Revenue based on different
countries so I'll select country and put
it under rows and then I'll choose total
revenue and place it under values
so here you have the different country
names you have Afghanistan this Albania
let me scroll down you have Bangladesh
there are
a number of countries you have Czech
Republic there's Estonia France Gabon
similarly if you scroll down
we have India this Jamaica Italy and all
the way to the bottom if you go we have
New Zealand this Netherlands Philippines
Portugal
we also have
Singapore
lots and lots of countries
we have the UAE United States of America
Zimbabwe and others
all right let me go up
So based on this pivot table let's
create our people chart
so I'll go to insert and select
recommended charts
from here I'm going to select the column
chart you can see the preview here and
let me click on OK
all right
so here you can see
the different country names at the
bottom and the revenue for each of the
countries
let's go ahead and edit this chart so
first of all I'll delete
the field buttons okay and let me also
remove the legend
here I'll write
Revenue
by
countries
this is going to be my
chart title
okay
let's format this chart a little more
so I'll click on this option
and we'll select a new style let's say
I'll select
style 6 okay
and
let me now go under colors and we'll
select the color of the bars so
let's choose this color okay
so you have
a horizontal column chart ready
and at the bottom you can see the
different country names and we have the
Revenue
cool
now
let me go ahead and
rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue by
countries
and hit enter
okay
and finally we'll create another report
which is going to be part of our Revenue
dashboard and this is revenue by items
so we'll visualize
our revenue for different items present
in the table
so if you see this we have Cosmetics
vegetables cereal fruits this cloths
snacks households and other products as
well so let's check the revenue for each
of these items
so we'll continue the same drill I'll
create my pivot table on a new worksheet
and this time I'm going to drag
item type under rows and
will have the total revenue under values
so here on the left of the table you can
see we have the different
item names and then we have the
total revenue
so let me just
sort this
total revenue
from largest to smallest so
you can see here office supplies meet
the highest amount of Revenue
followed by household then cosmetics and
fruits meet the lowest amount of Revenue
I'll click on this go to insert and
select recommended charts this time I am
going to create a bar chart so this is
how my bar chart is going to look like
I'll select OK all right now let's
format this chart a bit
I'll delete the field buttons and I'll
delete the legend as well
and
let's edit the chart title so this is
going to be
Revenue
by
items
cool
we also want to change the
color of the bars so I've selected all
the bars I'll go to my home Tab and here
let's say I want to select green color
all right
I've edited my chart a bit now
let's
make it
and I'll remove the Bold
okay
here if you want you can change the font
Also let's keep it in blue color all
right
finally
let's rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue by
items
cool
finally
now it's time for us to merge
all the charts that we have created
to our dashboard
so let me show you how you can create
the dashboard
I'll create a new sheet
and first thing I am going to do is
I'll click on The View Tab and uncheck
grid lines so this will remove the grid
lines present in the worksheet
next
I am going to insert an image so we'll
have a background image on our dashboard
so the way to do is I'll go to the
insert Tab and under illustrations I
have the option to select pictures or
insert pictures so I'm going to insert
picture
present on the device that is my
computer
I'll go to desktop and here I have a
folder called Excel dashboard files
and I'll select this dashboard
background and hit insert
so this is going to insert an image now
let me just
drag this image so it covers a fair
enough portion
so I'll hit shift and I'll drag it
all right
so you can see I have successfully added
a background image if you want you can
still
expand this background image
a bit to the right
cool
now the next thing
is going to be
the title of the dashboard so I'll click
on insert and here
I have the option to select a text box
so
I'll click on a text box and
I'm going to place text box in the
middle
and I'm going to name this text box as
Excel
Revenue dashboard
on sales
I'll
Central I net
let's do some more formatting so I'll
select this text box on the top you can
see ship format
here I'm going to expand this shape fill
and I'll select no fill
so
my text box is transparent now and I'll
also remove the outline
all right
now let me just double click on the
title of my dashboard and I'm going to
select
a font you can select whichever font you
want
let me stick to Britannica bold
and I'll increase the size to let's say
all right I'll just
drag the text box
I'll make the text as white instead of
black
all right so we have our
title of the dashboard ready
now if you want you can also insert some
icons to this dashboard so I'll go to
insert and I'll click on illustrations
again and select pictures
I am going to add
these two pictures which is of a store
and a card
to make it look
visually appealing so I'll
place the icons
here and similarly let me just copy it
and I'll place the
card and the store
to the right as well
all right
next
the idea is to
bring in all the charts that we have
created and place it on the dashboard
so let me copy
each of the charts and
place it
on the dashboard so I'll hit
Ctrl V to paste it
and we'll resize this as well
all right
similarly let me bring in all the other
charts as well
all right so now you can see I have
added
all my charts and graphs to this
dashboard
so you can see here we have
our line charts are
column charts the combo charts the Spy
chart
and others
now let me go ahead and format these
charts a little more so you can see this
looks a bit cluttered so let's adjust
the labels let me bring this down
similarly I'll bring
190 million
a little below
all right this looks fine now
one more thing we are going to do is
we'll remove the white background from
each of the charts and make it
transparent so let me show you how to do
it so I'll select this chart
then I'll right click and go to format
chart area
here on the right you see we have an
option called No fill so if I select no
fill you can see the white background
it's gone now similarly let me also
remove the grid lines so I'll select the
grid lines and hit delete so I've also
removed the grid lines from here now
let's also remove the white outline that
we have so I'll select this chart go to
format and here
I'll go to shape outline and I'll select
no outline
you see this so we have our total
revenue by year which is a line chart
and this is completely transparent now
now what I'm going to do is
I'll place this chart over a box so I'll
go to insert and in insert we have the
option to create a shape
so I'll click on illustrations and here
I'll choose a shape and let me select a
rectangle
so I'll just
create a rectangle here
all right and now
what I'll do is
I'll select this and bring this to front
I'll right click
and choose
bring to front
and I'll place this shape
below it
all right now the next thing is to edit
the shape
so first I'll change the color of this
box so let me select this blue color
and and let me increase the transparency
so I'll
right click and go to format shape
here I'll increase the transparency
let's keep it to
25 percent
or let's say
20 percent all right
next thing
we'll just convert all the
font to white color
including the access labels
the chart title
will also
convert all the
access labels to white color so it looks
better now we'll just adjust our
chart over here
next thing let's just
remove the outline so I'll go to shape
outline and I'll select no outline you
see
we have now formatted our chart let's
just
pull this a little up
all right now we'll add this blue
background to all the other charts so
we'll first add the background make it
transparent and then we'll convert the
font text to white color to make it more
readable and visible so
for the time being I'll just pause the
video and come back again
all right so now you can see on your
screens we have nicely formatted our
dashboard so I've added a few logos for
each of the
charts you can see the logos here so for
Revenue by countries we have a globe
then if you see here this is kind of a
map or a location
similarly we have all formatted the
color of the bars
then we have also formatted the labels
in terms of Millions
if you look on the y-axis even the
revenue for year-end region are all
formatted in terms of Millions
if you want this you can also format the
total year by Revenue in terms of
millions so the way to do is you can
select this graph
right click and go to format access
here if I scroll down you have numbers
and under category I'll select custom
then I'll select my type as
this format which is in millions
and you see here we have successfully
formatted our
y-axis labels
all right
so the next thing
is to add slicers and timelines to a
dashboard now slicers are used to format
your data based on a particular column
suppose if you want to see Revenue by
certain items you can add item as a
slicer and you can view the entire
dashboard similarly
for timelines you can add date columns
so if you want to see what was the
amount of sales or revenue generated on
a particular year or a particular month
you can do that using a timeline
so I'll select one of the charts
and then either you can go to the insert
Tab and here you can see under filters
we have slices and timeline or if you go
to the pivot chart analyze tab here also
you have insert slicer and timeline
option so I'll select insert slicer here
first now it's giving me the list of
Fields present in the data set so I'll
select
country
region and let's say we want to
know by
item type and sales channel so these are
going to be my four
slicers I'll click on OK
you can see it here we have our
four slicers here and these are the list
of values under region we have Asia
this Europe North America and others
similarly we have the different country
names for Country slicers and then for
item type also we have all the items
that were present in our data set
now
moving ahead we need to connect
all the slicers to a dashboard so what
I'll do is
I'll right click
on this option
and I'll go to report connections
okay so under report connections you
have all the pivot tables that we
created
you currently see only one of the pivot
table is selected so we need to select
all the pivot tables so let me check
all the pivot tables present in this
workbook and click on OK
all right now that we have connected one
of our slices we'll now connect the
other remaining slicers so I'll right
click on this go to report connections
and I'll check
all the pivot tables present in this
worksheet
click on OK
similarly let's do it for the country
slicer
I'll go to report connections and let me
select
all the pivot tables
and finally we have the item type so
I'll right click
good report connections and then I'll
select
all my Pivot tables
and let's hit OK
all right now let me just organize this
a bit so I'll
place my Pivot tables
to the right
I'll just reduce the size
let me scroll down
I will add
my region slicer here
similarly
I'll add my final slicer that is sales
Channel
now in our next dashboard which is going
to be the profit dashboard I'll show you
how to add a timeline
all right
now I have arranged all my slicers
so let's see you want to find the
revenue that was generated for an item
type let's say
beverages so you can just select
beverages here
and
all your charts
show the respective revenues so you have
the total revenue by year for beverages
only
similarly here you can see the revenue
by year and region only for beverages
item type
if I scroll down
now this chart represents the Revenue
that was generated in each of the
countries only for item type beverages
let me just uncheck it
all right
let's say you want to see
the revenue generated for a country like
India
so I have selected India here
and now you can see
My Graph has changed only for
country India
you can see here it is showing only for
India now
similarly you can also filter your
revenues based on the different regions
let's say you want to know the revenue
generated based on sales channel so we
have two sales channel that is offline
and online suppose you want to know the
revenue generated offline so I'll just
select offline you can see the values
have changed so these were the revenues
generated for each of the items only for
offline
if you
see here now these were all the offline
seals for the different regions
so
this is
our entire Excel Revenue dashboard on
sales
we created multiple charts and graphs
then we applied different formatting we
added different icons then we formatted
the labels also
next we added slicers and
finally we saw how we could filter our
data based on these slicers
likewise now we are going to create a
profit dashboard based on the same data
so before moving ahead let me rename
this sheet as
Revenue dashboard I'll write Rev
dashboard okay
Now we move to our data sheet and
start creating your pivot tables and po
charts for the profit dashboard
all right so let me go ahead and create
my first pivot table so
I'll create a new worksheet
this time I'm going to create a line
chart
to visualize the profit for each year
so I'll drag my
total profit column to values and my
order here to rows
so here you can see we have our
pivot table ready
now you can sort this data
to get an idea as to which
year had the highest profit and which
year had the lowest profit so from this
pivot table you can see since I have
sorted this data in descending order so
had the maximum amount of profit and
2017 had the least amount of profit
I'll just do Ctrl Z to undo it all right
now based on this pivot table let me go
ahead and create my PO chart so I'll go
to recommended charts and click on a
line chart so this is the preview of the
chart
I'll click on OK
let me close this similarly
we are going to
edit this chart now so first I'll hide
all the field buttons present on the
chart and I'll
rename the chart title as total
profit
by year
next I am going to remove the legend so
I'll delete this
let's do some more formatting
so
I'll go to style
and
this time
I'm going to select
my style type okay and if you want you
can
choose the colors as well for the time
being let's have this yellow color
next let me add the data labels so again
if you see here this is not formatted
properly so let's go ahead and format
the
data labels so I'll click on number
and I'll select custom here
and the type I'm going to select is in
millions and I'll click on
close so here you can see we have our
line chart ready which shows total
profit by year
let's
rename this sheet as
profit by
year
all right
now let's move back to our data sheet
again
next we are going to
show the total profit by countries for
this I am going to create a map so let
me first create my pivot table so I'll
go to insert and I'll click on pivot
table
let me click on OK
since I want the country name so I'll
select country under rows and then I
have
my total profit under values
the next thing I'm going to do is I'll
just rename the rule labels as
countries
and then
I'm going to delete the
grand total which you can see at the
bottom so here we have the grand total
let me just delete the grand total so
I'm going to select this pivot table go
to the design tab here we have subtotals
in Grand totals I'll
switch off the grand total let me just
verify it again I'll scroll down you see
the grand total has gone now
all right now we want to create a map
out of this the way to do is
I'm going to
select my data
copy it
'll go on top
and I'll paste it here
using this data I can create my field
map now so I'll go to insert here we
have the option to create a field map
there you go
you can see we have our map ready
I can expand this
as you can see our map has a color scale
which comes from light gray color to
dark blue color
so the countries that are in Gray or you
can say light blue
have the lowest amount of profit while
the regions or the countries that have
been shaded in
dark color a dark blue color have
highest amount of profit
I will go ahead and delete this scale
okay
next we need to connect this map to the
original data source so what I do is
I'll right click on this map and I'll go
to select data here instead of the
previous range I'll give my new Range
now so
my new range
will be my original po table that I had
created
I'll go on top and click on OK
so we have our
map ready now now if you want you can
change the color of the shade so I'll
just go to colors and let's see we'll
keep green color
so the countries that are shaded in dark
green have the highest amount of profit
while those which are highlighted in
light green color are
are the countries that made least amount
of profit
okay now moving on
next
we want to create a pivot table
that will show us the profit by
year and sales channel so for this we
are going to create another line chart
so I'll go to insert and click on pivot
table so I'll select new worksheet here
since I want to know the profit by year
first of all I'll drag my order here
column to rows
and then
I choose my total profit column under
values
next I'm going to select my sales
Channel under columns there you go so we
have our pivot table here
based on this pivot table let me create
my PO chart so I'll go to recommended
charts and I'm going to create a line
chart
I close this
you see here
based on this chart you can tell
The Profit generated with
online sales were actually lower than
that of offline so here the Blue Line
represents offline profit and the Orange
Line represents Online Profit
if you Mark Clearly
in year 2012 the Online Profit was
actually higher than the offline profit
so let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so we'll delete the field buttons
I'll also delete the legend for now
let me go ahead and add
a chart title so I'll write
profit
by
year and
sales Channel
okay
so this is my
second report before moving ahead let me
just
rename this sheet so I'll write
profit
by
countries
similarly
let me rename this sheet as
profit
by
year and let's say a c for sales Channel
okay
moving ahead
now I want to create a pie chart
based on a pivot table that will show
The Profit by sales Channel only so this
is going to be a simple pie chart so
I'll first go to insert click on pivot
table and click on OK
so I'll drag my sales Channel under rows
and then we'll have the total profit
column under values
so this is my simple pivot table now
let's create our pivot chart which is
going to be a pie chart let me explore
the other types of pie charts we have
okay so I'm going to select a donut
chart here I click on OK
let's
edit this chart I'll remove the field
buttons
let me now remove the legend as well
I'll just resize it
and this is going to be
profit
by
sales Channel
okay
let's also add
data labels
and here again
I am going to
format this label
I'll select the category as custom and
my type
will be in millions okay
let me just
move this
to the left
and this to the right
okay
let's also delete the lines cool
now let me just rename this sheet so
I'll write
profit
by
let's say C which stands for sales
Channel
cool
finally
I'm going to create a report that will
show the revenue and profit by items
so I'll go ahead and create my
pivot table first
this time I'll choose my
total profit under values
and we'll also have
the revenue column
so I'll put my Revenue at the top
then I'm going to select
item type under rows
so here is my pivot table
based on this pivot table let me now
create a combo chart
so you can see the preview of the chart
the blue bars represent the total
revenue and the Orange Line represents
the total profit
I'll click on OK
let me close this
first
let's remove the field buttons
let's also remove
the legend here
then we'll add a chart title I'll name
it as
Revenue
and
profit
by
items
okay
if you want you can also go ahead and
change the color of the bars
so let me just select
one of these colors okay
all right
so we have our five reports ready that
we are going to use for our profit
dashboard
next let's create a new sheet and we'll
get started with building our dashboard
so I'll click on a new sheet let me just
rename this as
profit dashboard
all right
we'll continue with the previous drill
so first of all let's go to the view Tab
and remove the grid lines
now will insert a background image
like we did for our Revenue dashboard so
I'll go to insert under illustrations
I'll click on pictures and select this
device
I am going to have the same background
I'll click on insert
all right so you can see we have a
picture of a company or you can say an
organization let's just drag this
a bit to the right
we'll adjust the size also
all right
now let's copy the title of my profit
dashboard so here you can see I have
brought my Revenue dashboard
and I'll copy the title and the logos
that we used
for the revenue dashboard
I'll paste it on my new dashboard
let's just align it
in the center
all right the next step
let me now go ahead and edit the title
so this is actually going to be
Excel
profit dashboard instead of Revenue
now we'll copy each of the charts that
we just created for example
the revenue and profit by items then we
had
profit by sales Channel
all this we are going to copy one by one
and put it on the profit dashboard
so let me just copy a few now
we'll paste it here
and later on we can make the adjustment
and copy this as well
similarly I'll bring the other three
charts onto my sales dashboard
okay so here on my
profit dashboard I have added all the
charts
and have
aligned and reshaped it so that it looks
good
I've also made some formatting for
example I have reduced the size of the
chart title
now let me go ahead and
show you a few more formatting that we
also did for the revenue dashboard first
let's remove the white background from
all the charts so I'll
select the first chart I'll right click
and I'll
click on
format chart area
here under fill I'll select no fill
next I am going to remove the grid lines
so I'll just delete it
let me close this
now we also have a
outline so I'll go to design
actually format and I'll remove the
outline
next I am going to add
a blue box at the back like how we did
for the revenue dashboard so let me
select a blue box from here and I'm
going to paste it here
okay
let me just select
the chart and I'll bring this to front
and I'll move this
to the back
next I'm going to change the font color
all to White
so that it's clearly visible and it's
more readable
I'll do it for the x-axis as well okay
so here I have my first
chart ready the same I'm going to do for
the rest of the charts
okay so now you can see here I have
formatted all my charts I have also
added a blue background
you see here I have also formatted the
y labels in terms of millions which is
actually the profit similarly here I
have added the data labels this is for
Revenue
some of the charts also have the data
Legend so here you can see the blue
color represents offline
and the red represents online similarly
here
you have the legends
have also formatted the map as well
okay now the next thing
is to make this dashboard more
interactive so we'll add our slicers as
well as timeline first let me show you
how to add a timeline
so I'll
select one of the charts and I'll go to
insert under insert I have the option to
create a timeline
so I'll just
click on timelines
so timeline is actually based on date
columns so since in our data set we only
have two date columns one is order date
and one is ship date so Excel has only
shown us two columns so I am going to
create my timeline based on order date
so I'll select my order date column and
I'll click on OK
you can see here this is called a
timeline I can expand this now this
timeline is based on months now and if I
scroll this timeline you can see here I
have my order year 2010 and I have all
the 12 months similarly we have for 2011
then we have for 2012 all the way till
2017. now you can filter this in terms
of years quarters months or days let me
just select year now
so I have
years from 2010 till 2017 let me just
squeeze this and I'll place it somewhere
here on the right
now let me go ahead and create a few
slicers for my profit dashboard so I
have selected one of the charts
under insert I'll click on slicer
you can see it gives me the list of
columns from which I want to create
slicers so I'll create region
let me also select country
let's say I want
the representative's name or the
customer's name
and I'll click on OK
so here I have created three slicers
let me
first resize it and
I'll place it
on the right
similarly I'll place the
country column also
then we have
the region slicer
I'll resize this and I'll bring it here
okay
the next thing we need to do is
I have to connect all the slicers and
the timeline
to
the pivot tables
for the profit dashboard so I'm going to
click on
the multiple select option and go to
report connections here I'm going to
select
all the pivot tables that are related to
profit
so here I have selected four and I need
one more which is pivot table number 10
if I click on OK
similarly let's create or connect my
region filter to all the pivot tables so
I right click go to report connections
here I'll
choose all my Pivot tables which are
based on profit
I'll click on OK
let's do it for the country slicer as
well
click on OK and similarly I'll connect
my timeline as well and go to report
connections
and I'll select
all the pivot tables related to profit
then I'll click on OK
let me now go ahead and create another
slicer based on sales channel so I am
selecting one of the pivot charts I'll
go to insert click on slicer and I'll
select sales Channel and hit OK
so I have my sales Channel
slicer now let me connect it to all the
respective pivot tables
that are based on profit
click on OK
now
let me just bring it here
all right
the next thing I want to show is
how are we going to use the timeline
first
so you see we have all the
years here from 2010 till 2017
suppose you want to know the profit that
was generated in the year 2012 so I'll
just click on this range and now you can
see our
charts only so information for 2012 so
this dot represents that was 51 million
profit in the year 2012. similarly you
can see here
The Profit by sales channel for 2012.
from the map you can see the different
countries and the
profit each of these countries made in
if I scroll down you can see the revenue
and profit by items
now if I select
another year let's say 2013 I can just
drag this to the right and
now you can see
are profit by year and sales channel for
offline and online you can see the map
or the line chart for total profit by
year so in 2012 it was 51 million and
then it went up to 54 million in 2013.
similarly
our map has also changed now this is a
sort of an information that we have you
can click on this and
check the information that
Excel has prompted all right so this is
how you can use a timeline now as I said
we checked by
years you can also see it for months and
quarters as well
let me just
uncheck it
I'll
send it back to the place where it was
and I'll reduce the size
okay
now suppose you want to check the profit
made by different Representatives you
can select them one by one let's say
Adam Churchill
this is the
profit generated by a Adam Churchill
similarly
you can select multiple persons as well
now suppose you want to see the profit
by different countries so you can use
the country slicer let me just bring
this to the middle and
let's expand our chart a bit
okay so here you have the
profit by different countries chart I'll
just
bring this to the front so that you can
see it clearly okay
now here suppose you want to see the
profit generated
in let's say United Kingdom you can
select United Kingdom so this is the map
of United Kingdom and it tells you the
total profit that was generated in
United Kingdom and
below you can see
the revenue and profit for all the items
that was sold in
United Kingdom so you had beverages
clothes household office supplies so you
can see clearly
office supplies item is the highest
amount of profit in
United Kingdom
now you can also select multiple
countries let's say I want to know for
France as well
so my
map will change accordingly so now I
have
United Kingdom and France selected and
the other charts present in my dashboard
change accordingly now I have my
country selected as India you can see
the map of India here
and these were the respective profit
values now one thing to note here is
this is actually
not millions that should be in K that is
Thousands so please mark this as
1000 and not in millions
even for this this is actually K and
naught million
all right
so we have successfully
created our second dashboard that is
on
profit
let me just resize this a bit and we'll
place it
where it was earlier
cool
so we saw
how to create different pivot tables and
pivot charts and then we formatted our
po charge based on our requirement we
saw how to edit the colors now let me
show you one more thing
you can also change the
look and feel of the dashboard by going
to the page layout tab under page layout
you have themes so here you can select
different themes currently we are
with the office theme now let me just
select another theme let's say face it
you see the colors have changed and it
looks
really beautiful
similarly let me try out
another
theme let's say organic you see our
chart has changed let me just delete
this okay so now once you change the
theme the text also change a bit you can
see
the slicers are in a different font
let me explore One More theme let's say
this time I am going to choose
depth
and this is more
offer a green type of color
you can play around and select
whatever theme suits the best
all right
now let me just move back to my Revenue
dashboard and see how it looks there you
go so since we changed our theme even
our Revenue dashboard is also impacted
so
this is how it looks now
you can always go ahead and play with
different themes colors fonts and
effects all right
so in this demo we saw how to create a
revenue dashboard so we created line
charts this combo chart pie chart
horizontal and vertical bar charts and
then we learned how to add slicers and
connected to different pivot tables and
we filtered our data to see
Revenue as well as profit by items by
countries by different regions
sales Channel
we learned how to create
a map
and lots more
allow me to introduce post graduate
program in data analytics by simplylearn
just just take a quick look at the
features followed by the skills you will
gain through this course some key
features of this comprehensive program
includes exclusive hackathons and the
editing sessions by IBM eight times
higher live Addiction in live online
classes by industry experts Capstone
from three domains and 14 plus data
analytics projects with industry data
sets from Google Play Store Lyft World
Bank Etc masterclass is delivered by
Purdue faculty and IBM experts simply
learns job assist helps you to get
noticed by top hiring companies and much
much more it is well said when skills
Empower possibilities flourish to grab
the opportunities gain skills like data
analytics statistical analysis using
Excel data analysis Python and R data
visualization Tableau and power bi and
much more so what are you waiting for
hurry up and Android Now find the course
Link in the description box lookup
function tutorial in Excel what is Excel
vlookup
vlookup stands for vertical lookup
vlookup lets you search for specific
information in your spreadsheet it
allows you to search for a particular
value in a column and returns another
value from a different column but of the
same row
vlookup takes advantage of vertically
aligned tables to quickly find data
associated with the value the user
enters now let's look at the syntax to
write a vlookup function so vlookup
takes four parameters or arguments you
can see it here there are four arguments
in the Wilco function
so the first argument is called the
lookup value the lookup value represents
the value that you are searching for
next is the table array the table array
represents two or more Columns of
information the third argument is called
the column index number now this
represents the column number in the
table from which the value must be
returned the First Column is 1 the
second column is 2 and so on and then we
have the fourth parameter which is
called the range lookup now this
parameter is optional now range lookup
is used to find an exact match
so if you want to find an exact match
you need to enter false or 0 meanwhile
if you want an approximate match you
need to enter true or one if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
now let me give you a brief overview on
what's going to be in our demo
so for our demonstration
we'll use a sales data set you can see
the data set on the left
using this data set we'll understand how
vlookup performs an exact and
approximate match we'll see how vlookup
is case insensitive then we'll perform a
wildcard character search
will understand how to handle errors
when a match is not found and finally
you will look at two-way lookups
now here is a small example of how
vlookup works
so we want to find the units sold by
Morgan using the data set on the left
so here you can see I have the data set
it has
some rows and columns so these are the
columns which are order date region
there's a representative column item
units this unit cost and total and from
this table I want to find the units that
were sold by Morgan if you look at the
table at the bottom you can see the
representative name Morgan and Morgan
has sold 30 units now I want to find
this value using the vlookup function so
here on the right you can see I have my
lookup value which is Morgan and this is
my vlookup formula and using this
formula I am getting the result as 30.
now let's go to our Excel workbook and
perform all the demos one by one so this
is my Excel workbook that we are going
to use for our demo and here is the data
set we'll be using now this is the same
data set that you saw a while ago
so this data set has seven columns you
have the order date the region
representative's name item there's units
unit cost and total which is basically
the total or the amount of sales that
was generated
we are going to use a chunk of this data
set and perform our vlookup analysis
so let's see our first example and the
problem we have at hand
let me go to the exact match tab
all right
so here
I'm going to use this chunk of data
which is actually taken from the
original data set so we have taken the
first
11 rows from the data set you can see
from Row 2
till root 12 is going to be a data set
that we'll use
so we have a question here
we want to find the items sold by
Thompson so here
Thompson is my lookup value which means
looking at Thompson I want to find the
item that is sold
so if you consider our table here you
can see we have the representative's
name Thompson
right here and from the table you can
see Thompson sold pencil
and I want to get this value which is
pencil using my vlookup function so
let's go ahead and write our vlooker
function
I'll consider this as my lookup value
and here under item I am going to write
my vlooker formula
to write the vehicle formula I'll write
first equal to
and
I'll write vlookup now if I hit tab it
will auto complete all right now let's
give the parameters so first is going to
be the lookup value which is nothing but
Thomson so I'll just select this cell
which is j17
comma now it's asking to give the table
array so the table array is the table
from which you want to retrieve a value
one thing to keep in mind is that the
value you are looking for should be the
first column of a table and you can
select the table array till the end of
the data set or till the column which
has the value you want to find
so here I'll select my table array
starting from the representatives column
till the end of the item column which is
going to be my table array then I'll
select the column index number so the
column index number is based on the
table array you have selected in this
case my column index number is going to
be 2 because we have selected just two
columns and the value which I am going
to find is in the second column so I'll
give 2
comma now the range lookup I am going to
give is false because I want to find an
exact match so either you can hit tab
or you can write 0 which means false
if I close the bracket and hit enter
it will return me the item that Thomson
had sold which is pencil you can verify
from the table that Thompson had sold
pencil all right
now let's try to change the table array
and see what result are we getting so
this time I'll slightly change the table
array so again we are trying to find the
item that Thompson had sold so I'll
write my formula equal to vlookup I'll
hit tab to auto complete I'll give my
lookup value as Thompson
comma this time I am choosing my table
array starting from the representatives
column till
the end of the data set which is
till p12
again my column index number is going to
be 2 because if you consider this table
array the item column is the second
column in the selected table array so I
am going to write it as 2 comma
the range lookup I want to give as false
because I want to find the exact match
if I close this and hit enter you can
see it has returned me the same result
that we saw earlier
now suppose let's say this time I want
to start my table array from the region
column which is this column
so I want to select my table array
starting from the region column now this
is going to show me an error because
your table array should always start
from the lookup value column so if you
consider Thompson as the lookup value
my table array should always start from
the representatives column so let's just
try this example
so I'll write vlookup
my lookup value I'm going to give it as
Thompson comma the table array as I
mentioned earlier I am going to choose
from the region column and let's say
I'll select till the item column give
another comma and this time a column
index number is going to be 3 because
since the table array has three columns
and my item column is the last column so
I'm going to give my column index number
is 3 comma I I want to get the exact
match so I'll give 0 if I close the
bracket and hit enter you can see it has
given me an error
okay now let me just show you another
method to use vlookup in Excel
so here on the top you can see there's a
formulas Tab and under formulas tab
under function Library you see we have
an option to select lookup and reference
if I click on this
and if I scroll down below you can see
there's an option
called vlookup let's choose this
all right now here you can give
your lookup value your table array
column index number and the range lookup
under this function arguments dialog box
so here I want to select my lookup value
as
Thompson my table array is going to be
from the representatives column till
let's say the end of the data set
my column index number is going to be 2
I'll write 2 and range lookup I'll write
as false because I want the exact match
if I hit OK you can see it has given us
the exact same result so this is one of
the other ways to use vlookup in Excel
now let's move to the next sheet which
is regarding approximate match okay so
sometimes you might have cases where you
don't have the lookup value present in
the table in those cases you can tell
vlookup to return an approximate match
now one thing to keep in mind is that
your lookup value columns should always
be sorted in ascending order while
trying to get an approximate match so
here we are going to use this table and
my lookup value column which is going to
be the representatives column is already
sorted in ascending order
and let's see the question we have here
so I want to find the item sold and the
unit cost format so my lookup value is
going to be matte now if you see this
table I don't have the representative's
name matte anywhere in the table now
using an approximate match I want to
find the item and the unit cost so let's
do it
so here under item I'll write my vlooker
formula
so I'll type vlookup I'll hit tab to
complete it
and this time meluco value is going to
be matte so I'll select this cell comma
my table array I'll select
from the representatives column till
the end of
item column because I want to find the
item value format I will give a comma
my column index number as per the table
array is going to be 2
comma my range lookup this time I am
going to give a screw or one
so I'll write 1
close the bracket hit enter
all right it has written me binder was
the item sold by Matt
now let's try to figure out why vlookup
returned binder as the item
now let's say you were asked to insert
the name matte to the representative
column in alphabetical order so where
would you place it
ideally you should Place between qvel
and Morgan
since this column is already sorted mat
should appear before Morgan and after
cubelle so in an approximate match
vlookup will consider the previous
highest value
in this case the previous highest value
before mat is qvel and hence vlookup
returned the corresponding item
purchased by keval which is binder now
similarly
if you wanted to find the unit cost
format
again vlookup will return the unit cost
of qvel which is 125. let's just try it
out so I'll write vlookup
my lookup value is matte comma my table
array for this time is going to be from
Representatives column
till the unit cost column I'll consider
I'll give a comma now the column index
number as per the table array is going
to be 4 we'll give another comma and
this time I'll double click true because
I want an approximate match we close the
bracket hit enter you can see it has
written me 125 which is actually
cables unit cost okay we have another
question and this time I want to find
the units sold by Rob now Rob is going
to be my lookup value
if you see the representatives column we
don't have Rob now let's see what
vlookup is going to return as the item
for Rob so I'll write vlookup I'll give
my lookup value as Rob comma my table
array
is going to start from the
representatives column I'll select till
here I'll give a comma my column index
number is 2
will give another comma
I'll double click on true
so close the bracket hit enter you can
see vlookup has written me pen now let's
understand why we look up returned pen
for Rob now if you are asked to insert
the representatives name Rob
into this column so ideally Rob would
appear somewhere between Morgan and
Sorvino because
since this is sorted in ascending order
Rob is actually greater than Morgan and
is less than Sorvino so as you know
vlookup in an approximate match Returns
the previous highest value which is
Morgan here and the corresponding item
for Morgan is pen and hence we look up
returned pen from Rob all right
now moving to the next sheet
which is another property of vlookup
which tells vlookup always looks to the
right this means that your lookup value
must always be on the left
and the value you are going to find out
should always be to the right of the
table now consider this scenario where
you look up values on the left in this
case it is the representatives value and
I have taken cervino for an example
and we want to find the order date for
Sorvino
now if you consider this table your
lookup value which is sure we know is
actually this column the representatives
column and we are going to find out the
order date so your representative's name
is on the right of the table and the
value we are going to find out is on the
left of the table
now as per the property vlookup only
looks to the right
so if I use the vlooker function for
this example here I'll write vlookup
I'll give my lookup value as sorpino
comma
multiple array I'll consider from the
order date because I want the order date
till
the representatives column I'll give a
comma and this time
my column index number is actually the
first column if I consider my table
array as the first three columns
selected
and my range lookup is going to be false
if we close the bracket hit enter it
returns me an error the reason is
vlookup always looks to the right and
this time the value we were trying to
find out was to the left of the table
now
if you consider
the opposite case suppose you have the
order date and you want to find the
representative's name you can do that
easily because your lookup value which
is the order date is on the left and
your representatives column is on the
right so let's just try this I'll write
vlookup my lookup value is going to be
order date so I'll select it from the
table
I'll give a comma my table array will
start from the G column let's say I'll
select the entire table
comma and my column index number will be
3 if you consider these as my table
array
comma my range lookup is zero if I close
this hit enter you can see we have got
Sorvino corresponding to the order date
all right now let's move to the next tab
now this tab says vlookup returns only
the first match so we have a question at
hand the question is
find the units sold by Jardine
if you see this table
we have the representatives name Jardin
twice you see here and if you look down
we have Jardin here as well but the
items sold by Jardin at the first
instance is pencil and at the second
instance it's desk
now as per the property vlookup always
returns the first match now ideally when
we write the vlookup function and look
for the units sold by Jardine you will
see vlookup will return
36 instead of 3. let's just try it out
I'll write the vlooker function
my lookup value is Jardine comma my
table array
I'll select from the representatives
column till the end of
units column
will give a comma my column index number
based on the table array is three I'll
give another comma Now I want the exact
match so I'll select 0
close the bracket and hit enter
as you can see it returns me the first
match of Jardine which is 36 so vlookup
did not consider the second match
now similarly
if you consider this table
we have Jones repeated Thrice so you
have Jones here
you have Jones
here for the second time and also we
have zones for the third time and let's
see you want to find the unit cost for
Jones so if I write the vlookup function
I'll consider my
lookup value as Jones comma my table
array
I'll select from the representatives
column till the end of unit cost column
I'll give a comma based on the table
array my unit cost column is at the
fourth index so I'll write 4 comma the
range lookup is 0.
if I click on this
and hit enter you can see it here
vlookup has returned the first instance
of Jones and it did not consider the
second and the third instance so a unit
cost
for Jones is 1.99 because vlookup only
Returns the first match
okay moving ahead to the next example we
have here is vlookup is case insensitive
if you consider this table
I've added another
Row in green
so if you see here I have a
representative name called Gill which is
in proper case or
popularly known as sentence case here I
have added Gill's name in
capital letters are all in uppercase so
I want to find the total revenue
generated by Gill the total revenue is
basically the total column
let's do it I'll write vlookup
my lookup value is Gill which is
actually in upper case
I'll consider my table array from the
representatives column till the end of
total column or the sales column
based on the selection my column index
number is 5.
comma the range lookup is false so I'll
just double click on false
if we close the bracket hit enter
you can see it here
our vlookup function has returned the
total as
539.73 which is actually
the value for this row so clearly
vlookup did not consider Gill which was
present at the bottom of the table in
uppercase
so this shows that vlookup is clearly
case insensitive
all right
now moving to the next example the
vlookup function supports wild cards
which makes it possible to perform a
partial match on a lookup value for
instance you can use vlookup to retrieve
values from a table after typing only
part of a lookup value to use wildcards
with vlookup you must specify the exact
match by giving false or 0 for the last
argument that is range lookup now we
have a question here
I want to know how much sales did the
representative whose name starts with k
i make now here sales represents the
total column actually
so I want to find out the person whose
name starts with Ki
so if you consider the representative
column I have one representative whose
name starts with Ki that is give l so
using Ki as my lookup value I want to
find the total so let me show you how to
use wildcard characters and find
the value using vlookup
so I'll write my function vlookup
okay now in lookup value I'll give Ki
after that I am going to write Ampersand
followed by
double inverted commas
then I'm going to write a star and close
the inverted comma this means the value
starts with k i am percent actually
represents concatenation and star
represents anything followed by Ki
so this is going to be my lookup value
in total
I'll give a comma
next I'll select my table array starting
from the representatives column till the
end of total column because I want to
find the seals
give another comma
my column index number based on the
table array we have selected is 5.
comma the range lookup is 0 because I
want to find an exact match
let's close the bracket hit enter you
can see it here
vlookup has returned me 999.5 which is
actually Cable's total
now there's another way to do it
instead of selecting the cell in which
we have the lookup value I can directly
write it in the vlookup function
so I'll write the vlookup function
something like this so my lookup value
I'll pass Ki within double inverted
commas because k i is a character value
So within double inverted commas I'm
writing Ki followed by Ampersand which
is for concatenation
followed by
a star
within double inverted commas so this is
going to be my lookup values this in
total means anything that appears after
Ki will be considered as the lookup
value
again the table array I'll select as
these rows and columns
comma my column index number would be 5
comma the range lookup is 0. if I close
the bracket hit enter you see we have
the same value so this is another method
or another way of using
vlookups
okay now moving ahead let's explore
another feature of vlookup so if the
vlookup function cannot find a match it
returns a hash an a error now if you
want you can use the if any function to
replace the hash any error with a
friendly message so suppose
you want to find the region in which an
order was placed on 10th of May 2018.
now if the order date is not found I
want to return a message that is invalid
date
so
if you look at the order date
column we don't have any value for 10th
of May 2015. you can see these values we
don't have any value corresponding to
this date
so
if my vlookup function cannot find this
lookup value I'll return invalid date so
let me show you
how to write this
I'll type my vlookup function
I'll give my order date as 10th of May
2015.
as my lookup value and then
I'll consider my table array starting
from the order date column till the end
of
region column
will give another comma my column index
number would be 2 this time based on the
table array we have selected comma
I want an exact match
so I'll give 0 close the bracket and hit
enter
there you go it has written me an error
now I want to convert this error to a
friendly message saying invalid date so
let me show you how to do it I'll do it
here so to return a valid message
I'll use the if any function
and within if any function I'll give my
vlookup function
so let me type if n a
I'll hit tab
now for the value parameter I'll use my
vlookup function so my lookup value is
going to be the order date
comma my table array I'll select from
the order date column till the end of
region column comma where column index
number is going to be 2
comma my range lookup is 0
I'll close the bracket give another
comma Now if this expression results in
an error I want to display a message
that is invalid date so I'll put invalid
date within double quotes
since it is
a text message
I close the bracket hit enter you can
see
the result which is invalid date
now moving on to the final section of
the demo
we have two-way lookup
now in the vlookup function the column
index parameter is normally hard coded
as a static number however you can also
create a dynamic column index by using
the match function to locate the right
column
and this technique allows you to create
a dynamic two-way lookup matching on
both rows and columns
now let me first show you how a match
function works so suppose
I want to find the index where unit cost
column is present
so here I'll use the match function
I'll give my lookup value as the unit
cost column name
comma suppose I'll choose my lookup
array starting from Representatives
column till the unit cost column comma
I'll give my match type as 0 for exact
match
if I close the bracket hit enter it
returns me 4 because
my array was selected from the
representatives column till the unit
cost column and in this array unit cost
is at the fourth index
all right now using this idea let's
solve the following problem I want to
find the cost of each item sold by
Morgan
so let's
write our vlookup formula
write B lookup
my lookup value is J5 which has the
representative's name as Morgan comma
while table array I'll select from
C2
till
F12
I'll give a comma and this time I know
that my column index number is at
4 but I'll be using the match function
to find the same
so I'll write match
my lookup value is
unit cost comma
my lookup array is from C1 till F1
comma my match type is 0
I close this bracket give another comma
and I'll give my range lookup as 0
close the bracket hit enter you can see
for Morgan the unit cost is 19.99 you
can verify from the table for Morgan the
unit cost is 19.99
all right now
we have another question here
I want to find how much sales did
Andrews make in the central region so
here I have
two lookup values one is Central one is
Andrews now looking at these two values
I want to find the total
to solve such problems
let me first create
another table
I'll place the table somewhere here
okay so let me just paste the table here
all right now I'll create another column
where I'll merge the values of region
and representatives so here let me
create another column okay I'll just
name this column as
region
rep
all right now this column
I'll use the concatenation operator
so I'll Select East
use Ampersand and then select Jones I'll
hit enter
now the same thing I'll just duplicate
it
for the other rows as well so I have my
new column created Now using this table
I can easily solve the problem
now to find the total I'll write my
vlookup formula
so my lookup value
will be a combination of j11
ampersand
k11
comma well table array will start from
the region rep which has the values of
region and rep combined
till
the last column
and from this table array my column
index number is 5
and my range lookup is zero if I close
the bracket hit enter you can see
for central region which is this one
and for Andrews representative the total
is 149.25
all right now we are done with our demo
let's have a quick glance at what all we
did in this demo
okay so first of all we saw our data set
which was a sales data set that we used
then we started with our first example
to see how vlooker performs an exact
match we also saw how using the formulas
Tab and lookup and reference you can
write vlookup in
another way so you can use the function
arguments to give your vlookup
parameters next we saw how vlooker
performs an approximate match so we had
matte and raw which were not present in
the representatives column
after that
we saw an important property of vlookup
that is vlookup only looks to the right
followed by
vlookup only Returns the first match
following which we saw
that vlookup is case insensitive so here
we had added a new row where Gill was
present in uppercase but still we look
up
found the total revenue for Gill which
was in sentence case or proper case next
we saw how we can use wildcard
characters to
use vlookups
and here we saw how to use an if any
function along with vlookup and finally
we saw how to use two-way lookups choose
from over 300 in-demand skills and get
access to 1000 plus hours of video
content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more now we are on
the sheet of Microsoft Excel and here
you can see some data on my sheet
that is employee name employee ID and
salary
so here we are going to perform our
horizontal lookup but before that let me
show you that this particular drop down
menu so this particular drop down menu
has all the names of the employees in
this particular table and we have
created this using data validation in
Excel if you want to create the drop
down menus just like this then feel free
to check out our data validation in
Excel tutorial link to which is in the
description box below now let's try to
implement each lookup in Excel so here
we have employee name but we want to
find out the employee ID so for that
let's create the hlookup now for that
equals to hlookup
now the first one is a lookup value so
this one is the cell which is the
employee name now after that the table
array we have to select all the table
arrays here
now
the row index number so the employee ID
is in row index number 2 according to
the table so for that provide 2 and
close the bracket and before closing
brackets you might want to give the
exact match so for exact match select
false and close the bracket press enter
and there you go and if you select jet
then you'll find the employee ID of
check and if you select jury you'll find
the employee ID of cherry reflecting
here now similarly let's find out the
salary of all the employees using
hlookup so equals Edge lookup
and lookup value that happens to be the
name of the employee now the table array
and next we have row index number that
is salary happens to be the third row in
the table so free and
exact match
close the bracket and enter so now if
you change the values in this particular
drop down menu you will find the
employee ID and their particular salary
so Jack happens to be carrying the
employee ID as one zero zero one and his
salary is ten thousand so similarly
let's try to find out Peter's employee
ID and salary so there you go 1005 and
50 000 as salary so that's how you use
hlookup in Excel here you can see the
first chart so this particular data is
converted into a table format to avoid
confusion while you're fixing the data
so here you can see the name of the
employee employee ID Department salary
and date of churning and here you can
see the salary column and the bonus
percentage of each and every employee
based on their salaries now coming to
the new data table and here on the table
2 which is an updated table here you can
find we are going to find out the
department of the employee and the
current Department of employee and the
bonus percentage based on his or her
salary so why are we finding current
Department again
so here you can see that we have an
intern Emily who has joined in the year
2020 but recently she got promoted as a
developer so her department has been
changed from Department in turn to
Department developer in 2021 so that's
what we're gonna find out here in the
current Department using X lookup now
let's start to implement X lookup so for
that equals to xlookup
and for lookup you can see if you need
to find out the lookup value lookup
array written array and all the other
two are not important right now but you
can use them to get some exact matches
in the future we'll also use that in the
future for now let's try to use the
first three parameters that is lookup
value lookup array and written array so
the lookup value is the name of the
employee Mary and lookup array is right
here which is this one
now we are going to select the lookup
array then comma and we're going to look
up the department so this is the
department lookup array
and that's all we need
close the bracket and press enter
okay I think we missed out the lookup
value
so the employee or the lookup value
which we required was missed so I've
added it here so that is the lookup
value the first one which is Miri and
there you go
press enter and you have the department
here now let's add it to all the rows
and here you have all the rows and all
the data related to all the employees
now we will find out the current
Department as you can see here you have
Emily as intern which is the older data
but what if you needed the latest data
that is the developer in the year 2021
right for that you might want to
throughout the X lookup formula a little
bit so let's try that X lookup
lookup value which is the scene and
comma now where you have to look for the
array that is lookup array this one and
the return array which happens to be
this one
and next
you can find the exact match for this
one so that's all right exact match and
here comes the important part where you
have to search last to first by default
X lookup searches for first to last that
is like this in the starting place to
the last place so that's the reason why
we had Emily as intern so now if we give
last to first then it retrieves the
latest data where Emily will be shown as
developer now select that and now you
can close the brackets and press enter
so let's add that to all the rows there
you go now you can see Emily Clark Peter
and James all they have got their
updated job profiles as you can see in
the original data Emily is a developer
now so is Clark who was originally a
tester and he got promoted to
development team in 2021 similarly Peter
became a senior Finance executive in
2021 and James the manager of sales now
let's try to find out the bonus for all
these employees based on their salary so
this one is quite simple
so X lookup
now the lookup value is their existing
salary
comma and the bonus part so the lookup
array is the salary range
then here is another important point so
here you might want to find the exact
match but finding an exact match will
not help you here you might want to
declare another type of value where you
can get exact match or next smaller item
so you'll understand it why I'm
selecting that so now let's close the
bracket and enter so
so now we have the bonus values now
let's add the bonus value to all the
factors all the rows I mean so you can
see we have different variety of
salaries that is thirty eight thousand
twenty two thousand thirty nine Etc but
here in the ranges we have provided 10
20 30 1450 so what if the value is
between 30 and 20 that's when you want
the list number right that's when you
want the number which is equivalent to
30 or less than 30 which happens to be
15 percent so that's how it has worked
here that is 0.15 bonus to the actual
salary rate
so on my screen you can see an example
Excel budget template theme so on my
screen you can see a column where you
have the debit amount so in the I column
we have all the amount what we are
spending for a month and on the right
column will be the balance amount or the
running balance of that for example you
can see that there is a row number five
where the debate amount is 8000 for our
genes Levi's and it is done through UPI
payment now if I change this value of 8
000 to 4000 something
then you can see that the running
balance will automatically change you
can see that currently the running
balance is 73 000 and if I change this
value from 8 000 to 4000 then all the
Ryan balances will change let's show
that so for that let's press enter
there you go you can see that the number
has been changed successfully and all
the values from the running violence
have also changed until the last date
which is the March 30th
now how is this working and not just
that you can see that we have also
included what is the total debit amount
in January and what is the running
balance that is the total available
balance after one lakh has been debated
into the account in the month of
February as February income
now the current available violence is
one lakh 13 200 and the total expense in
February is 1 lakh four thousand five
hundred right how am I doing on this
looks so much interesting right now
let's do this practically
so for that I have already created a new
sheet and I have included all the data
that we have used previously the income
of that particular month and all the
expenses of that particular month
now without further Ado let's begin to
implement the Excel budget template now
our first step happens to be converting
all the data into a natural table so you
know that in Excel all the data values
are stored in the form of a database by
default so it happens to be our duty to
convert the database type table into the
pure table type table so for that select
quality data and press Ctrl T and then
you have an option to convert this data
into a table and remember to check this
particular checkbox and tell your Excel
that your table has headers so we do
have headers here so now press OK and
your table will be converted into a
natural table
now let's type in the formulas
so now let's select the cell J2
and type in the formula
so what are we doing here is we are
trying to add the sum of J2 plus H3
so which is this party lesson and
removing I3 that is this particular
debit amount so this formula is used for
checking the running balance let's press
enter and there you go
so it means that you received 1 lakh
rupees in the month of January and out
of that one lakh you spend 15 000 rupees
for something maybe your educational
load or something and then the remaining
running balance out of 1 lakh Rupees is
85 000 rupees now let's copy the same
formula to all these cells
there you go now the running balance has
been calculated for all the cells here
now remember the monthly income
available balance and debut for
generating final balance now let's try
to calculate that for all the three
months so here we have three months that
is January February and March now let's
do a simple calculation to find out the
available balance of that month and the
total debit made by that person in that
particular month
the formula is really simple all you
have to do is use a sum function and
calculate the sum of all these values
and done right
there you go so the total expense of the
month January is 93 800 rupees now let's
calculate the total debit of February
month same formula that is
calculating the sum of
all the expenses made in the month of
February
day
now let's also calculate the sum of all
the expenses in the month of March
done so we have the final values of all
the total expenses made in those
particular months
now let's calculate the final balance
now I think I forgot one important thing
so before we calculate the final balance
we need to find out the available binds
that is the available balance after 1
lakh Rupees is created into our account
and along with the savings that you have
from your previous month right so that
we have a simple formula
now which all we are doing is just
adding the uh income cell with the
balance cell that's all
so there you go now after crediting one
lakh rupees and adding up the uh balance
of that particular month that is we have
13 200 remaining from the month of
January and the month of February we
have income of one lakh so the total
amount is 11 300 and
I don't know it is 1 lakh 13 200 yeah
now we have the final balance that is
the difference between the available
balance and the debit made in that
particular month so in the month of
February we had a total balance of one
lakh 13 200 and the total debit of one
lakh four thousand five hundred so the
final remaining balance is eight
thousand seven hundred
similarly the same formula has been
applied for the month of March and the
final balance we have is 37 300. so
that's how you implement budget template
in Excel all simple formulas and you
have all the numbers at your filling
tips so here I'll be discussing some
important questions that you will come
across when you finish interview for
Excel and we will start with the basics
the beginner level and most of them will
be discussed here will be the beginner
level at the beginning and then we'll
discuss it for at the further left
okay so of the first question that you
might get asked is what is a cell
address in Excel so
a cell address is a combination of
column letter and a row number that
identifies a cell on a worksheet
basically each cell will have an
Associated column number column letter
and a row number so you have to keep in
mind it will be always be a column
letter and a row number each Excel sheet
will have suppose for instance if you
take Row 5 rows will be in numbers and
the columns will be in letters column a
column B column C column D and so on and
the numbers will be for the rows so for
instance if you take this particular
cell the cell address is D5
column D and row five so this is the
cell address now let's move on to the
next one
now you will be asked what is relative
cell referencing and absolute cell
referencing even at Excel so relative
cell referencing is usually the relative
references change when a formula is
copied to another cell depending on the
destination's row and column okay so
this is called relative cell referencing
absolute cell referencing irrespective
of the cell you know you don't have to
depend on the value of the cell
destination there is no change when a
formula is copied so this way I'll
explain it in the next Slide the basic
difference is this type of referencing
is there by default in Excel relative
cell referencing you just insert the
formula you don't need to put a dollar
sign in the formula whereas absolute
cell referencing if you don't want to
change in the formula when it's copied
across cell then absolute cell
referencing requires you to add a dollar
sign before and after the column and row
address so see for instance
this is relative referencing you know if
you see this this particular cell is
having we put the value as A3 into B3 so
what it will do is it will multiply A3
and B3 and it will give the product this
is relative cell reference whereas
absolute cell referencing is again the
same thing but you have to put a dollar
sign before the column and the row
number so here you are specifying this
as a pre into B2 okay A3 into V2 and it
will give you this particular answer
irrespective of that it will give you it
will calculate what is there in this and
it will give you the answer
okay now we next move on to the next
point is basic question when you scroll
across an Excel sheet sometimes you have
a header and you will see this if you
see here
select the third row and click freeze
pins so you just select this and click
replay
okay so you're going here and you are
going to the third row and you are going
to view Tab and you are selecting free
Spin so what happens is first two rows
will be locked okay
these two rows will be locked similarly
for if you want to freeze the columns
okay it's the same thing I am going to
select this particular column
and then click on view and then click
freeze pane so what happens is the first
two columns are locked A and B will be
locked and if I scroll right you will
always see the customer name and
category column so these two we have
logged and the next will be scroll so
this is the function of freezing panes
okay now coming on to the next one and
you will be asked and you have an Excel
sheet or a spreadsheet and you want to
restrict you want to protect the data
for from anyone or from someone cop from
copying the cell for your worksheet so
how do you do that you need to select
that particular data that you want to
protect and then click Ctrl shift F and
then you will see the protection tab
okay you just need to go to the
protection Tab and select lock
okay and you will be asked to put a
password wherein you will be getting the
review tab where you you need to select
the sheet put a password and just save
it so I will show you across in one of
the examples here so this is particular
uh data that you have and you need to
protect you select it
so here as I said I selected it and then
I just press Ctrl shift F so here you
see the protection tab click the
protection Tab and then click select and
then locked then click OK and then you
need to go to the review Tab and then
click on the protect sheet and you are
having the you need to select this
protect worksheet and contents of Log
search so if you are selecting these and
you are protecting the content and you
just need to put some password
okay and then click ok
so this is how you protect the data on a
worksheet and you are selecting this
area Ctrl shift F and just put up a
password and select lock sheet so this
is how you protect the sheet from anyone
to copy it
and now the next question that you might
be asked is what is the difference
between a function and a formula in
Excel
so you will be asked this question and
you need to remember this formula is
like an equation which is typed in by
the user you are typing it suppose a 1
plus B2 you are typing this formula in
one particular cell okay whereas
function functions are predefined
calculations it is like a formula which
is already there in Excel and you can
use it so as it says here it consumes
more time and it has to be typed in
manually you this is as per the need
basis and this is particularly it's very
quick and very efficient you have
inbuilt formulas in Excel the sum and
multiplication product and various other
things that you will come across so this
is the basic difference between a
formula and a function in Excel okay
that now the next question that you
might be asked is uh or you need to know
basically is the order of operations
used in Excel while evaluating the
formulas so what is the order you need
to remember this acronym padmas p e d m
a s or another simple terms you can use
this also please excuse my dear and
Sally so these are the acronyms p e d m
a s now let's see what happens first and
you uh in math when you do some
calculations you have order of
operations okay bod mass is the one of
the order of operations now in Excel
similarly in Excel when you put up a
formula you Excel will calculate it in a
particular order and this is called the
order of operations and the Order of
Operations is first it will calculate
what is there in the parenthesis it will
perform this function and then it will
see if there are any X components in it
and if it is there it will do that
calculation the next and after that it
will see if there is a new
multiplication or division so Eed and
then it will see if there is any
addition okay and then the last one will
be the subtraction so Excel knows this
and you have to know this so that when
you put up a formula you will know what
is going to happen first and you will
not mess up with your formula okay this
is the order of operation so it is one
of the important questions in the
interview for a beginner Excel level now
the next one is uh how will you write
the formula for following multiply the
value in a cell A1 by 10 and add the
result by 5 and divide it by 2. it is
quite simple okay say I'm just giving it
as an example in this slide and you
might be asked something else so you
will be given a task to calculate or put
up a formula for this so when you are
asked to multiply the value in a Cell of
A1 by 10 so this is particularly okay A1
is the particular cell that is being
given and you are multiplying it okay
you put it in parenthesis and then add
the result by 5 so it will calculate the
parenthesis first okay and if it sees if
there are any exponents you have to
think in that way if there are any
exponents in or not and then first it
will see the parenthesis and then
exponent there are no exponents here and
then it will do the multiplication and
then the addition and the division okay
so you will get this particular answer
and if you put it simply in this way
your answer is wrong because it will
multiply it into 10 at 5 and divide by
2. so you have to check which one is
right and you have to make sure that you
are putting the right parenthesis Okay
so
this is the formulator
okay
the next question is uh there is a
different what is the difference between
count counter and count blank these are
three particular important things that
you need to these are similar but they
are quite different when you actually
see it okay so first we will see what is
count count is basically it counts the
number of cells which have numeric
values as the name suggests it is count
it will count the number of cells which
has numeric volumes okay if you see this
column and uh we are at a11 we are
putting it as count equals to a 10 to A2
to a 10 so you're taking this range and
you're finding out what are the number
of cells which have numeric value if you
see this one two three four five so five
cells have numeric values it counts the
cells which has numeric value and the
next thing is the counter okay what
counter does it counts the number of
cells which has any form of content it
can be anything it can be a number it
can be a alphabet it can be anything it
will see what are the number of cells
which has any form of content okay for
example this is the same example here
taken here and we have put the function
as counter A2 to 18. now see one two
three four five six
seven so it sees that there is
seven cells have some content in it it
is numbers and letters it can be
anything but it has some content so
counter is the function for this then
the next one is Count black okay as the
name suggests it will count the number
of blank cells only
so again the same examples count black
A2 to a 10 okay it will see what are the
number of blanks okay if you see this is
blank and this is black so two cells are
blank so it will count the number of
blank cells only okay now the next one
is uh what is the shortcut to add a
filter to a table why do we use filter
and it is one of the basics uh function
in the Excel where you need to do some
sorting and it can be done by using a
printer what is the shortcut key it's
very simple control shift and L this is
the key that is used to put up a filter
you just press this
Ctrl shift L altogether and you will
find the filter and you can sort it now
the next question that you will come
across is how do you create a hyperlink
in Excel so it's quite simple there is a
simple shortcut Ctrl
okay you press these two together and
you will get the option you will select
the you can select the cell where you
have to insert the hyperlink hyperlink
basically it redirects to any other
document it can be a web page it can be
a Word document it can be another Excel
sheet or so on okay so these are the
things okay
now another important questions uh that
is how to merge multiple cells
text strings in a Cell so how do we
merge the text strings in multiple cells
into one cell
there is one particular simple function
that you can use which is called called
as concatening concatenate function is
used to merge text strings present in
multiple cells okay and it's a very
simple thing you just need to put this
equals to concatenate and then if for
example this is the formula concatenate
text 1 text to textly or this is a
concatenate A1 comma B1 comma C1 this is
the data in our three cells Excel is one
in A1 V1 and C1 so now if you want to
put them all in one and you can merge it
in one cell using the concatenate
function and it's very simple
concatenate and parenthesis A1 comma P1
comma C1 okay and you will get it all
merge in one particular cell okay so
this is how you use the concatenate
function and you can also use the and
operator to combine cell values it is
the same thing you can use e and
operator instead of Commerce okay and
and I will show it to you in the example
here
okay now we have this I'll just copy
this thing to
yeah okay
let's make it simple and now I want to
put this here equals
con
cat in it and A1
comma B1 comma c i just close it and I
put enter so you see this this all three
the different text is merge in one
particular cell and it will you can
perform various merge functions using
the concatenate function it's a very
simple thing and it is a frequently
asked questions in the interview okay
the next question uh it is very a very
important one again and very basic as
well so how can you split a column into
two or more columns you have some
particular text or a sentence written or
data written in your cell or a column
and you want to put them across in two
or more or many number of columns so how
do you perform this function it's very
simple again you need to select that
particular cell so for instance we have
it here is India is a democratic country
India space is space a space then
Democratic space country so the it's a
different text here and you want to
split this particular sentence into
different columns okay you need to
select that cell and then go to the data
Tab and then choose text to columns
there will be an option when you need to
select text to columns okay and you will
see this screen okay and you need to
select the choose the delimiter here and
what we are specifying here is first it
is a delimited and then we are selecting
a delimiter as space because we see that
that is space here which is very common
and we want to split it so you will see
a preview here which shows what your
output will be like India in one column
is a democratic country so the diameter
is space here and T you need to select
this and then click next Okay so so you
will see the options select the columns
data format and choose the destination
now you see the data View and you need
to select the destination where you want
to put this output as you select that
and then click finish and this one what
it does it it's it splits the text into
multiple columns okay so you see this
you have selected this as the output and
it starts here India is a democratic
country so you will come across some
data which is you know huge and there
are spaces or objects or anything that
is differentiated it with and you need
to put them in different rows or
different columns so this is the
function r that you need to use to split
the text into different or multiple
columns okay okay the next question can
be very simple one or most widely used
in fact and what is the use of vlookup
and how do we use it so what is this
particular thing in Excel vlookup
function is used for looking up a piece
of information in a table and extracting
some corresponding data or information
so you have some set of values in one
particular column and you want to
retrieve or extract the data
corresponding to that particular column
or a cell in the whole sheet okay so the
syntax is something like this it is you
need to go to one particular cell where
you want the output as and you type the
function
vlookup and you are selecting the value
weight is the cell exactly where you
want the output to be and you are
selecting the table here and the you are
specifying the column index and range
lookup so value this indicates the value
that you have to look for in the First
Column of a table okay and then the
table table basically this refers to the
table from which you have to retrieve a
value we will show this in the example
in the next slide and the column index
column index it provides the column in
the table from which we are to retrieve
a value okay we will specify the column
index which one you are looking for
the next thing is range lookup which is
optional true that if you put true it is
approximate match which is default and
false if it is exact match if you are
looking for the exact match so what is
the use of vlookup and how do we do it
okay so Prime the product related to a
customer name Richard okay you have this
sheet and in this one you want to see
what Richard has bought okay what is a
product that he has bought and you can
do this with the vlooker function okay
so you just go here and you type in the
function vlookup you're naming the
temperature
and first thing is the value it is H4
okay and then the next thing is the
table okay table is A2 because this is
the table okay and you're looking for
customer name Richard
okay and then you are selecting this the
whole column index which is E15 I mean
you are selecting this whole table then
15 okay e 15 you're selecting this and
then the next thing is option which is
give you the uh arrange lookup okay what
it does is it's optional it is you are
looking for an exact value or an
approximate by default it is
approximately so how it performs the
function okay so it gives you the answer
as scanner it goes and lookups for
Richard in this particular it will give
you the output here and the A2 is the
table that it will look for the customer
name and it will search for Richard and
then it will give you the half dash
camera now the next thing will be
vlookup different from lookup function
how different they are we look up lets
the user look for a value in the left
most column of a table so as we've seen
in the example it allows you to look for
data in the leftmost column of the table
and Returns the value in a left to right
okay it starts in left to right well
lookup function lets the user look for
data in a row column and Returns the
value in the another row or column it
will give you the lookup function in the
next workout okay not very easy to use
as compared to the lookup function okay
as we see uh it's a bit complicated when
you compare it to the lookup function
it's quite simple and it is used to
replace the V dookup function okay so
this is the different lookup and vlookup
function now Excel is basically used for
reporting mainly used for reporting to
management you have to extract different
kinds of reports and what are the report
formats that are available in Excel this
is one of the important questions again
for a beginner level and there are three
formats basically compact form outline
form tabular form okay these are the
three formats that are available report
formats that are available in Excel okay
the next question is about a function
which is how does IF function work in
Excel okay the F function in Excel it
actually performs a logical test and you
will give a condition it performs the
test and returns a value if the test
evaluates to true and another value
which you again will specify if the test
result is false okay for instance we
have here a simple example which is
shown in the slide and what we are doing
here is a written record is valid if age
is greater than 20 we have age here
specified and salary is greater than 40
000 else Returns the record is n value
so we are giving two conditions and it
actually checks and evaluates whether
these conditions are met and it will
give you then output whether record is
valid or invalid based on the two
conditions that are specified okay and
F22 axis which is this this column we
are specifying it should be greater than
infinity and G2 to G6 which is the
salary column and we are specifying the
condition to be greater than forty
thousand So based on this two things it
will check and perform if these
conditions are met then it will give the
desired result okay so this is the
function that is used in Excel IF
function okay the next thing is sum IF
function okay again the sumic function
adds the cell values specified by a
given condition or a criteria so you are
giving a condition
and you are actually doing another
position which is performing the
addition okay it will add the cell
values based on a condition again it is
shown here the total sum of salary where
salary is greater than 75 000. again for
example the salary column is G2 to G6
and we are doing a sum F function what
the result will be it will perform the
addition of salaries which are greater
than 75
000 so it will see which values are
greater than 75 000 and then then the
output will be it will be adding these
salaries which are greater than 75
000 okay
now coming to the next slide we will
discuss another important function
counter and we'll find the data
um result based on the data that we have
and the countif function so we have a
slide uh where data here and using the
Kobe data find the number of days in
which the number of deaths in Italy has
been greater than 200 okay it's not uh
shown here for some reason but I will
show you in the Excel sheet okay so this
is the data that we have and we will try
to find the function so we'll use the
countif function and counter function is
again simple counter you are specifying
the
column that is the source that you are
looking for that is G2 the column G and
it is 2. it starts from 2 Row 2 G2 till
G35 triple seven which is the end of the
column and what you are looking for is
Italy you are specifying it in codes
Italy and then the next column that it
will look for is the E column the number
of cases okay here we have the number of
cases e 2 2 again we are specifying the
range and what we're looking for is
number of cases which are more than 20.
so we'll perform this function and it
will show you the output okay I'll show
you to you e XL
so here is the sheet and I will try to
get the answer here and
the
so we are performing count
foreign
[Music]
okay
Algeria
and you specify it in quotes
okay
comma
then what is the next Target that you
are looking for is the column e various
it is mentioning the number of cases
okay so you specify the column range for
the number of cases which is again e and
then
uh
the three five triple seven I mean it's
a basically long list data that you are
looking for and then
you are what is the condition that you
want to know and you have to specify it
in course and what you're looking for is
number of cases which are more than
and you hit enter
okay so it gives you the output as 143
so there are 143 days in which the
number of cases were more than 20. so
let's refine our search further let's
see 30.
and it gives 140
40. so another example that you can take
is let's pick Afghanistan
and quick so for about 19 days that you
will see the number of cases where more
than 30 and this can be done with the
count F function
so the next question is about the pivot
table
so what is a private table it's
basically is a summary of table of the
data set I mean the data that is there
that can be you know multiple number of
rows and columns which has different uh
data that has to be uh that is there in
the reports and you need to analyze
those Trends and you need to create a
report and basically present it to the
management or in a presentation so pivot
table is a summary of table you know
whatever data is there you can put it in
a summarized format they are useful if
you have long rows or column that hold
values you need to drag okay so you have
long list of data and you need to
summarize it and put it in a
presentation or a you need to track the
values so
it's very simple you have to select the
data and then go to the insert Tab and
select pivot table okay and then it will
show up like this and you need to select
the table which is a table or range and
then you need to specify where you want
to put up this private table okay and
it's quite simple and I can show it to
you in one of the examples Okay so
what you need to do is you need to
select this and once you generate our as
we have seen in the previous slide you
need to select this and you need to
select the output where you want to put
the pivot table and then once you do
that you will see something like this
and you need to select these particular
fields and put it in value so it will
for example you need to select the depth
number of death you can just simply say
click this select this drag and drop it
in the values okay so these are the
different fields that can be put up in
the table okay we can show it to you in
the example here
so this is our data and we need to show
it in a pivot table okay select this and
then go to the insert app and click
private table okay
select that and it will show you the
table or the range and now where you
want to put it okay I will put it in the
existing worksheet okay and I'll just
select which color I'll put it here for
example let me show you this and click
ok so this is the table and now you need
to select the fields that you want to
show in the table for example we need to
see the continents the number of cases
as per the continents okay I selected
and put it in the row and we see the
immediately we see it in a table where
you see the number of names of the
continents and now I want to see the
number of cases and I simply select it
and put it across in the value so this
is quite simple and very informative
very short and crisp
form of presenting the data in
a private table okay so this is how it
is being used and it is being presented
we just need to go to the insert tab
private table and it will generate the
table and then you can select the fields
all right
so the next question here is how do we
create a drop down list in Excel this is
particularly useful when you need to
sort a particular data with the drop
down list where a number of different
variables are there and you need to
select one particular uh field and sort
the data so you can do this by creating
a drop down list using the data
validation in presenting the data tab
it's quite simple you select the data
and you go to the data validation tab in
the data and click select data
validation so once you select that it
will ask you to specify a range so you
need to select what data you need to
sort and put a drop down so we need to
select this and click
data validation and you select the list
option which shows you that there is a
different option okay I'll show it
across in the Excel for example what we
have here is some particular data and we
have different variables we need to sort
or put a drop down list so just go to
data as in as said in the slides and go
to data validation and click data
validation now as you click it it will
ask you to data validation settings okay
and in the drop down go and select list
option so it will ask you to specify the
source so when you ask to specify the
source just click this particular column
and click ok so here I'm mentioning the
source is column B okay B 3 t b fourteen
Okay click OK and then it will give you
the option so here you can uh you can
put this in anywhere across the Excel
and click the option okay so this is the
way to drop down using the data
validation option so in the next example
we will see so how do we apply Advanced
filters in Excel we use the advanced
filter option present in the data tab so
this is the scenario wherein you have
multiple set of datas and you need to
sort it and it's it's actually huge data
and you need to sort a particular column
or a field with this criteria and you
can select it and specify the criteria
and specify a range what you want to
select or based on what criteria the
range can be specified and you can just
get it in a single click so this is the
option you have to go to
data tab Advanced and you have to apply
the advanced printer and then you need
to specify the list Trend that is the is
killing the source then the criteria
wherein you specify the criteria present
here I mean you are specifying in this
case we will take an example where we
are trying to sort the data or the
number of cases based on number of
deaths and in a particular country and
we are specifying the output the copy to
field is the output where you will see
the output so I'll show it to you in the
Excel so here we have a spreadsheet
wherein you will see all the uh data
copy data that we have and based on the
countries and the continents and the
number of tests number of cases and so
on okay and that's also has different
fields like the date year and month
alone so so here I am going to sort the
data which is particularly for Europe
and which has that's of more than 200 in
a day so how do we do it go to data
Advanced and the
you need to select copy to another
location okay and this is the list
screen so it's basically given in this
countries okay and the criteria range
you have to specify this so I am going
to select this as my criteria okay and
then I have to put the output in one
particular cell so I need to select it
again let's say here okay
and then I just click ok
see it's quite simple instead of running
through the whole thing
we can just do it with a simple
function okay so it shows me the deaths
which are more than 200 and for which
particular country and for which
particular are continents all right so
this is basically made very simple with
this option the next question is uh you
know you need to highlight some
particular cells using a particular
criteria in this case we are trying to
analyze or highlight those cells where
the total sales is more than five
thousand dollars so what we do is we use
conditional formatting to highlight the
cells based on the criteria it's a very
useful tool in analyzing data and
Visually it helps you know you can have
a look at the data in quick flash you
will see the data and it's quite visible
using the conditional formatting so how
we do that is I will show it to you now
so as said in the slide we have the data
of the sales that is provided to us and
we need to see who has done more sales
which is greater than the five thousand
dollars so just go to home and you need
to say go to conditional formatting so
for that you need to highlight or select
this go home conditional formatting
highlight okay and you have different
options here you select way through that
and you specify the value I here my
criteria is five thousand dollars okay
we can select which color so let's go
for green
okay
see this you will immediately see the
option you don't have to dig or look in
deep into the data and find out which
one is more than 5000 or any particular
value okay so conditional formatting now
moving on to the next question the index
and match function you must be familiar
with the index and match function and
why it is used basically index function
is a very powerful tool wherein you know
you for example you have a table of
planets in our solar system and you want
to get the name of the fourth planet
Mars so you can do it with a formula
using the index function and at the same
time you can use the match function okay
with the match function together you can
play wonders with it okay match function
is another function that is designed to
find the position of an item in a Range
you can use the match function
to get the position of a word or look or
in this case we have a name and we can
use the index and match function to find
the city how we do that is shown here
okay it uh it looks quite complicated
here when you see the formula but I can
show it to you in the Excel and explain
it further okay so here I have and I
want to know where these people are and
where they belong to okay
so
let's see how it goes uh we have seen it
and we use the index function okay
index okay now when I have to specify
the range okay so the range is A2 and it
shows it selects the name and I want to
select it from A2 to
a cell okay E7 sorry
e
called e 7 okay so as you see it
highlights the whole table okay now what
I'm going to do is I want to match it
okay match it with a condition I have I
am specifying a condition a 10 why
because I have to specify a name here
and it will show me the city where he
belongs to okay where it shows is a two
okay if you see A2 it shows the name
through A7 I have to specify the range
here okay not just one name we are
specifying the holding as you see if you
put the values it will show you the
selection
okay as soon and what it should be it
should be the exact match so 0 denotes
the exact match parenthesis is closed
and I am putting another match condition
okay what is this and this will give me
the output what output is okay
B9 okay this is my city v9 is the city
when I'm trying to find from okay and
what it should look for is a column A A1
through
e one okay let you select these this
particular row and
what it should be it should be the exact
match again okay let's see how it goes
it will give you an error because you
haven't put the value here okay so let's
see
foreign
index and match function being used and
it can be asked in frequently in the
interview questions okay the next
question will be uh how to find
duplicate values in a column okay there
are two ways that you can actually do
this and one is basically the very
simple one which is the conditional
formatting and the other one is we have
seen this before count if function okay
how we do that we need to Simply select
the data and go to conditional
formatting and select duplicate values
and it's quite simple and there is
another way which give you the color
coded conditional formatting okay there
is another way with easy count F
function how we do that is again the you
have to put another column and put up a
counter criteria contact function
wherein you see that you are specifying
the range
and the
the value which is being twice or enter
duplicate and you have to put up a
condition I'll show it to you in the
text so here we have the data and I need
to find the duplicate values here so I
just select this and as I said it's
quite simple go to conditional
formatting form and then go to
conditional formatting and select
highlight cell rules and simply go down
and select the duplicate values okay it
will give you which color you want you
can simply select red R anything as you
see the moment you select you will see
the duplicate values highlighted okay so
I just cancel this and there is another
way then count a function so I'll put
another column where it says duplicate
names and I will put up a counter
function here
okay
so let's see how a counter function
works here to check the or find the
duplicate names so as I said I will put
up a formula a function here for the
count f
and we'll drag it to other cells okay
counter and since it's an absolute
reference
I have to put up a dollar symbol
okay my reference here will be H the
column here h
okay
again dollar which is using it as an
absolute reference
colon
through
dollar symbol again
nine okay so it drags till at the whole
attracts till the
all the names okay the H9 all right and
then
what I'll do is I'll put a comma
in y I want to do is I have to select H2
okay this is my criteria I mean it is
repeating twice all right
and
I have to close the parenthesis and if
it is more than one okay so this is my
formula I just put enter
and it should say true so this is the
condition and it is true okay I simply
drag it the whole thing and whether
events is repeated yes it's true Andrew
it's a duplicate entry false me is a
duplicate entry and it says true and as
you see me and events are duplicate
entries so this is how we use the
counter function and the conditional
formatting to sort duplicate entries in
the date
now let's move on to the last question
for The Beginner's level and since we
have duplicate entry there is also a
problem to remove duplicate entries so
how can you remove duplicate values in a
range of cells okay to Simply do that
you can delete the duplicate values in a
column by simply selecting the
highlighted cells and press the delete
button so you go in each column and you
see the duplicate values select it and
delete it okay and this is one tedious
way of doing it and you can also after
deleting the values you can go to the
conditional formatting choose clear
rules to remove the rules from the sheet
so this is one way okay the next thing
is again a simple button that is there
in the data tab that is the is one of
the tools present in the data tab which
is simply called as remove duplicates
it's quite simple and it's there in the
data tools let me show you in the Excel
so here we are and we have this data and
we need to check and remove the
duplicate so as I said go to the data
Tab and simply click on remove do
periods and when you click on it it will
ask you you want to continue or expand
this selection I just say continue with
the current selection and to move
duplicates okay select all click ok to
duplicate entries that were removed
previously we saw that events and
[Music]
weather so that has been removed okay
so that's it for the beginner level and
we'll go to the intermediate level in
the next slides choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
Plus hours of video content for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so here we are at the intermediate level
questions and these are like higher
level or intermediate level compared to
the previous things that we have
discussed with the basic level questions
for the Excel interview so let's move on
to the next thing
and so there's there are some scenarios
where you enter the date or
some dates in particular data sheet and
you need to find out what is the day of
the week okay so you might be asked you
a question how do you find out the day
of a week for a particular date so that
is the function we we have a specific
function and that is the weekday
function to find out the day of the week
or a particular date okay so as we know
these are the seven days of the week and
we just put the function as it says
equals to VT and we need to enter the
column or the area or the cell address
here so weekday is the function and it
will give you the
which which day it is of the V okay we
go as it says one it denotes Sunday
okay and three is again Tuesday okay so
this is the function that is used to
find the day of the week
so now we move on to the next one
and there is a there might be a question
what are the wild cards available in
Excel so basically Excel Sports three
types of wild card which are
Asterix the star it represents any
number of characters it can be used in
different formulas and all like
multiplication and all so it represents
any number of characters okay the next
one next Wild Card is the question mark
it represents one single character okay
you just need to memorize this in the
back of your mind that it represents one
single character okay whereas asterisk
is it represents any number of
characters and the third one which is
rarely used in Excel it is the tilde it
is used to identify a Mobile card
character that is till the Asterix
question marks in the text okay and it
is very rarely used so you need to
memorize these three things that the
there are three types of wild cards we
can see the functions of this in the
later sessions okay the X1 is we have a
question here what is the data
validation illustrate with an example
you might be asked this question and you
have to know what is data values what is
what is it used for and you you should
know how to set up in an example okay
data validation is a feature in Excel
that is used to control what a user can
enter into a cell okay so you have with
the data validation you are not allowing
a data kind of data that should be input
in the cell okay for example you have
the authority by setting up the data
validation that you can enter either a
number or a text or a just a number and
so on okay using the data validation and
where is it available it is in the data
tab okay select data validation option
present under data tools okay and you
just need to select the particular cells
where you want to set up the data Vision
I'll show it to you in an example so
this is how it looks like you just need
to go to data tools and click on data
validation and it will show you and you
have the options here allow and if you
click on the drop down you will see
different options like I will show it to
you in the example here okay
for this particular thing if I want you
know a this column should have only
names and it should have if you insert a
number you will be thrown with an error
okay you will get an error message
saying that this is not a valid option
okay so there are some columns where you
have to put only names or you have to
put only number so you can set this up
with the data validation
technique okay you just allow it or
customize it as per your requirement so
this is how it looks like when you set
up another so here we have set up a data
validation saying that it should not
allow you to put any text okay so you
will get an error when you put a number
here the value does not match data
validation restrictions defined for this
cell okay so here as an example I have
some data where I am putting the names
here and I'll put the salary here I want
to make sure that you know we cannot
enter any numbers here okay it should be
only text
should have only name so how do I
perform that how do I restrict any user
to
that they should not be able to enter
any number and you should only enter the
text okay so there is a function okay
you just need to go to data validation
click data validation and here in the
setting I'll go to custom there are
different options here you can you can
choose whole numbers decimal list date
time so your these are the option and I
go to custom and I am giving a
particular formula here okay what is
that it should be only text okay so it's
a simple thing it should be text and I
need to define the range okay so how
I'll Define the ring I just select this
okay and
select the range okay
so I have selected the range here and if
you go to input message and error alert
you can customize it and here we are
taking the default one and this is the
input message if you want to set or
customize something okay so let's see
how it works okay I have said this and
then I try to put a number here and it
throws me an error the value you entered
is not variant because we have set a
restriction a user has restricted value
that can be entered into the cell so
this is how the data validation work
okay the next thing is you will be given
a situation wherein you have to uh you
will be given data and you have to
perform a function like in this example
we are taking a condition where you will
have data and you have to specify the
result based on the data you have to
formulate it okay so given below is a
student table write a function to add
password fail to the results column
based on the following criteria you will
be given a criteria so this is the
student table you are giving the student
names marks and attendance and then
based on that you will have to specify a
next a formula wherein you will see the
result okay based on the past student
data you have to put a pass fail results
in the column based on the following
criteria what is the criteria and for
example here in this example what
they're saying is you have to say that
the student is passed if his marks is
more than 60 and the attendance is more
than 75 percent okay so how we perform
this function as it says you have to use
the IF function and check with the hand
condition to fill the results column
okay so let's see this in the example
here
so here is the example and we will
perform the
IF function and check with the and
function so how we do that is here okay
so I have to put the IF function here
okay and check with the and function
okay and I have to specify the
conditions I have to subscribe where it
should see the or check the conditions
okay so we are checking the conditions
here and the marks should be in row I
mean the column U and it starts with u5
so let's see U 5 okay it will
immediately go to column U and 5 row
five okay and then what is the condition
we are satisfying here it should be
greater than 60 okay and the other
condition is
uh the column V that is the attendance
column okay and what is the condition we
are specifying V 5 should be greater
than
75 okay
and we just close this conditions with
the parenthesis and now we have to
specify the result whether it is pass or
fail
pass
comma in quotes again
three okay so let's see how this works
okay
okay see this works okay the marks is 50
and attendance is greater than 80. so he
is failed because he has marks of 50 his
attendance must be more than 75 but yes
he is he has not scored marks more than
60. so we drag the same formula to the
whole thing and you will see the result
okay this is quite simple and you will
see this
formula and using the if and
check and check with and condition okay
now moving on to the next question you
might be asked to you know this is
simple function wherein you can you'll
be asked to calculate your age in years
from the current date okay so how we do
that there is a particular function and
it's very simple use the ear Frac or
dated IF function to return the number
of whole days between start date and the
ended so you specify a start date which
will be uh today's date and the I mean
the birthday and then the end day will
be today's day for example okay and you
will get to know the age using the year
Frac function and rated F function okay
so here is a small example and this is
how we use the ear Frac function okay
you specify this function and then
specify the inputs that is the today's
date and the date of birth and the
today's date okay and this is one of the
ways to get it and there is also gated F
okay this again it is dated a function
and you specify the input cells okay so
let me show you an example for the same
so here we are and we have today's date
that is the fourth of May and date
report for anything it should be so I
will specify the EF right now okay
equals
here right okay
and then I should as soon as you enter
you specify the start date and the end
date okay and I will specify the start
date as today's date let's fix the
column and then I put the comma
and then the end date should be this
thing okay and just close it and it will
give you the
age
okay so this is the age for example if
you want to find out my age I don't want
to reveal my birthday but it's okay
okay
let's see if it calculates
I'm 32 years old okay all right so this
is one of the ways and similarly you can
use the dated IF function shown in the
example all right now moving on to the
next question you have a nested if
statements this is very important and
you will definitely be coming across
this question how are nested if
statements used in Excel what are nested
statements the IF function can be nested
I mean it can be Loop when we have
multiple conditions to meet okay it can
be nested the false value is replaced by
another IF function okay you have
specified some condition and you are
putting up a condition and if that
condition is not there or not met then
if it will be replaced with another
IF function so the syntax will be like
this below is an example so we actually
we use two if statements in conjunction
okay so here is an example here we are
specifying a condition wherein you know
uh the result is excellent if it is more
than 80 and if it is less than 16 it is
bad or average so this is very simple
you are perform one if condition and if
that is not met
it will go for the next if condition so
we are nesting two if conditions we are
joining two if statements okay uh I'll
show the same example here in the Excel
so here we are we have some data and the
students and their Mars okay and we are
specifying a condition wherein if the
result or marks are more than 80 the
result is excellent and if it is less
than 60 it is bad or average okay so how
we get this is we use two if conditions
if statements so uh as we have seen it
if
if now the first condition is our source
or the source is B2 okay so B
and what I am specifying is it should be
greater than
80. all right I just close this and the
result should be excellent okay
foreign
excellent if it is more than 80 and if
this condition is not met it will go to
the next if statement okay we are
nesting another if statement what is the
condition here for the next statement it
will check D2 is
less than or equal to 60 you can specify
any marks all right so if it is less
than 60 it should give the result as bad
or average okay
specify anything and you
okay and just close the double
parenthesis so let's see how it works
okay see
it looks like this
now let's pull up the same formula the
for the other results okay
see if it is more than 90 it is 90 it is
excellent so it is checking the first
thing if it is greater than 80 it is
excellent okay and now in this case for
Mark it is bad why because it will first
see whether it's excellent or not if it
is not excellent then it will check the
other condition if it is less than 60 it
will give you the I have a bad result
all right and similarly so on for the
other
months all right so this is how we use
the nested if statements you are adding
two if statement the first condition and
the second condition with another if
statement okay okay when it comes to
excel it is basically involves a lot of
data and a lot of data to be analyzed
and we have some powerful tools which
are used in Excel to analyze the data
one such uh important tool is
descriptive statistics
that is used to analyze the data so we
might come across a question and you
will be given a data or a table and you
need to find the descriptive statistics
of the columns using data analysis too
okay so you will be given us maybe for
example anything and you will have a lot
of data you have to use the descriptive
statistics option in Excel for the data
analysis okay how you do that is you
have to add a pack okay you should be
knowing that you need to add a path
which is called the analysis tool pack
which you go to file options and then
just click on the add-on and select the
analysis tool pack click Excel add-in
and just click go and it will add the
option and then when you select the data
you have to go to the click on the data
analysis option which will be which will
show up when you select the Addle or
when you add the add-on okay then you
need to select the descriptive
statistics what we need to do is we need
to analyze this data and it will show
you the values like mean and the you can
also customize you can you see you have
this data and for you to check each and
every row and find the mean the smallest
the
a maximum number and things like that so
this can be easily done using the
descriptive statistics for the data
analysis uh I'll show the same thing in
the Excel how it can be performed so
here we are and I'll show you first how
to add the
option to it okay go to add and select
analysis tool pack as shown in the slide
and you need to click go if you just
click OK it will not add so just click
go and then you need to select analysis
tool pack okay it will give you these
are the different options uh for now we
are selecting analysis tool pack and
just click OK as soon as you do that you
will see the data analysis this option
gets enabled when you add that pack so
this is the data that you have you need
to find or analyze using the descriptive
statistics
so as you see it
click data analysis and click select
descriptive statistics okay and it will
show up the option like this and you
need to select the input range okay for
some reason it's already there and if
you want me to show I will show it to
you across you have to select the whole
update
okay this is my input range you need to
select this labels in the first row so
that you know it doesn't take the first
row okay I'll show
okay and now I'm putting the output in
another worksheet okay you can specify
or you can press by a new worksheet and
these are the options that you can
select so you can either you are getting
a summary statistics which is the
default and you can select the
confidence level that is the mean value
and you can set it up by whatever value
percentage you want and you are
selecting the largest one and the
smallest number so all these data will
get analyzed and it will open up in a
new sheet and just click OK and you will
see this so these are the if you see
this is our data paid organic social and
revenue so this is uh
okay
let's make it more precise
okay so with a single click yeah all our
data is analyzed okay this is the mean
value and this is the minimum is zero
maximum is so you can set this is the
total and the number of count is 1000 so
you don't need to scroll down and check
what is the largest amount that is paid
so this is the largest amount for the
complete okay and so so on so before the
largest revenue generated all these
things are generated with a descriptive
analysis okay descriptive statistics
with the data analysis too so the next
question is about a pivot table and this
is more refined or more advanced
compared to the last one that we
discussed in the beginner level so here
you are asked to create a pivot table to
find the total cases in each country
belonging to their respective continents
you are giving you are being asked to
put up a table or pivot table with two
variables basically each country and
their respective continent so again we
have the same data and we need to set up
a pivot table which shows the continents
and the countries with the respective
continents the number of cases okay so
let's see how we get this in the example
so here we are we have the same data
that shows the days months year cases
countries
and there are consonants okay
continents here and so on okay so I'm
I'll go to the insert Tab and select the
pivot table okay again the same thing I
will be asked to enter a input range
okay so I select this
and since it's huge I'll just
put the number to be 777
okay let's assume
now this is our input data and where you
want the output to be it's already
selected you can put it anywhere I am
putting it here okay just click OK and
it will give you the option to select
the fields now what we want is number of
cases okay which will show you the value
and the countries and territories there
respective continents so okay so this is
how it looks like and we have to check
now it is asking us to find the
countries Okay so
with their respective continents you see
this you see Africa as a continent and
you will see
okay
you will see Africa
if you just remove this you will see the
number of on I mean the cases with the
respective continents and if you want to
include these countries territories
where their respective continents you
will see as such if you just expand this
you will see the countries that are
having the cases in the continent Africa
okay so country wise sorted with the
continents okay this is the other
Advanced step to get the data or show
the data in the pivot table okay another
question that you might be asked this is
a basic and we have already seen this in
the previous example that I have shown
how do you provide the dynamic range in
data source of a pivot table you have to
select a particular data source in your
input table for to show up in the pivot
table so you have to select the input
range but how do you create or how do
you create a provide a dynamic range in
this data source so just need to create
a name table to provide a dynamic range
so where is the data of your table so as
we have seen in the previous example you
will be able to select the input range
and you just need to put this value any
number so that you know it will pick up
the dynamic range for your input source
for the tape okay so now we move on to
the next one and this is about about the
pivot table again is it possible to
create pivot table using multiple
sources of data yes
yes you can create a pivot table from
multiple worksheets sometimes you will
have different data in different sheets
can you create a pivot table for all the
worksheet in a single pivot table yes
you can but there is a condition there
should be a common Row in both the table
so you cannot have different types of
data there should be a common row okay
so then only it will act as a primary
key for the first table and the foreign
key for the second table okay so this is
something that you have to remember and
you need to create a relationship
between the tables and then build the
pivot table so you have to analyze what
kind of data it is it should have a
common Row in both the tables on both
the sheets and then you have to
establish a relationship between this
table and then build the table okay
there is a wizard for that well
see that later now let's move on to the
next question so the next question is
again you know with the pivot table uh
wherein you I will be asked to further
refine or you know refine your search
and show it in the data so here we have
with the code data example again you
will be asked to create a pivot table to
find the top three countries from each
continent based on the total cases using
the coveted again and we have done this
before we have created a preview table
for this and we need to further refine
it showing the top three countries with
the number of cases and I will show that
same thing in the Excel and we already
have created a table and we'll refine it
further to show the top three countries
which are having the
highest number of accounts in the
respective context so here we are we
have the table uh already with us and I
just click on the
show field list it will show me the
countries and territories what we are
asked is you know to show the countries
with the top three that is number of
cases
so you just need to go here and you need
to select the value filter there is a
filter which you can select with the
value and now I select top 10 and what I
need is top three it's very simple and
you just need to know these themes okay
and based on the sum of cases okay this
is our field already there just click OK
and it will show you the top three
countries so it's quite simple and it is
very important to know this field and
how you play with the value of the
filters for each particular uh field in
the pivot table so it shows you these
things all right now you can refine it
further with the continents and all okay
so different continents and you can see
this so you go there and there is a
value filter you can set up all right we
have set up a value filter okay
okay now there is another one
how do you create a column in a pivot
table okay like you will be given a
situation where you need to add one more
column and show it in the pivot table
with a particular calculation or with
the particular value and you have you
don't have that actual value in your
data but you have to calculate it and
show it across in the table so there is
another option which is called pivot
table analyze and you need to create a
calculated field from pivot table
analyze option so when you go to your
table and then go to pivot table analyze
you will see the option to add a
calculated field okay just go there and
click select calculated field and you
need to Define so in this example we are
going to Define another column where we
calculate the bonus of the sales and
there is a particular Formula E formula
is you put an if and statement and then
you calculate the formula you specify
what is the bonus and what is the way
that you're calculating the bonus and it
will particularly add it another column
to your table so let's see how we do
that in the table it so here we are we
have this table and I have inserted a
pivot table and I'm putting it in
output here
okay
and then you will get the table okay now
you need to select the
customer name
and the unit Source unit price sales
okay so we'll add another column to it
how we do that is this
go to pivot table tools and then you go
to analyze okay
click on field items and set okay you
need to select calculated field here
select that and we are defining a new
field here which is the bonus
bonus and as I said we will put up a
formula for this and we will Define it
how we calculate the bonus okay and then
hit and statement which we have seen
before how we
put up a
and if and statement okay now I'm going
to say it has
like the sales to my sales should be
I'll specify a condition how they will
calculate the bonus if sales is greater
than 4000
and the unit sold okay I am trying to
put it as the unit switch also depends
on the units sold
is greater than thousand okay for
example let's say a thousand a person
who is uh
able to do a sales of thousand four
thousand and the unit sold should be
more than thousand and the sales what is
this the bonus will be
sales
into that is the amount of sales he has
done
into five percent okay let's say five
percent bonus
and
sales
yeah
is
if it is two percent okay
okay
we are adding this field bonus click add
okay so we have added this and we have
put up a calculation for the formula and
you will see this signal so this is
simple way of adding the column to your
existing data and we are doing the
calculations and showing it up okay so
this is one way go to pivot table
analyze and field
item sensors you can select this option
and add it okay you can customize this
as I said with adding different fields
this is pretty handy in analyzing the
data which does not exist in the table
and you add some value to your pivot
table okay
the next question will be about slicer
you must be familiar with what a slicer
is in a pivot table and how do you use
it for the purpose of using it and how
do you put up a slider in the pivot
table so how does a slicer work
basically slicers are used to further
filter data in the pivot table suppose
you already have some data and it's for
ease that you can do it by just adding a
slicer you can select particular uh
data in or a field and you can see the
output for that particular field that
you have chosen in the slicer okay so
it's very simple go to the insert Tab
and select slicer under printers okay
and then it will be like this okay and
here if for example you see this is our
period table we have added two slicers
to filter our table that is month and
countries and territory so this will be
the general pivot table that looks like
and we haven't added another two slices
that is month and Country so if you go
for example if you want to see what is
the
number of cases and some of the deaths
for a particular month and for a
particular country you can just do it by
a single click and it will show that
particular data only in the table let's
see and do this in our Excel okay
so there is a table uh pivot table
already created for this and I want to
add a slicer so how do I go ahead and do
this is I go to the
options and insert slicing okay at the
moment you click on it you will see what
are the options that you want to add you
can select different fields and
select the slice input uh for this
example we are choosing month
okay this is one of our sliders you can
just put it here
adjacent to the and again
this will be our slider okay
let's add another slicer here
okay
and this will be the countries and
territories okay
click on that and you will see two
simple badges here that you can choose
from so if I want to know in the month
of Feb how many number of cases were
there for particular let's see the
moment I choose the month it will show
that particular number of the
corresponding table for the whole and
now I want to further refine it to a
particular country so for example
Australia okay so there were total
number of 18 cases and zero deaths at
the same time if I go for Algeria it is
like this so
as you see
it goes like this okay so this is one of
the very important tool that you can use
to show the data in a much simplified
Manner and ease
okay so the next question is about the
pivot table again what is the percentage
of contribution of each country in
confidence to the 30 cases again the
same example product code the kovid one
in this time we want to show the output
as the percentage of contribution for
each country and continuance to the
totally cases so we have the same data
and we generate a pivot table and we
should show it as the sum of the cases
to be percentage okay and this is how we
do it
this is our
data and I'm going to create a pivot
table for this
okay
so it shows the table and here I have to
show what is the fields that we need to
select okay first is we are just
selecting the cases and the countries
and territories Okay so
cases to be the values okay
okay so this is how it looks like
now when I see
okay
see they chose the number of cases now
if I just want to refine it further and
see it as number of
percentage percentage as the number of
cases okay so how I do it show field
list I go here and I go to Value field
settings okay then
again
number format show the value as okay
sorry
show the value as you need to select
this thing
percentage of grand total and then just
click okay
and you will see
this to be the percentage so it shows
the data in the form of percentage okay
this is very simple and you just need to
remember as we have seen before
field and then value field settings okay
this is the thing that you need to check
okay Grant percentage there are other
options also and you can select from
whatever you want to in this case we are
showing it to be the percentage okay
okay guys now the next question is about
a very important aspect of presentation
when we come to favorite charts how do
you create a favorite chart in pivot
tables this is very
basic or very you know important aspect
of pivot tables that you can represent
data in a in the form of a chart and
there are different types of charts
which I'll show it to you in the uh
example okay so we have a data here and
we want to show it as in and right now
it is in a table at home okay we have
put up a pivot table for this and now if
the same thing can be put up in a pivot
chart okay so what you need to do is go
to the insert Tab and select the pivot
chart it depends on different versions
of excel that you have different uh
forms or different buttons so I will
show it across to you and this is how it
looks like okay it's very simple it can
be a pie chart it can be a bar chart it
can be different forms and we can see
that in the example here okay so let's
go to the example and
so we have the pivot tables generated
here already what you need to do is you
need to select the table and go to
insert and
see the options there are there is a
column chart there is a line chart there
is Pi Bar area scattered and other parts
okay there are different forms okay so
right now what we do is we will select
the column chart here okay you need to
select the pivot table and click on the
column chart again there are different
forms which can be seen in some time now
so this is the basic form okay and it
will show you the countries I mean the
and it will show it as a form of a chart
okay again you can change the chart type
you can change it to Pi okay this
personally is very good in presenting or
doing presentation and you can select
different forms different styles okay
I'll also show you the percentage
so this is one form of presenting your
table into a chart okay again bar type
is also there
so this won't suit here in our example
there are different ones I'm just
showing it to you as how it looks like
so depending on your I mean the
aesthetic you can see and select what
kind of chart is best suitable okay
so this is how you put up a pivot chart
in pivot tables okay
so this is when last for the
intermediate level and what are macros
in Excel create a macro to automate a
task basically you have some daily tasks
that you perform in Excel okay and
you can do this with quite ease using
the macros okay it basically is a
program that resides within the Excel
file and it is used to automate tasks in
Excel some daily tasks that you run like
run when you come across in any data and
you have to scrub that data and you do
some daily routines and by removing some
columns or adding some formulas and you
know doing some adding some colors and
changing the fonts or be it anything
that you perform and you have to do a
repetitive task so all that can be done
by recording a macro and this is what
macro is used for in Excel so how you
capture those steps in Excel is through
a macro to record a macro you can either
go to the developer tab in the Excel and
click on record manager or you can use
or access it from The View tab Okay so
these are the uh ways to access macros
okay just go to the developer tab and
click record macro when you know when
you click record macro it will record
the steps that you are performing in
each step and it will capture that and
you can save that it is like a daily
routine that you run and you can do all
these multiple steps maybe n number of
steps within a single click by running
that macro later on okay so do you
record a macro and run that okay you do
it through the developer tab go to
developer tab and click record macro and
it records all the steps that you are
performing okay you need to name it and
you just need to perform the actions and
it will record the macro and you just
save it later on whenever you come
across the same daily task that you run
you can just click it by running that
macro okay
so in a single click it will perform all
the actions that you have done or steps
that you have performed on that
particular Excel sheet or any other
Excel sheet okay this is very handy when
you have similar data and you do the
similar task each day okay so this ends
the intermediate level and in the next
slides we will see the advanced level so
now we discuss the advanced level uh
interview questions for Excel and when
it comes to the advanced level you will
come across definitely you will be asked
about what if analysis how does it work
how does it how does what-if analysis
work in Excel so what if analysis as the
name suggests you have to have
an analysis done okay with the help of
different complex mathematical
calculations like formulas and using
different formulas and calculations you
can experiment with the data and you can
analyze if this particular input changes
what will be the scenario how will your
output turn out to be so as you can see
it is about different variables to see
how your changes would affect the
outcome of a situation so this is what
what if analysis is and the same thing
can be done with Excel and how it is
done is you need to go to the data Tab
and click on the what-if analysis under
forecast okay so there are three options
in
one is the scenario manager goal seek
and the data table so these are the
three situation or three tools which are
available in the what-if analysis in the
data tab okay so goal C is basically for
reverse calculations okay and you have
some idea you have some set goal in mind
and you have certain variables and what
you need to do and what you need to
achieve to have certain set goals okay
you have you will set a value for the
goal and with the goal seek option you
can get to know what value you have to
achieve to come to that level okay so
this is what goal seek is it is one of
the simplest sensitivity analysis tool
and so for example you know that you
know a single outcome you would like to
achieve like you have a set goal that
you have to achieve this particular
grade okay and the go seek feature in
Excel allows you to arrive to that goal
by mathematically adjusting a single
variable within that equation so you set
the goal and you will do the what if
analysis goal seek uh option to know
what you have to do or what you have to
achieve for the set goal
the next option is the data table and it
is basically used for sensitivity
analysis okay so in this scenario
you the data tables allow the adjustment
of only one or two variables within a
data set but each variable can have
unlimited number of possible values okay
so basically they are used for side by
side comparisons and it makes it very
easy to read the scenarios okay one but
you need to set up the data table
correctly okay and what you do is you
give the input in the table and then you
set up the formula and for instance you
need to calculate the monthly payments
for a loan okay you provide the
principal amount like whatever amount
you are taking 2 lakhs three lakhs and
you set the interest rate in a formula
okay and you set the term in and then
you need to provide different uh input
options like what loan amount that
you're taking and you set the formula
and go to data table and I mean go to
what if analysis and select the data
table table stretches across and then
you will see the monthly payment options
or the monthly Emi that you can
calculate there are different uh things
that you can calculate you can calculate
the Target or the sales bonus or things
like that okay giving different
scenarios in the variables okay but you
need to set up a data table it might be
a little challenging but yes it is a
very powerful tool okay so the next one
is the scenario manager it is a bit more
complicated compared to the other two
but then it is uh more advanced than
Google seek as it allows you the uh to
adjust the multiple variables at the
same time okay
and this is very complicated compared to
the other two and it is even I mean it
gives more better output when it
compares to the other two what-if
analysis tools
so here when you go to what if analysis
and the scenario manager you have to
select the data and provide different
scenarios that is different values for
each scenario and then it will create a
it will analyze calculate and create
different scenarios okay so it becomes
very easy for you to analyze what if you
are changing the value of your interest
amount or the
term of loan or if your targets like
monthly targets or an yearly targets and
things like that and you just have to uh
see what the scenario will be when you
set this particular value
for a
table or for data whatever targets that
you need to set you can use this what-if
analysis in Excel for the different
scenarios and different calculations
okay these are very powerful tools and
you need to know this
now as we move on to the next one you
might be asked what is the difference
between a function and a subroutine in a
VBA okay
even though these two are used quite
frequently there is a
pretty much different from each other
okay so a function always returns a
value of the task it is performing okay
so when you are writing a module you
will have a function when you have a
function it will always give you a value
okay for example you are performing an
addition it using the function it will
give you a value for sure whereas
subroutine it does not return a value of
the task it is performing functions are
called by a variable okay you can set up
a variable and you can call the function
okay whereas subroutines can be recalled
from anywhere in the program in multiple
times okay in many different ways you
can recall a subroutine like we have
seen we write a subroutine and we put up
a button and we can when you click the
button it will recall the subroutine
functions are called by variable okay
you have to set up a variable and when
you enter it it will come okay functions
are used directly in spreadsheet as
formulas whereas Subs cannot be used
directly in spreadsheets as formula okay
this is very important difference and
the next thing is the functions can be
used to perform repetitive tasks and
return a value whereas users must insert
a value in the desired cell before
getting the result of the sub so this is
particularly limited okay whereas
functions can be used to perform
different repetitive tasks and return a
value user input is not required whereas
if you see the subroutines user must
insert a value okay in the desired cell
that way in a particular cell which is
defined in the subroutine to getting the
desired result okay so these are the
differences between functions and
subroutines now the next one is what is
the difference between this workbook and
active workbook in vda so when you work
on modules and different Excel
spreadsheets and workbooks you will have
these different workbooks open and there
is a particular difference and you might
be asked what is the difference between
this workbook and active workbook so as
the name suggests this workbook refers
to the name of the workbook where the
code is actually running from okay you
are running a code VBA code and it is
the actual workbook where you are
running the code from and that is this
workbook okay and you have multiple
spreadsheets open and you are working on
particular suppose for example you are
working on a sheet X okay and you active
workbook is the workbook that is
currently active from the different open
verbs you have different open workbooks
but you are working on one particular
workbook and that is called the active
workbook so this workbook is the
reference to the name of the workbook
where the code is actually written
whereas active workbook is the one one
that is currently open currently active
Okay so this is the difference between
this workbook and the active workbook in
VBA as shown in the example this is a
simple sub that is written a code that
can be written to find out which
workbook is the uh it which workbook is
the uh this workbook in the VBA and the
active web processor okay so this is a
simple thing that you can run to
determine okay it shows the active
workbook and the this workbook okay so
as we move on to the next one
so this is the question how will you
pass arguments to a PBF function okay
there are two ways basically arguments
can be passed to a VBA function as a
value or as a reference so this is an
example that you can see it is by
reference the key word for this is by
reference okay so when you are pressing
an argument by reference the keyword
should be by r e f whereas by value
you're specifying a value and the
keyword is by v a l value okay so these
are the two ways that you can pass an
argument in VBA
so when you pass an argument by
reference in a procedure the variable
itself okay the variable itself is
accessed by a procedure and it is to the
location or the address in the memory
okay the value of the variable is
changed permanently by the procedure in
this case all right okay so to pass an
argument by reference you should use
buyer that is the keyword before the
argument okay so in this example it is
clearly shown what is the keyword that
is being used okay and by reference is
the default in the VBA unless you
specify something else which in this
case is by value okay and as I said the
keyword for buy value passing the
argument y value is by b a l okay so
when you set the keyword by Van
the variable what happens is the by
value argument function or argument
uh is passed through by value okay the
number function is called here which
means it assigns a value to the variable
X here okay because the variable was
passed by value in the function any
change to the value okay any change to
the value of the variable is only the
current function so it ends after it
performs the function okay then it
revert backs to the value when it is
declared again where it is set to zero
so if the variable has been passed by
referencing the function then the
variable would have permanently assumed
the new assigned value so this is the
basic Difference by reference and by
value
so now we move on to the next one so
there might be a question that you will
be asked that how do you find the last
row or a column in a VBA okay so to find
a last row sometimes you have long list
of uh data and it has like
the number of rows and N number of
columns so instead of scrolling down all
together to find the
last row you can use this VBA code you
can write this code it's a very simple
one and it will give you the last row
you will find the last row with the
single click okay let's see it in the
VBA so here I have a sheet which you
know it has long list of uh rows and
instead of scrolling down I can just
find out the last row with this
VBA code okay I just click on this and
as seen in the slideshow I have just
return it and you will see the if you
just run it and you will see the number
of rows it will give you the last row in
the sheet okay similarly we can do this
for the column as well okay in case if
you have long list of large number of
columns instead of scrolling right you
can just uh run this VBA and you can see
you can know the
last number call okay number of columns
so as we've seen in the last row now
we'll see the code for the finding the
last column is the same thing uh instead
of row you will see it as column all
right and it will when you run it you
will get the it will give you the last
column okay
here we wrap up Excel full course if you
like this video consider subscribing to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply learn
thanks for watching
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here